foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Laughter]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
the knights one of them was in the
corner we can refresh you on how we got
as he deploys his Queen on the nice A4
Square both sides develop their Knights
to G3 and G6 ikaro grabs space on the
king side with this Dutch move F5 then
developing his Bishop to E7 nepo
continues to expand on the queen side
with B5 sort of delaying the development
of his Bishops an interesting approach
and goes after the pawn on A7 clearly
Robert nepo has not had his breakfast
today because all he cares about is
winning that A7 pawn and all Nick Haro
cares about is going for Checkmate on
the king side look at this F4 the Knight
drops back to E2 we have a trade on E3
and hecaro's last move was C7 C6 adding
a little bit of dynamite a little nasty
on the queen side and this is the
current position with gandapanishi to
move it's move 11. yeah the wanna move
C6 is because the point everyone is that
if white were to take this Pawn on C6
that Knight on d8 that's sitting at home
will jump out to C6 protect that weak A7
pawn and all is looking better in
Black's camp now Donna something that's
easy to forget about is that white can
still castle kingside and likely will
that will just take some time you need
to move your knight out of E2 develop
your Bishop Knight D4 is a good start
once the bishop develops to a square
like D3 then white can in fact Castle
kingside so that would protect the F2
Pawn although it might leave the G2 Pawn
a little bit vulnerable down the line
and black could try to exploit that with
a well-timed knight Sally to H4 that
Queen on A8 don't fall asleep on the
long sort of diagonal moves in Fisher
random robber we have seen so many
blunders where players Miss moves and
ideas because of how unconventional they
are in the context of regular chess so
castles certainly does not solve all of
White's problems but the ball is now in
Hikaru nakamura's Court he has to decide
what to do with this C6 Pawn he has to
take action because if you don't do
anything then White's going to take on
C6 and permanently ruin Black's entire
Queen side structure so my guess is that
Hikaru is either going to take on B5 or
play C5 which of these moves is your
instinct point to Robert oh gosh really
tough call and I'm just also looking at
the clock of Yonder Palm she up uh going
on four minutes typical Yanda Palm oh
actually starts even in this game my
apologies I was looking at the time in a
different game but here we see that the
C Pawn has its choice I do think that
um C5 makes sense we actually have the
wrong camera so I think from Reykjavik
we have Nordy Beck Abdus atarov and
Magnus Carlson uh camera so we would
like to switch to uh hikaranaka Yanda
Palm machine when we have a moment but I
think you're right Donya it's all about
the C Pawn right now and I would go with
C5 I think it looks more in the style of
Hikaru having Dynamic chances and look
at that
listen I was gonna say I'm gonna go see
takes B5 precisely because Robert Hess
would go C5 that's literally my only
motivation I did no other thinking
C5 Knight F3 is on the board but I
interrupted you explain how would you
follow this up Bishop F6
I like Bishop F6 with the pin I mean if
you're getting Ultra defensive at some
point you might play them like Rook B7 I
don't like the look of that so I think
this position is much more in hikaru's
style where he's getting his pieces
active he has this Pawn mass in the
center a C D and E Pawn you might see D7
D5 D5 to D4 and the position will
explode open and only one side has a
king in the center that's yonda Palm
she's King sitting in the middle of the
board and that can fall victim to a
swift attack it most certainly can and
right now of course Yana has to defend
this night on C3 which is hanging with a
fork Bishop B2 looks a lot more natural
to my eyes than Bishop D2 Bishop D2
doesn't actually solve the pin Rook to
A3 by yacht as he tries to take care of
everything in one fell super Robert the
obvious drawback of this move to me is
that you are relinquishing the threat of
Queen takes A7 had you played Bishop B2
Hikaru would have had to address the
threat of Queen takes A7 which not only
wins the pawn but in this particular
instance forces the queen trade now
Hikaru can take care of business in the
center and there's your D5 movements
already on the board
right and just to put this show and
Bishop E2 was quickly played it looks
like uh oh no sorry not in this one in
uh I'm getting lost between games you
know we have uh some still have four
matches going on let's uh set the table
for everybody this is the championship
match this is where our attention is
going to be Yonder Palms Hikaru Nakamura
but Magnus Carlson is still playing
against noribbeck Abdul sitarov we have
fedosev taking on Wesley so we also have
Matthias bluebaum taking on kirovar
Stein gretarsen for the different prize
fund uh in different places so that is
happening all at once uh our eyes are
darting from place to place but it's
focusing in on this position Dania
um Queen takes A7 not possible as you
highlighted because the Knight on C3 is
loose The Rook is uh going into overtime
protecting the queen and the Knight
unfortunately you can't defend both the
same time this position so that just
means that A7 is defended tactically now
what I was going to add is that this
move D5 takes away the E4 Square from
the Knight that Knight could move it can
move because the Rook left the pin but
now it has nowhere good to go so D5 is
just such a good move expanding in the
center potentially even going up to D4
but taking away vital squares from
White's pieces and on top of that you've
opened up the very kind of nice
defensive possibility of Shifting The
Rook up to F7 which does the exact same
thing as Rook B7 but without the
attendant awkwardness right Rook B7
blocks and the queen and the bishop Rook
F7 is a very unobtrusive kind of nicely
coordinated defensive move and once you
take away the pressure on A7 you know
that begs the question okay well Jan
he's done all of this stuff on the queen
side he's gotten this piece of City a
file what does he really have to show
for it because Hikaru has to show for
his play is excellent central control
good piece coordination what does Yana
have to compensate for that on the queen
side I kind of like Black's position and
now Bishop P2 is indeed played on this
board
yeah Bishop E2 uh I can't say I
predicted it it was just a mistake
looking a different game but Bishop E2
has been played now white can Castle so
that's the good news the bad news is
even if white does Castle next turn
putting the King on G1 sliding The Rook
to F1 black still has this monstrous
Center and this Pawn on A7 can be
defended by a move like Rook F7 or even
Rook B7 Rook B sounds a little bit
awkward for the moment but if that Rook
on B8 lands on F7 Donya you can see the
making of a king side attack just
swinging over to the other side of the
board
that's a really interesting point the
one thing I would caution against is
playing e52 quickly I think a lot of
players would be tempted by this move
and the reason that it doesn't work
isn't because of Queen takes A7 then
black intake and play E4 but rather
because of Knight takes D5 poking holes
in black center and queen takes D5 meets
with Bishop C4 so Hikaru has to play a
lot more methodically than that that is
precisely what he does I stand corrected
Rook B7 is on the board and I think he
is heading precisely for the F7 Square
piling the pieces up and preparing for a
king side attack
there is a way this turns from
potentially tactical into strategic the
move E3 to E4 for Yonder Palm machine
because if black responds with a very
natural D5 to D4 that seeds control of
all of the light squares so you have to
be very careful if you're Hikaru because
that could just be a long-term just
Devastation waiting to happen as you
give up literally all the light squares
yeah and then we mentioned that the
Knight doesn't have too many good
squares well it can drop back to B1 but
not as a final destination rather on
route to this juicy outpost on C4 so I'm
totally with you I think E4 is one of
White's kind of biggest Assets in this
position Depot starts by castle and King
side so now his King is safe and the
sort of center of the battle has I think
now shifted to the center I think we are
very likely going to see something like
E4 uh perhaps even on the next move
yeah now it looks like a must for Jan
because as you look across his pieces
the bishop on C1 not in a promising spot
black has good control with the C5 and
D5 pawns so E4 is borderline pre-movable
honestly Dania like that I I don't think
black has a move that will stop E4 from
being played if you play Knight to F7 or
Rook to F7 E4 still seems like the
logical reply so Queen B8 played now E4
a little bit less tempting because that
Knight on G6 can land in the F4 Square I
still think it's a viable option and I
think we're yeah I'm on the same page
there you have to calculate Knight F4 I
will just add that an additional benefit
of Queen ba is that it uh prevents this
nasty idea of B5 B6 had black rushed
Rook F7 he would have had to reckon with
this additional resource of B6 probably
not that impressive but it's definitely
annoying and Hikaru kind of playing with
an abundance of caution here shifting
his Queen to B8 aiming at the H2 pawn
and getting F4 under control so big big
moment now Robert Yan could take it slow
he doesn't have to play for immediately
he could play a more neutral move like
Rook D1 maybe vacate the F1 Square for
the bishop but this is a big decision he
has to decide on sort of the tempo of
his play
yeah no Rook D1 is just a waiting move
saying what is your plan Hikaru that's a
good question to ask because if Hikaru
had a free turn right now I'm trying to
figure out what is with likely Bishop D7
just developed uh the pieces that
doesn't create a devastating threat at
least not yet so it's not like
um Jan is in danger of losing on the
spot if he Dilly dallies but you you see
what's happening Bishop D7 Knight d8 to
F7 to D6 going after this B5 Pawn the
Knight on C3 can be removed from the
board at any moment so it's not like
Giannis all the time in the world and
speaking of time Donya I haven't seen
John down on the clock in pretty much
forever yeah I mean especially not
yesterday he adopted this insane
strategy of going with his instincts
playing so quickly building up at times
a 10 minute advantage against the world
champion and that strategy passed with
flying colors it was an amazing amazing
Victory uh for for janaponishi but yeah
taking his time hesitating this is a
difficult position Robert I have a
trivia question for you what real chess
or what regular chess opening does this
structure remind me of the Blumenfeld
excellent oh we are on the same page as
usual these pawns on e65 and C5 I wish I
could show the Bloomfield but the
starting position is different but uh
you know the chat can do their own
research this is actually a position
which could be confused for a regular
chest position at this point none of the
pieces are truly placed all that
unconventionally okay maybe with the
exception of the night on on d8 although
we could justify that as well the Knight
went to C6 White's Pawn to B5 and then I
just went back to d8 so you're right
this resembles a chest position that
could come from the regular starting
setup and all right yon thinking here he
is spending a lot of time and Hikaru has
a good position thus far you can
understand why Jan is taking this time
but that feels abnormal like I'm almost
worried about Jan's position because of
the fact that he's down on time now
that's maybe a distraction more than a
reality but with 15 moves to make and
only now 11 minutes and 50 seconds
counting down here it's gonna be
difficult for Jan to figure out the
right path forward
and there's the sort of sunk cost effect
where you sink so much time into your
move and then if you don't play a move
like E4 if you end up defaulting to
something slow you start getting annoyed
at yourself and why didn't I play that
move faster if I'm not engaging my
opponent tactically so with every second
that Jan thinks I think the likelihood
of him playing a move like E4 increases
because you've already made this big
time investment you might as well have
something to show for it right give me
those light squares I need something for
my pieces and what else is here let's
talk about move candidates
um the queen on A4 Rook on A3 they're
staring at a pawn that's well defended
in fact The Rook on B7 covers it by
itself so that Queen on B8 May jump into
the middle of the board Queen D6 things
of that nature so E4 is our I think most
prominent can to move is there a
justification for like an H4 or some
kind of play on the king side
H4 that is quite the move I mean you're
you're trying to push the spot up to H5
dislodge the knight from G6 I think in
another reality NEPA would consider that
move but between E4 and H4 I think he's
gonna prefer E4 I would say the other
candidate move or at least another
Canada move is is Rook F1 to D1 or maybe
a rook F1 to E1 if he wants to play it
slows or something like Bishop D2 just
some sort of
semi-neutral developing move that tries
to toss the ball back into black score
yeah no I I agree with that I think
another idea that I'm now thinking about
is if you could play C2 to C4 and he
does play E4 right away that would have
been another way to break in the center
but you'd had to move your knight first
and then play C4 it was too time
consuming so D4 the immediate response
from Hikaru Nakamura and then the
question is where is this Knight going I
think back to B1 as you were
highlighting earlier but that pawn on B5
is just going to be picked off when
black plays Bishop D7 soon yeah Bishop
D7 is nasty 92 Knight C4 takes a long
time and as you're pointing out when the
Knight reaches C4 that slices off the
connection between the bishop and the
pawn I think that nepo has to seriously
consider the pawn sacrifice E5 carving
out the E4 score but he goes for the
more conventional Knight D1 as you
predicted
and I do think that it's very likely
Hikaru Parks is Bishop on D7 or plays
Knight F4 well I think I know what
Jana's going for he's gonna play this
Pawn to C4 so we would love to put a
piece on C4 but because the pawn on B5
is going to be hanging you need to
protect it so C2 to C4 if black takes on
passant white is very happy about that
that opens up the board for the rest of
the pieces and if black does not take on
passant there then black has this
protected past Pawn on D4 but white can
easily block hate it as you're
indicating a knight is the best piece to
block k at a past pawn and with the
Knight on D1 this is why Yana pamshi are
one of the many reasons why he's in the
high 2700s almost 2 800 In classical
chess is because he understands where
the pieces belong and that Knight is
very likely going to end up on the D3
Square I think that's great thinking by
you I agree that C4 is likely now it's
important to point out that losing the
B5 Pawn does not end the game
You could argue that this is not the
most important Pawn on the board and in
fact after C4 which has just been played
I was going to make these moves to
illustrate the sample line but they're
making them for me if black is only
thinking about material gain Hikaru can
say God besant Knight C3 Bishop takes C3
Bishop takes B5 and it's time to pop the
champagne bottles except it isn't
because here you're missing the forest
for the trees you've won a pawn but look
at what you've done to your own Pawn
structure look at what you've done to
White's pieces and after a simple move
like Bishop E3 White's probably going to
recover the pawn and only white can be
better in a position like this so for
Hikaru it's very important to see the
whole picture here I don't think he's
just going to blindly grab the B5 Pawn
at all costs and what that position
looks like that you have on the analysis
board it looks like you're happy about
hitting seven pins and bowling but what
you're left with is uh pins all over the
place right you are not going to hit
that with that split so that is not what
you want if your hit card Nakamura but
then the question is do you want this
position with the Knight going into B2
to D3 in the future you kind of think
well wait a second my happy pass pawn it
ain't going anywhere and that A7 Pawn is
a long-term target white will develop
the dark Square Bishop that's been
sitting at home The Rook on F1 will land
over on A1 and maybe that pawn on A7
will not last for too much longer you
want to hear about a ridiculous idea I
came up with the move Rook F7
and if Knight B2 then I was thinking A6
now obviously can't take with a pawn
looks like a blunder but after Queen A6
I think I have Bishop takes B5 and if
cb5 Rook A7 traps the queen I believe
yes but maybe white gets a Pawn on it I
can leave the queen on A6 and say here
take it I don't care I'm gonna make a
new one with my B5 fun yeah you can park
the Knight on C4 uh maybe there's a more
accurate move but I agree this is a
little bit too outlandish and Hikaru he
actually does take on Passat and will he
take again on C3 wow where is he gonna
stick a knight on F4 it's a bit
surprising that he would take nope yeah
what an idea
oh my gosh yeah your idea is playable in
this exact position Hikaru Nakamura with
the Tactical Brilliance the point
everyone is what Dania is showing the
Rook is distracted once again from the a
file Rook A7 traps the queen over there
and you know what in to my eyes Dania
like after Rook takes C5 Rook takes A6
here funnily enough this doesn't look
completely lost for white like white has
this past Pawn protected from a bishop
on E2 you have a rook and two pawns for
the queen that's actually seven points
compared to nine and that past Pawn is
worth something so I would say that if
you're young to Palm she and you don't
like the Alternatives the queen sack is
really a legit try
it it absolutely is especially because I
don't really see any alternatives if you
give up the B5 Pawn black connects uh
two past pawns on the queen side and
those past spawns are just gonna tear
white apart a takes B5 and then you're
immediately threading a fork with B4
Robert I don't know if Jana has another
option I think he has to go for the
queen sacrifice and I totally agree the
position there is more complicated than
it may appear no question that Hikaru is
probably objectively winning but this is
right up Jan's alley in terms of how he
likes to defend but A6 let's take a
moment to celebrate the Brilliance of
this idea ikaru's level of tactical
sharpness in this tournament is just out
of this world and Hikaru is celebrating
he you know he's got that drink in hand
non-alcoholic beverage don't you worry
everybody but icaro he's leaned back in
the chair appreciating his idea and whoa
whoa E5 it is
has found an alternate defense
okay I see what he's going for right he
is trying to distract Black's Pieces
away uh from the the queen side so if he
can do that then the A6 Pawn will be
hanging so black in the current position
can take this Pawn on B5 although the
bishop 106 is hanging because the queen
is under attack so well we're seeing
just a takes B5 will has
you see one Bishop takes B5 I think he
has to I think Yonder Palm she has to
take the pawn with the bishop
yeah we can we can show why that is so
currently the queen is saying if you
move the queen then clearly your whole
strategy has failed and then you've
simply given up another Pawn on E5 if
you play Knight takes B5 then black
isn't obligated to take the Knight
immediately black and start by snapping
off the pawn on E5 and you're gonna lose
the Knight and so nepo that only leaves
the move Bishop takes B5 if Bishop takes
and you take back with the Knight and at
worst you're going to lose a pawn and if
black plays Rook takes B5 then you can
take the other bishop and funnily enough
there is no effective Discovery because
the bishop on D7 is undefended
really good point you know this loose
piece on D7 does not allow you to
exploit the bishop and Queen on same
diagonal and if Bishop takes B5 right
now for black white simply takes back on
B5 and I think hikar will take this Pawn
on E5 go up a pawn but it still is the
point you mentioned earlier E6 and C5
are isolated pawns you're a healthy Pawn
ahead except wait a second I think two
those pawns need a trip to the doctor
because they're not very happy to be
split from each other
but you're not just one healthy Pawn
ahead I think if we extend the line
after Bishop takes B5 Knight takes B5
Knight takes C5 wine is experiencing
logistical problems with his Knights the
Knight on B5 can drop back to C3 but
that allows Knight takes F3 and if you
trade first and your knight is hanging
and suddenly the H2 Pawn is hanging as
well so I agree that a visit to the
doctor is required but at least there's
likely to be two extra pawns rather than
one and this is happening as we speak
Knight takes E5 is on the board oh gosh
yeah I forgot about the H2 Pawn there
good call and I guess after 95 Bishop E5
there's this move F4 to throw in but
then you have to factor in King safety
because the Rook on f8 will land on F1
trading off those Rooks I mean just to
go down this line a little bit more yeah
as the players are sitting and
calculating F4 even Rook takes B5 here F
takes E5 like Rook F1 King F1 there's a
king out in the open here but you can't
go Rook V1 though there it is Queen H
mate which means Rook B3 is actually
kind of a threat if Roy had a free move
wow that's a brilliant idea Rook B3
would win the game on the spot but black
can use this free move to create some
look for his king or to shift the Knight
off of d8 in order to protect the eight
square with the queen something like
that F7 comes to mind but I'm with you
in general I think Jan most certainly
has serious drawing chances here even
after a move like Queen A8 if Yan could
get this into an end game I could
Envision a situation where even with
these two extra pawns black is a very
hard time coordinating his pieces and
winning yes no that's the problem with
having isolated pawns difficult to
protect hard to push up the board
because the squares in front of them are
not going to be defended by another Pawn
so this is what Jana palmchi has to go
for something like this hoping that he
holds and maybe in the current position
he's thinking about retreating the
Knight and he does just that to C3
accepting weakened pawns on the king
side that's a compromise structure
for that compromised structure the
double F pawns The Rook on A3 is
perfectly placed to keep them safe the
E6 Pawn is a potential Target the C5
Pawn is a potential Target and black
does not have an attack that's the most
important thing if you have to move
Pawns in front of your king it often
exposes your king to checks and attacks
but what attack there's not even a
single check that black can use at the
moment except for Queen takes H2 or
queen G3 which loses the queen so the
point is the King on G1 is actually
decently safe for the time being and the
C5 and E6 pawns are targets for the long
term
you bring up a great point a lot of
people look at the pawn structure and
just automatically assume it's going to
be Checkmate in three moves no in order
to create Checkmate you need to make a
Checkmate threat you need actual pieces
on the king side and one way that Hikaru
could try to deploy his pieces is with
the Rook lift Rook before hit the queen
and then swing The Rook over to H4 and
that does create a main thread against
stage two so my instinct is to play Rook
before but there are a lot of enticing
Alternatives you could stick the bishop
on D4 nice Central Square open up an
attack on the F3 Pawn you could work on
getting your knight into the game via F7
so Hikaru kind of spoiled for Choice
here but Robert in a way that could
actually be a good thing or nepo I think
it's very important if he wants to save
this game to equalize the time situation
to get this into some sort of a Time
scramble right now he's got five and a
half minutes and I'm still pretty
pessimistic about his saving chances
here and you can look at yawns I mean we
don't want to read too much of the body
language but he's usually pretty relaxed
at the board he is not relaxed right now
right he was hunched over the position
trying to figure out his moves and Rook
before and that looks like Queen A6
quickly the response from Jana Pancho
rolls up his sleeves a little bit there
the E6 Pawn is tender we keep talking
these isolated pawns Knight F7 not so
fast E6 is hanging if you swing your
Rook to H4 you just highlighted the move
F3 to F4 shutting off that Queen
H2 squared only move but a very easy
move to spot and not only is it a good
way to block the Checkmate that Rook cut
A3 may swing over to G3 in the future so
Knight E4 Rook G3 so Rook lifts you
always want to consider where they're
going The Rook on B4 wants to swing to
the king side but so does that Rook on
A3 eventually
yeah that's exactly right the line that
I was calculating here is Rook H4 F4 you
could try the cheeky Bishop G5 saying
get off of f4 and White's gonna say no
no no I can drop the Knight back to E2
carrying out your idea and preparing to
bring White's own Rook to the king side
and lending further reinforcement to the
F4 Pawn which is completely ruining the
coordination between black species so a
frontal assault against White's King uh
Robert doesn't quite yield the desired
result I think he car will have to
demonstrate a little bit more finesse if
he wants to uh convert this material and
positional Advantage into actual Victory
and it's a truly awkward moment for
Hikaru and the reason why is the E4
square is a kind of outpost for White's
Knight so you don't want this Knight to
land on e4 but you simultaneously don't
want to take on C3 and give up your
bishop and you don't really want to put
your Rook on H4 if it's going to get
shut off with F3 to F4 so are you really
going to stop 94 and if not is white
just going to have happy pieces so it's
a difficult choice right now for a car
he sees his options Rook H4 is natural
um you know Knight to F7 eventually with
the E6 Pawn is hanging uh taking this
Knight on C3 don't really like the look
of that Bishop can come to D4 at some
moment opening up the f file so they're
all these options they all come to mind
but do you want to allow this Knight to
situate itself on e4 is the essential
question
and ikaro sort of answering that
question and he says no I don't want to
allow 94 and the way he's going to not
allow it is by threatening the H2 pawn
bishop E5 is on the board guess what
Robert I would not rule out 94 here I
think it's the top priority for white
has to be to maximize the coordination
of his pieces and that almost might be
worth another Pawn if yon passively goes
H3 then The Rook would have swung to H4
and you would no longer have them moving
forward look what's happening Jan has
played 94 and he has sacked the pawn on
H2 he's now three ons no he's two pawns
down
did major in math sorry
that is a big decision there like to
give up the pawns and now he is down two
pawns but I like it he has more activity
for his pieces for example right now A
Move like Queen to A8 or queen A7 comes
to mind they're trying to trade off the
Queens if the Queens come off the board
Black's two Pawn lead this is actually
counterintuitive right Daniel when your
head you want it straight but actually
in this position the two pawns that hit
car is up they're vulnerable the C5 Pawn
is already hanging I don't want to take
that pawn when my king is exposed uh you
know if you take on C5 there could be
like a rook F5 Rook G5 things of that
nature Bishop takes C1 Queen coming in
so let's get those Queens off the board
ASAP and once those Queens are gone then
I can go Pawn hunting very instructive
moments so many people and they're
learning they become dogmatic when it
comes to trading pieces when you're down
they automatically rule out these Queen
trades but I think what you're
highlighting here is a set of factors
that supersede the general principle
yeah in general simplification favors
the side up in cereal and this
particular instance the queen is kind of
what I would call a glue piece it's you
know it's defending B4 it's protecting
F4 it is directing things from a
distance and if you trade it off black
just doesn't have sufficient
coordination to really hold on to both
of these pawns at the same time I think
Queen A7 is the best move here
and I think if you're a car you're like
nope not trading those Queens I'm
bringing my queen to E5 oh good thing
about this Knight on e4 is eventually
it's going to go to G3
it's gonna Shield the white king with a
bishop trade on F4 at some point or on
C1 the point is the dark side Bishops
are coming off that Knight will go to G3
so Jan I think instead of Queen A7 he
just brought his Rook to the center Rook
D3 can't fault him for that choice the
engine doesn't love it but I understand
it he is just going to an open file that
Knight on d8 he wants to Target it to
get the E6 Pawn loose but I think that
for Hikaru right now he can take on C1
if he wants just to give the F4 Square
to his queen or he can start by bringing
his Queen to the center with Queen E5
the threat is Rook takes E4 yeah Queen
E5 looks like a very sensible move here
because it takes this thing entirely out
of any exchange sacrifices on d8 it
centralizes the queen eliminates the
near-term possibility of a queen trade
Queen E5 is a very Hikaru s kind of
solid move
uh I was also contemplating a move like
Rook D4 but then I think white could
potentially snag the pawn on C5 and if
you can trade a pair of Brooks then
white king gets out of danger that seems
to be an eminently drawable position for
white
yes now this is a uh situation where
it's an uphill battle but there are
clear chances where Yan is looking this
is the trade I need this is the type of
position I need to get and yani's
looking everywhere except for the board
now he's back looking on top of it but
Hikaru Nakamura you know he recognized
that this is his moment so Dunya Bishop
takes C1 with the queen landing on F4 it
makes a lot of sense to me but as I
mentioned that Knight and E4 is such a
good defensive piece it covers G5 checks
it can slide back to G3 Brook on D3 is
perfectly placed covering the F3 Pawn
just in case so I just feel like The
Knockout is really difficult to find
Hikaru had the show nakamura's Knockouts
back in the day he's gonna have to
relive some of those happy memories
listen if there was an easy knockout
hikara would have found it two minutes
ago he's investing a lot of time the
time situation now a little bit more
concerning for black although still
plenty of time we remind you that when
move 30 is made an additional five
minutes are added to both players clocks
and a five second increment comes into
effect so you get five additional
seconds after executing each move this
is Black's 28th move so Hikaru three
moves away from getting those additional
five minutes but he understands the
gravity of this decision right here and
right now because a move like Queen E5
move like Bishop takes C1 everything
here is committal he needs to commit to
a particular attacking approach and
commit he does and queen E5 is on the
board and I really like that move it's
patient and it just accumulates the
pressure and tosses the ball right back
into nepo's court and the shot clock
shows three minutes they make a decision
and if any player doesn't need a shot
clock is
as quick as they come but right now the
decisions are not easy uh Queen D6
trying to trade those Queens comes to
mind but I feel like trading on D6 is
not the desirable outcome that's a weird
Square to trade on the bishop and queen
lined up over there and I guess black
kind of has to trade Queens actually
after Queen D6 right
yeah but black could essentially do it
on a certain black could trade and then
play C4 for example But to answer your
question I think wait Queen D6 Rook
takes E4 rookie four oh God wait oh does
that work
Bishop F4 maybe that's weird such a
Trippy position look at this position
The Rook is hanging so after Queen F4
white grabs E4 and The Rook still
protects the queen
so I guess here black guys to play like
Rook F takes F4 then the Knight of
single track I I'm not touching this
with a 10-foot ball yeah no I blended up
jc4 honestly so luckily there's Bishop
F4 but it looks like Rook D1 was played
just going after the night and that was
a mistake and when I see the bar drop
that much down it must mean Rook takes
even Rook takes E4 it has to be Rook
takes E4 nepo might have overlooked an
important detail if he grabs the Knight
on d8 there is a four karuski on G5
exploiting the vulnerable position of
White's King and if you take the Rook on
e4 and whites King is even more wide
open and I guess Black's Queen just goes
to town
and perhaps after running before that
before you just take on C1 yes you're
winning pieces Queen G5 protects d8 and
covers the scene once because Rook takes
E4 hit card just played that move we can
show it on the board here I I saw him
grab that Knight in the center fe4 loses
the bishop takes C1 Queen
protects the Knight and the bishop at
the same time and the bishop this is so
rare whichever minor piece you take it's
the same the fork uh is given with on
the same square Rook see one Queen G5
and Rook d8 Queen G5 and there is most
importantly no way uh to give up The
Rook on d8 and win both of Black's minor
pieces white cannot recapture either
piece and that means Robert black has
two pieces for The Rook White's King is
in shambles this game is over
it's done and Hikaru he's like yep ready
for the next one yeah a win with black
is Meaningful we won't deny that just a
win in general in this format however
what happened yesterday Magnus Carlson
took down janapomsy with black in game
one Jan storm back with two wins of the
black pieces in a row so Jana pamji he
needs to find his footing here in the
championship match because he did not
come out with a hot start in fact Hikaru
Nakamura from the outset of this game
seemed to outplay John he just seemed to
have a better handle of the Dynamics
getting that blue midfiel Gambit type of
position and the car Nakamura is he
wearing the same shirt as yesterday by
the way I was going to make that point
and uh that is entirely unacceptable
uh it is in fact it should disqualify
him yeah maybe when you uh
sweep somebody three to nil you're like
you know what I don't care I'm gonna buy
another one of this shirt keep on
wearing it because uh chess players they
can be a bit superstitious but
Superstition magic none of that will
save yonda palmishi in this position and
his look says it all
right yeah Chad is not gonna forgive
hikara for this for this transgression
Andy Carr yeah he just seems bored but
that face of course isn't the face of
someone who's bored it's the face of
someone who has everything under
complete control in addition he has made
move 30 he's got nine minutes on the
clock to react to whatever nepo throws
at him this is a really impressive game
one Robert and I made this point
yesterday about one of the positions
that nepo has this is the kind of game
that we would often see him playing with
black having the position he did with
white is just not something that he's
comfortable with in the least
no and what does he calculating here
queen queen G5 check picks up
ah I think I understand his idea
oh back rank Checkmate ideas but black
has the H4 Square so let me show this
King F1
Rook takes d8 Queen takes C6
now King f8 might be the clinical move
to avoid any background Shenanigans the
point is that King h8 meets with Rook D5
and of course you can't take because of
background
now that's very straightforward tactical
line
[Laughter]
please go ahead grab that one
doesn't even Queen F6 I think is winning
but just Queen H1 and here you can just
move the Rook to G8 worst
five okay tribal
oh the queen is trapped
oh my God look at this position it's not
even that there's some mate idea the
queen on each one is trapped so black
has to only play The Rook to E8 in order
to attack you foreign
that was really funny you know like any
move is good and then you know Rook G8
and the Queen's trapped over there on H1
rare thing to see by the way but that's
uh not happening yet it looks like the
pawn E6 uh was just grabbed by Yan and
hikar's thinking do I have to go to h8
and the reason he wouldn't want to go to
f8 so King f8 eliminates back rank
checkmates but it does walk into like
Rook trade and queen F5 check takes C5
now that's completely winning for black
you have an extra Bishop there's no risk
there but if you don't want to give up
that pawn and for some reason that may
lead to more draws tendencies that would
be the reason to avoid King f8 and King
h8 might be more accurate and if there's
a player that's precise his name is
sakar Nakamura yeah Hikaru trusts this
calculation regardless of whether there
exists a safer option he is going to try
to make the objective move he's going to
try to avoid any uncertainty when it
comes to conversion and that is why he's
taking his time he has his head in his
hands he knows that if he makes the
right decision here the game ends
immediately he can sense it and there's
no need to rush it he's got plenty of
time on his clock
no rush at all five second increment is
added after move 30 we are now move 33
so even if he milked this clock down to
a few seconds left he can rebuild that
time he is in no danger whatsoever and
Yanda palmsee he looks like a guy who
wants to resign but he's willing himself
to play a few more moves just to create
a challenge here or there but ikaru
sitting calculating still showing all
the new players to chess what you should
do even in winning positions don't take
your foot off the pedal continue
calculating he plays King h8 Jana Palm
she takes a drink of water but Dania I
think you would agree that while that
typically means the player is Happy uh
when they take that water during a game
right now I think it's just to uh try
and wake himself up for the next game
listen maybe he feels some false hope uh
connected with the Rook defy he's got to
try Rook D5 that lion uh we might see
reproduced on the board I think that was
entirely forced for 55 Queen H4 Queen G4
Etc
of course after Queen G4 maybe there are
alternatives but Yan might as well
exhaust every last resource you might be
wondering why doesn't he resign well you
can resign at any moment no reason not
to make a couple more moves we've seen
crazy things happen in chess the problem
is those crazy things almost never
happened to hikara when he's up a piece
right handicara you know he knows he's
got this oh I mean what happened
I just wanted to point out really
quickly sorry to interrupt you but after
Queen G4 I think an even simpler move is
just Queen back to E7 and if you come
back to E6 yep and queen G8 blocking the
check and block emerges
with the extra Bishop sorry continue no
it's a really instructive moment that
background Checkmate only works if a
piece can't block that check and the
queen blocking on G8 would mean that
it's just a trade of all the pieces and
when you're ahead by a bishop and one
Pawn you definitely enjoy yourself some
trade so uh janapamishi he's jittery in
game one Hikaru Nakamura he has been on
fire this entire event he has not lost a
single game and we should note that Jana
palmchi this is his 17th game here in
the Fisher random World Championship he
has zero draws Hikaru Nakamura it's his
17th game he has zero losses so Hikaru
just will not lose in this format in
this event and if he keeps it up he will
be the official random world champion
I mean his form is just absolutely
unbelievable and I guess maybe John's
play in the opening was not objectively
all that bad you know this whole B4 A4
stuff but it just didn't seem and I I
hate to use these generalities oh he
didn't play his style he didn't get the
kind of position that suits the style
these players are all Universal they can
play any position positional tactical
dubious objectively sound but it just
seemed like Jan wasn't all that
comfortable in a position where black is
the one who's got central control and
black is the one who holds the cards on
the king side
right and Jan right now he's leaning in
and he's I don't know what he's looking
for because yeah it really is there is
nothing to be found
I'm somebody who always likes to give
chances until the last moment if there
are available there are no chances here
it is a clear extra bishop and pawn for
Hikaru White's king is not any safer
than Black's King in the corner as long
as you avoid back rank Checkmate you can
just bring your pieces back
enjoy the extra material and then win
the game from there so Jan
um I'm just trying to wrap my head
around you know his feelings right now
he must be pretty annoyed but he does
have yesterday to look back to him like
wait a sec I lost a Magnus and then I
came back so I can do it against anybody
yeah Jana's obviously not going to tilt
he's not going to lose hope
and he's feeling a little bit of deja vu
but unfortunately for Yan Hikaru has
consistently demonstrated far far
superior form throughout this tournament
than the world champion I mean hikaru's
number of one move blunders I think not
only can be counted on one hand I think
have been limited to something like two
or three throughout the entire
tournament and in a rapid time control
an official random event that is nothing
short of amazing and nepo spending his
final seconds looking for something that
isn't there and I think he's going to
resign
perhaps after one more move
really Riley
it threatens nothing what about H6
H6 looks pretty good don't see a problem
with that creating uh some left for the
king and
Hikaru
looking like he's ready to move he has
the the all right yeah let's uh
you know let's get some rest and finish
this game kind of face on Rook take C5
Jan's still trying
but he is down a full bishop and at this
point he has relinquished all hopes of
tricking Hikaru on the back rank
yeah and even though we are stating
quite clearly that the position is Hope
oh my God
it should be three
three that is a dagger
can't take it because Rook lands on D2
check with Checkmate on the next turn so
that is nasty that is Hikaru Nakamura
flexing his tactical muscles and now his
Bishop can just Retreat now that the
Rook went back to C2 and you're up a
clean Bishop with an attack going so
Hikaru even when he's well ahead when he
can just Coast to the Finish Line he
says no let me find the Finesse let me
find the correct continuation he is
playing perfect chess yeah this isn't
he's leaving nothing to Chance The Rook
is coming to f8 when possible in order
to launch the decisive attack against
the F2 Pawn quite simply black is more
attackers than white has Defenders
because well I believe the black is up a
piece if I'm reading the position
correctly nepos still Clinging On to
this game Queen drops back to F5 making
it difficult for black to play Rook f8 I
don't think that we can fall in that
boat Robert I think you'll co-sign this
point before playing on this is the
final there's is a lot of money on the
line you can resign whenever you want
why not exhaust all of your chances I
think we should commend nepo for playing
in a position that's kind of very nasty
to play he knows that he's going to lose
this game but you know he wants to win
he's still trying his best nothing wrong
with you he definitely should be
commended because if you resign or you
lose you still get zero points so that
would be the same outcome he might as
well give himself at least a tiny tiny
tiny bit of Hope and by playing on here
and Hikaru has six minutes remaining so
Jan he's not even looking at the board
right now he is an objective chess
player he knows he's completely lost
queen E7 seems to be hikaru's choice
just retreating keeping everything
defended all these pieces in the dark
squares and one thing that Jan could
pray for is if the queens and Rooks get
traded and somehow black loses the G7
Pawn then it's the wrong colored Bishop
with the pawn on the H file
that's not gonna happen
well before that moment it's kind of
well defended by about a thousand pieces
nepo playing move F4 of course on the
previous move oh actually it is that was
a mouse he's playing it oh my God that's
hilarious I swear that was a mouse slip
I just clicked on that square by
accident and it's the only piece that
could land on that square because if the
queen moves anywhere oh my gosh it wins
the game you lose the E4 pawn and your
rook and you take you get your queen
loss resignation Hikaru Nakamura a
one-nothing lead at the start of the
Fisher random World Championship Finals
what a game I mean it was so smooth it
almost seemed like from the very opening
Hikaru was the one posing problems he
was the one asking questions getting
control of the center and then
seamlessly converting his strategic
Advantage into a tactical plus and then
into a material advantage and then
taking that material advantage and
expanding it going up a piece and
converting without giving nepo a single
chance at anything resembling a
successful resistance no what a finish
there and with a key moment if we just
dial it back was that moment where uh
John overlooked this Rook takes E4 the
defensive task was maybe insurmountable
anyways but allowing Rook takes E4 with
the queen coming to G5 defending the
Knight on d8 and covering the bishop on
C1 that's beautiful geometry and it's a
beautiful first round victory for akaro
Nakamura it most certainly is had nepo
grabbed the bishop on F4 maybe even with
the move Queen D6 he would have granted
himself better chances for a defense but
honestly given his time situation given
the fact that hikara was up two pawns I
think it almost seems like the win was
never really in question but Rook takes
C4 a beautiful resource to finish off
the game what a great start for Hikaru
in the finals
let's go on over to Magnus Carlson
against Nordic abusive tarov that is the
third fourth place matchup and in this
match there is I believe fifteen
thousand dollars at stake so forty
thousand dollars for fourth place 55k
for third so a lot of money here and as
I look at this position black is up a
pawn but white with that very active
Rook so nordbeck Abdul sitarov uh he's
keeping Black's pieces at Bay for now
but it's the end game Wizard it's
Madness Carlson are you concerned at all
for nordbeck's chances especially given
he only has one minute remaining on the
clock
yeah and I I have no question that
Magnus will whip up something he will
not simply Shuffle his Rook back and
forth and admit to a draw especially I
think given magnus's psychological State
he's got absolutely nothing to lose
rumor has it that uh he played more than
a couple of Blitz Games on chess.com
yesterday to blow off some steam hey
nothing wrong about my friend Nika
Theodora message me he played a long
match with him so in a way Robert
perhaps Magnus is a little bit more
relaxed and when the world champion is
relaxed you know he tends to produce
some pretty good Chess at this point the
difference between third and fourth
place it's a significant sum of money
but for the world champion it's peanuts
so I think we're gonna see a relaxed
Magnus Carlson and maybe we're gonna see
a Magnus Carlson who blunders less than
he has throughout this tournament
oh Magnus and he needs to will himself
to care sometimes and in this position
oh my gosh is there Knight takes G4
oh
wait Rook Cafe
and then you run to G5 yeah oh what a
tactic because
he missed it and you caught that
immediately let me show that really
quickly Knight takes G4 Paving the way
for a discovery E5 and he takes D4 and
black goes up two pawns and if white
gives a check out a f8 not King E7
Robert because of Knight G6 but no you
have opened up the G5 Square
unbelievable another Miss for the world
champion but Knight F7 still looks very
nasty from a practical standpoint
okay if E5 I guess there's like like D5
check holding on well if I'm just
transparent the only reason I saw was
the eval bar went crazy right like the
bar just dropped and give yourself some
I'm trying to give you some credit
accept appreciate that but I I like
being honest it's important uh but in
this position Rook A5 played and maybe
if Magnus realizes that that shot was
there he'll go back to E5 North Beck
will play Rook A8 again thinking we'll
just make a draw by repetition and then
19 G4 will be a cold shower except I
feel like Notre back wasn't born
yesterday Magnus should ooh and E5 has
been played after Knight D5 is he
wait a minute Robert King G5 Knight
drops back to C3
and wait a second there is a maiden one
thread oh oh my lands Knights overlooked
yes he did Magnus overlooked this
retreating night move you saw his his
eyebrows raised he's like oh oh didn't
see that coming oh you could just tell
immediately does he have a move here
and it's not just a mate threat Robbie
you can stop the main Threat by
eliminating the pawn on G4 the problem
is that their sits on d6a Rook which is
going to get forked after Knight takes
E4 is black losing here uh this looks
really bad the eval bar hovering on the
fifth rank to the left side of the
screen so it's clearly there's some kind
of wild defense and I think that wild
defense is indeed Bishop takes you for I
think he has to bite the bullet give up
the exchange and then at the end of the
line miraculously black has the move G5
to cover the check but oh my God what a
transformation and now Notre back the
only one with any winning chances
that's crazy and you know while we were
just talking about how magnets he needs
to you know force himself to care almost
because he always wants to win a world
title nordeback needs no motivation he
wants to defeat Magnus Carlson he is the
Olympia Champion he's the world rapid
champion and can you imagine how crazy
Uzbekistan would go if noribbeck Abdul
satara beats Magnus Carlson in a match
oh and it doesn't matter in what context
it doesn't matter where Notre back is
all guns blazing he's upset after
yesterday's match but he has a amazing
chance to redeem himself but can he pull
this off with only seven seconds he's
playing on increment and Robert I have
no idea what the evaluation is if the
knights come off the board right that's
the big question and magnets
quickly over Rook B6 brings his King
back yay so I guess White's gonna push
the pot up to E5 there's no
Bishop's trapped oh
oh my gosh
and norvik knows he won look at this
Atara the teenager from Uzbekistan what
takes down world champion Magnus Carlson
Rook C6 look at this final construction
the king and the Rook at something
straight out of an endgame study it
dominates the bishop had Magnus had the
spot on H5 he would have had the G4
square but he doesn't hear
Robert what a 180 this is insane
oh my gosh and Magnus Carlson he reset
some of the pieces he laughs himself but
he's just laughing because otherwise and
is in that kind of last couple days the
number one rated player in the world and
what an achievement for noribek
abducator teenagers are saying be Young
Vicious Magnus Carlson has found out in
many different events in Abdul sitarov
the legendary Uzbekistan player who's
still in his years takes down
Magnus Carl
he is vicious and he is viciously
resilient that looked like an endgame
Magnus would win nine times out of ten
notabeck playing on increment the world
champion up upon missing the tactic with
Bishop takes G4 and by the time he did
Play Bishop takes G4 it was already too
late and he was losing his exchange what
a start for the Uzbek youngster and of
course what an amazing start for the
finalist car in Nakamura
for sure well we have the results in in
the or is it the fifth sixth place
matchup we saw that so and Drew in the
uh seventh eighth match of hard to
remember what places they're for uh
Matthias gretzerson there in game one
but all eyes will be on Hikaru Nakamura
and she or Nakamura won game one
the names are reversed but we know
Hikaru with the American flag he won
game one so we will fix that gong four
allergies everybody uh but we would not
be able to do this coverage without the
presenting sponsor Brave so shout out to
Brave Brave means private browsing and
so much more by default Brave blocks ads
and trackers and every page and video
you visit even on YouTube no ads means
up to three times faster page loads
faster shooting and faster it means 35
of the life while saving on mobile data
Internet bandwidth for Android iOS and
desktop get the best for gamers the
creators in 60 seconds at brave.com
don't go anywhere we'll be right back
with more coverage for the feed eight uh
Fisher random World Championship brought
to you by Brave
foreign
okay
what's up man hey just solving some
puzzles
get my coffee
oh shoot
which one is that is that our new one
yeah
I can't get this one man
oh shoot
what's wrong with you man
this is hard
you sure you're feeling okay
uh one got it oh shoot
oh my gosh
95
[Music]
I should say T1
foreign
there either Rook C7 a7's falling uh it
is E4 pushes the pawn this is getting a
little messy takes a knight of one
yeah 91
[Music]
let's play
tune
it
takes it right
but there was Checkmate in one for black
after Knight takes G3
oh my God and instead he played here oh
my God A7 wins from White oh my gosh
[Music]
foreign
dress is great for the brain it's also
fun to play and chess kid makes it easy
to have fun whether your child is a
whole beginner or a prodigy they can hop
on and find a well-mashed opponent from
around the world
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Laughter]
[Music]
turn here to chestos.com's coverage of
the Fisher random World Championship
brought to you by Brave I'm Grandmaster
Robert Hess with Grandmaster Daniel
daradizki Donya in the championship
matchup between Yonder Palm shinikara
Nakamura it was all Hikaru in game one
it was and the word that comes to mind
is control he was in control of the game
from the very beginning he never let Jan
steer the game in his Direction the
strategy that Jan adopted yesterday
yesterday against the world champion
fell by the wayside as nepo fell behind
on the clock something we don't say
every day it was a masterful display by
Hikaru consistent with the kind of form
and the level of control that he has
exhibited throughout this entire
tournament yeah I don't know something
about a four nil run in the last couple
days beating noribbeck abdusitara with a
clean sweep now up one nil against yonda
palmchi something tells me he's hungry
for this title he's always wanted to be
a world champion why not in Fisher
random but yeah napomishi we know what
kind of competitor he is yesterday in
the semis against Magnus Carlsen lost
game one with the white pieces then he
was able to strike back two games in a
row with black
and Jana has to continue trying to
adhere to his strategy playing
intuitively playing quickly trying to
steer the game in a very tactical
chaotic Direction but sometimes when
you're facing somebody who is in as good
a form as Hikaru is you just feel the
sense of hopelessness you feel like
whatever Direction you steer the game in
your opponent is going to out-think you
or out calculate you or out strategize
you and Jan has to avoid getting in his
head in that way
yeah it's hard not to be down on
yourself after that kind of defeat but
Jana palmishi he knows he can hang with
anybody in the planet and he's had tough
defeats before he went through a world
championship match okay and then he came
back and won the candidates once more he
knows what it takes to be at the very
top so he needs to find that form right
now but what is the format here in the
final day of the official random World
Championship the players are dookie
enough for first third fifth and seventh
as mentioned earlier each match is four
games as it has been in the semis first
to two and a half points wins this is
the second game it's kind of like two
little mini matches of two games within
the four game match because you have the
same position in games one and two then
a totally new position in games three
and four so uh the tide Patrol 25
minutes no increment to meet reach move
30 you also gain five minutes at that
juncture so Dania I love the rapid pace
of things I think the world's rapid
Champion Nordy back abdusitara has shown
that it's format to his liking as well
it most certainly is I think it's a very
you know it's a good compromise where
you don't get flat out time scrambles
you have that additional five minutes
after move 30 you have the increment
because the point here is not to win by
flagging as much as certain commentators
like to win games by flagging we won't
mention any names but the time control
it caters to high quality chess and yet
time pressure enters the equation as it
should raising the entertainment value
but the young kids Notre Beck he loves
this and of course Hikaru Nakamura with
his Blitz and Rapid pedigree feels right
at home as well
that's true we see the live shots the
players are you know getting seated uh
we can see the in the playing Hall
Magnus Carlson he is already in his
chair and somebody who needs to recover
fast is Magnus dude yesterday he lost
three games in a row to yonda palmushi
he has now lost his fourth game in a row
this time to Nordic Abdus atarov and I
mean he just doesn't look like a person
who's happy to be sitting in a
chessboard what do you mean he looks
absolutely thrilled just his body
language the way he's sitting
you know he looks like at his he's at
his birthday party surrounded by friends
and family
and you know he's enjoying every moment
of it no but it's and and of course
there's nobody more Furious than Magnus
himself we can criticize but I can tell
you that what's going through magnus's
mind is probably how on Earth is this
happening why is this happening for the
first time in many years what's going on
he's got to push all of that away he's
got three more games to play and
give a notabeck's result yesterday you
know he showed some signs of weakness so
let's see if the world champion can
muster up a little bit of motivation and
a little more control in his play right
and in that third fourth matchup we have
two world champions Magnus Carlson the
world champion and we have uh no Rebecca
of the world rapid shame and here we're
gonna have a world champion for the
first time in Hikaru Nakamura or Yan
nipponishi so it's exciting day for
these two probably ton of nerves and
both players have their chances Nakamura
out to The One nothing lead but unlike
In classical standard chess having the
white pieces has not necessarily led to
an advance here in fact if we think
about the matches from yesterday we saw
that yonda palmishi he won two games in
a row with black and then Magnus Carlsen
won the first game with black Hikaru won
this game with black he won two games
yesterday against nordi back with black
the black pieces is almost an advantage
it seems like in this format
it's it's absolutely crazy and the gong
has sounded we saw a little bit of
Applause there uh and the game has
kicked off and it's already taken on a
somewhat different tenor a somewhat
different tone from the previous game
but if Hikaru pushes this Pawn up to A4
then we will indeed get a very similar
structure to game one
yes we saw that pawn break trying to
open up the a file and Hikaru when you
win with the black pieces in that kind
of line you may be like I don't want to
do this I won with black I liked it from
that side of things so it's going to be
interesting to see how hit card develops
and I'm most curious on you about how
quickly yawn plays
yeah and so far he's been blitzing out
his moves but obviously he's just
copying uh what Hikaru plays and these
moves are pretty straightforward when
you have a knight on h8 you literally
only have one option for its development
and the ball in hikaru's court and
there's our answer no he will not play
A4 in fact he does the opposite Robert
he safeguards the pawn on B4 keeping the
queen side closed and I think the reason
he did that is to ensure that the pawn
does not hang after HiFi and ketos is
Bishop
for the long run red but I don't really
think he's preparing C4 I don't know uh
C4 is one of those moves that you
actually really have to weigh in such a
position and already for young he plays
A6 so both sides refraining from A4 or
A5 and now I do like the look of C4 I
think it's just a good move you're gonna
develop your Bishop from F1 right out
there you're gonna open up the position
a little bit so I don't see the drawback
yeah I I can definitely see a case be
made for C4 but Hikaru starts uh with a
more flexible approach Bishops C1 and B2
that doesn't prevent him from playing C4
on the next move and I think there's no
reason that yawn will not do the same
and when will be our first deviation
Robert I'm just gonna copy each other
forever
um well I I don't think I would mind
that copycat chess is always funny but I
think here is that moment F6 was played
uh just shutting down the queen and
Bishop on the long diagonal so blunting
the force of that battery there and now
I'm starting to you know think about
things from a broader perspective for
Hikaru is he going to play C4 and if he
does does that allow black to strike in
the center for instance C4 you chop on
C4 white will take back then you play D5
quickly and maybe C5 is a quick
follow-up and I feel like black is just
gaining a ton of space
yeah black is definitely getting control
of key Central squares here
and the move F6 works really nicely in
terms of building a Harmony among
Black's pieces it also vacates the F7
Square for the Knight which is a very
nice defensive spot controlling squares
on both sides of the board so I'm with
you there I I think C4 has lost a lot of
its luster now that F6 is on the board
which back to the question okay well
then how does Hikaru develop his control
over the center I'm looking at a move
like F4 maybe doing the same thing that
Yan is doing and he literally does the
same thing that Jan does he plays F3 and
the copycat chess continues
never play F6 never play F3 Ben feingle
somewhere chirping at these players but
the difference I would say between the
two is now the light Square Bishop for
black not on B7 and it may never want to
go to B7 because the Pawn's in F3 so I'm
not sure about the configuration of
pieces but if Yan wants to shut things
down he can play D5 himself no more C4
for you and the bishop on C8 may
eventually go on its initial diagonal E5
and develop maybe to E6
I really like the move D5 and the
drawback positionally of that move is
that it weakens the C5 square but that's
kind of a hypothetical weakness which
can't really be exploited in the near
future especially if black let's say
Parks the dark squared Bishop on D6
anytime whitesnite gets to C5 that takes
a while and the bishop can just snap it
off the board so I think after D5 if I
had to choose a side here in the early
going I would probably actually prefer
black nepo takes a more developmental
approach he shifts the Knight over to F7
and he keeps D5 in his pocket I think we
might see this move
uh very shortly unless of course Hikaru
counter strikes with C4
no he does not he plays Knight F2 just a
little bit more of CopyCat chess it's
interesting that black has the advantage
here and perhaps the reason why is
because there's this bishop on C8 not
yet developed the B7 that leaves The
Rook on B8 as a happier piece right
there's no Bishop in its path and so if
these files start opening up The Rook is
well positioned and I think that you
know it's hard to criticize people in
fish are random right you just don't
know what objectively is best and Knight
E5 it looks like maybe not the single
most accurate move but very logical play
from both thus far
but I'm a little bit puzzled at this
move so let's say white responds with
something nonchalant like Bishop B2 and
that is indeed what Hikaru has played
where is this Knight going you're not
really going to C4 it can be snapped off
the board and even after like 94 Bishop
C3 that Knight isn't all that impressive
nepo seems to be prioritizing the
Improvement of his Knight but what's the
ultimate destination Robert what's gonna
be his follow-up
maybe we'll just leave it there although
F4 for white seems to strike me as a
good idea yeah exactly perhaps
exactly so I'm he he plays Bishop B7 so
he does eventually bring his Bishop to
that diagonal and you see the evil bar
creeping a little bit up in White's
favor because we have essentially the
same position and Hikaru can play Knight
G3 to E4 I don't think he should just
copy what Yan is doing right he doesn't
know how to do that at all all better
silver a dollar that he keeps his Knight
on G3 for the time being I don't see
anything wrong with short castles now
some of you might be worried about a
sack on F3 but that pawn is incredibly
well defended black has not nearly
enough Firepower to generate any serious
threats on the king side maybe in some
cases the other night could jump out to
G5 but Robert the word that comes to
mind to describe all of this is
artificial the this is just not how you
defeat hikaranakamura Knight G5 runs
into F4
and I think after Castle short the the
landscape of the position has has really
shifted I just don't like this strategy
associated with Knight E5 but maybe
young will change my mind in the next
couple of moves we'll see
right and for now
Hikaru we were talking F4 Pawn pushes
you do not want to push that pawn
anymore that opens up the long diagonal
for the queen of Bishop so you see
Hikaru he's like I'm gonna Castle he
kind of made that clear and then grabbed
the king and move the rook and these two
have a history right there was a game I
think a Blitz game is that right Dania
where yep
separate hands with the separate hands
and that was a whole to do these players
have the utmost respect for each other
they're not trying to create any
controversy so Icarus said I'm castling
let's just let that be and Bishop E7 is
the response from Yan so White's
made the king's positioning clear Jan
simply develops likely will Castle to
the same side or there is the
possibility that y'all wants to go for a
king-site attack so maybe we could put
those positions on the board done yet
just the moves I should say with castle
and Bishop E7 but is there a chance that
Jan tries to play G5 and get aggressive
on the King Center is that just begging
to be punished no I think there
absolutely is it would be pretty
consistent with this provocative
placement of the night on E5 and there's
a couple of questions that have to be
answered before we figure that out first
of all does white want to play the move
d4 or a positional standpoint it Blunts
and blocks in the bishop even further
but it chases the Knight off of the
Central Square maybe in some cases white
will want to reopen the queen side with
A4 but I doubt it to answer your
question though I definitely think Jan
is eyeing the possibility of G5 and
maybe just G4 to reopen this battery and
aim at the G2 Pawn
yeah I mean in a must oh it's not a
must-win game but he must win a game to
catch up to Hikaru you start thinking
about these sort of possibilities and
Jan is a little bit ahead on the clock
that is some very good news for him and
for the people who are supporting him
because in game one he was a little bit
too slow it didn't feel like he felt
comfortable in the position now he's
making very logical moves his position
is absolutely normal and Hikaru is the
one who has a slight deficit on time and
one instructive line I'm not entirely
convinced that this is objectively
accurate should white play D4 after
Knight C4 I think a lot of people would
rule this move out because after Bishop
C4 BC black has seriously damaged the
structure and you have seemed you seem
to yield white better control of the
center but now with the light squared
Bishop gone Robert this G5 G4 idea not
to be a broken record but now it
acquires uh a different level of
strength if you get your Pawn of G4 you
carve open the long diagonal light has
simply nothing to defend it with so I
think that makes D4 a lot less appealing
and hikaranakamura puts his own Knight
on e4
right shutting down
virtually a symmetrical position the
only difference uh is the placement of
these two nights that I've highlighted
and the castle for oh yeah what is it
yeah where's Waldo identify the
difference that's probably the most
important element of the position not
that black wants a castle Queen side now
if you Castle Queen side you're getting
huge trouble white will just open up
that side of the board but at some point
black can just shuttle that King
limousine service over to C8 and then
the Rook will end enter the center of
the board and shuttle over to the king
side so I think right now it's a big
moment for Jan he can Castle kingside
keep everything uh nice and steady or he
can make a move like you were pointing
at Knight C4 comes to mind because white
doesn't really want to give up that
light Square Bishop
yeah it's so interesting that the center
you can't even really say that the
center is closed the center is open in
the sense that neither side has tried to
control it too intensely with their
pawns they've left uh real estate in the
center to be occupied by the pieces I
think Knight C4 is a very interesting
decision Jan has to avoid kind of
forcing it but I think we're going to
see him take a couple of serious
positional and maybe even tactical risks
in the next couple of moves and Knight
C4 I think is a good example of a
calculated risk that introduces an
imbalance into the position without you
know making permanent structural
weaknesses among Black's ranks
really tough decisions in Fisher random
chest Janda Palm she's still up 45 or so
seconds uh he needs to come up with an
idea right now I'm honestly looking at
H5 I mentioned that idea half jokingly
earlier I was like oh can I throw my
pawns for it but the Knight on G3
defends the Knight on e4 so it's a pawn
for a pawn in a sense so H5 if you take
it I believe black can just take twice
on e4
yeah and as emotionally painful as it is
to part ways with your light squared
Bishop I think your point Robert is that
the queen is actually virtually
unassailable and not just that it's
attacking C2 White's pieces are kind of
relatively uncoordinated you can't play
D3
so I think H5 is very much in the mix
yacht instead pushes his d-pawn up to D6
not the most aesthetically pleasing move
but I think he's preparing F5
he certainly is only one King has
committed itself hikaru's King on G1
it's not moving to the other side of the
board so that is something to take
advantage of as a car plays D3
protecting his Knight on e4 I have what
she's having
yeah and if you are a key and peel fan
I'll have what I'm having it's from one
of the skits but Hikaru now leaves the
board and I'm wondering if if Jan needs
to leave the E5 square with his Knight I
feel like the center is just very
clogged for now and I want Pawn pushes
of sorts like can you move the Knight
play E5 and D5 and things like that I
guess the E6 Pawn is necessary to remain
put because if that pawn moves from E6
that Knight on G3 will land on F5 so
it's really hard to figure out even the
subtleties of a simple pawn move
yeah it's such a weird position because
it's so amorphous right there's no
actual definition in the center what
does that create it creates a situation
where there's like six or seven
plausible moves either side could push
either of the Central Pawn pawns forward
and so the players are largely relying
on their intuition here it's so hard to
actually calculate these positions out
Jan follows through on his idea pushes
the pawn up to F5
and I would have said that even a move
like F4 is not out of the question
except it is precisely because black has
refrained from castling here we see Jan
concretely reaping the benefits of his
more flexible approach
and where's that night going for Hikaru
it actually can go to C5 right now I was
about to say does a pawn D6 you can't
hop on over there but Knight C5 is both
legal and quite decent because the pawn
on D6 is covering the Black Knight on E5
an overloaded Pawn so Knight C5 if DC
Bishop E5 then C7 is G7 is hanging if
you take my Bishop of the center my
queen lands there just like in the
variation you showed earlier Donya with
the E3 Pawn being loose here it's E6 and
C7 and C5 I think white is very happy
this position is totally out of the
question for black it looks like his
entire position collapses so after
Knight C5 there's two points at which
black can make a choice you could
refrain from taking the Knight you could
potentially drop your Bishop back to C8
yuck that allows white to reposition his
own Bishop to the long diagonal if you
don't want it I'm gonna get it and if
you play Bishop D5 Robert this bishop is
not exactly the picture of stability it
can be pushed away right off on the spot
with the move E4 wait a second is why
just claiming the initiative and the
advantage after Knight C5 did Jan miss
this move
I initially was like it's not possible I
was like wait a sec
very much as possible what does Jan have
as a way out there I mean it's the Eva
bar still hovering towards the center so
it's not that bad for black but just the
way the position is unraveling it would
seem that Jan has to be extremely
careful because his position could
collapse in anything oh and Hikaru does
not go for it he drops his Knight back
to D2
which of course is also a totally
reasonable move white remains solid but
I guess there was something about Knight
C5 that Hikaru didn't like and yawn
follows up with G7 G5 a move that we've
been talking about for a while and now
it is on the board not mincing his words
nor leaving his actions up to
interpretation he wants to get this King
side attack going ASAP and I feel like
I'm watching a Nakamura game from black
or a repeat of yesterday's win for yawn
over Magnus throwing the pawns up the
king side he may sacrifice a pawn in the
near future to open up files the queen
and Bishop lurking on the light score
diagonal if G4 happens you've been
asking for that for a long time watch
out for the G2 Pawn how do you stop that
you can play E4 shutting down the
diagonal but allowing black to push
forward with F5 to F4 in the style of a
king's Indian it's not a defense at this
point it's a full-on attack
I'm almost never skeptical of Kings
Indian related ideas but I am here and
the reason has to do with this move
Knight H5 if white sticks does 99 H5
it's actually very very safe it's
virtually unassailable you actually
can't get to this night and G4 while it
may appear imposing let's not forget the
black's own king bears the brunt of this
move F takes G4 White's pieces are
perfectly poised just to tear this King
apart so Robert as long as white keeps
the queen and Bishop out of commission
the uh effectiveness of Black's attack
on the king side is going to be severely
limited I really like the movie four I
think that's a classy defensive move and
a car that's some serious questions
he went Knight H5 so he almost like
reverses the move order
putting his Knight there so if we uh hop
the Knight to eight
is G4 G4
I don't quite understand
is F4
is what's the
oh
there's always Knight F3 work I'm just
wondering about that too
so oh my gosh there's there's
intermezzos connected with the move
Knight G7 check but where
do you throw that move in like Bishop F3
gf3 Knight G7 check something like that
I guess you have to do that and the
crazy thing is that the sacrifice might
look so enticing oh I have a Pawn on G2
but white uses that pawn as an umbrella
and Black's attack kind of Fizzles out
after Rook F2
and Knight H5 G4 is on the board let's
refresh and get to the live position and
let's see what Hikaru has in mind here
I I would imagine F4 was his plan
because you don't want to take on G4
then the Knight simply takes back you're
gonna made it on G2 E3 is hanging so
this is a huge moment for Hikaru now
it's important to point out that after
F4 black is under no obligation to
sacrifice
anything at all but maybe he should
sacrifice but not with Knight F3 rather
not with Bishop F3 either although that
is some of what should be considered but
Bishop takes she too and after F takes
E5 you can take the Rook you could even
try to set up some sort of a mating net
with Knight G5 and Knight H3 Robert
let's get this gets really serious
really quickly what do you think about
this idea gosh because Knight H3 is
Checkmate and if you go Knight F4 to
stop the Checkmate I think you can still
even think about nothing oh and you open
up the the G file and if white tries to
run no no no get back to G1 where I'm
going to Checkmate you literally on the
next move this is actually just
Checkmate wow this is actually eight oh
but young rushed it he went Knight F3
immediately
[Music]
should have spent a little bit more time
to calculate his options he knew Bishop
takes G2 is available uh maybe didn't
see the exact follow-up with that Knight
G5 sequence Knight F3 so tempting but
Bishop takes and Knight G7 check young
will have compensation
but Hikaru is spotting the tactic but I
feel like this is a little bit of
naivety coming from yawn I mean does he
think that Hikaru Miss Knight F3 and if
the answer is no then wouldn't it have
been worth it to at the very least
double check and make sure that you're
not missing any other uh promising
candidate moves but again I have no
doubts that black has serious
compensation maybe Robert after Knight
G7 the most prudent approach is just to
play King D7 and keep both of your Rooks
alive but never mind because Hikaru has
played the move G3 instead
oh okay okay so he wants to just
surround that pawn right like leave that
pawn there you use the term umbrella
Pawn that still is one right if white
could play Rook F2 and just shut down uh
that side of the board then he can play
in the center maybe Rook eight of course
81 B to E1 and pawn to E4 just close off
the diagonal and then eventually win
this Pawn F3 so yawn needs to operate
quickly does not have all the time in
the world I would at first thought play
Knight H6 to bring my knight into the
game that Knight is dominated by the
pawn F4 three squares away so Knight H6
Knight G4 and I'm not sure what I'm
threatening but it feels like it's
heading in the right direction
yeah that is definitely uh an idea as is
a timely F3 to F2 check chucking the
pawn in order to reopen uh the diagonal
for the queen and the bishop I wouldn't
play that move immediately because I
don't see any clear follow-up and the
third thing I point out Robert is that
the prospect of black Castle in
queenside has increased I mean that's
like the great relief of you know
staying in a one-star hotel after
camping for two weeks not that I've ever
done uh any of that but we mentioned
earlier that castling Queen side is
associated with a lot of risk I think it
still is I think white can still try to
open up the queen side but keeping the
king in the center especially in the
context of white opening up the e-file
looks a heck of a lot more on appetizing
so we might see Castle queenside still a
legal move for black yes it is Dart that
King on over to C8 The Rook will go to
d8 and then looks like a normal Queen
side Castle I don't know if I would do
that right now I feel like having that
in reserve is generally useful but white
is kind of threatening Knight G7 checks
or Knight F6 checks whoa things like
that so you need to keep it in mind
I feel like
okay I maybe I shouldn't be reading the
chat because Chad is saying something
about Magnus but I'm gonna ignore it for
now okay well I see Jan ignored all the
moves we suggested and played Rook G6
yeah so he he brings that up to G6 and
what is his plan with that move I guess
he's protected E6 which is useful in
many uh situations that's part of it
maybe there's a rook H6 in the future or
he's gonna Castle Queen side and then
bring his second Rook to G8 and so he's
ready to seize the initiative I think
that's more plausible at first I thought
he might want to dislodge white tonight
with Rook H6 but the Knight has options
so much so that Hikaru goes to F6
voluntarily and he does it immediately
trying to fish out black star squid
Bishop which he does
and after Bishop takes F6 you cannot
Castle
just yet but you can't play King D7
if you want to involve The Rook so this
is a moment where we should mention that
their opposite colored Bishops now
having those opposite colored Bishops is
very useful when you're the attacking
side that is good news for janapamshi
the reason why the bishop on F6 inherent
to how Bishops work can only stay in the
dark squares cannot fend off the attack
on the light squares so yawn should be
feeling pretty good about his chances
right now not that he's with an
overwhelming Edge we see the eval bar is
a slight Advantage for black but I just
think logistically speaking Knight H6 to
G4 looks even more promising you're
hitting the bishop 106. Rook B8 to G8
looks enticing maybe there's a rook sack
on G3 leading to a checkmating attack so
I feel like yawn should be thrilled to
be in the position that he is and I'm
not sure how icaru is going to Parry the
many threats that Jan is building up and
Gianna's still up on time Hikaru at 12
minutes the time not yet a deciding
factor perhaps it's time to implement
your idea rook be1 and E4 trying to whip
up counter play along the e-file because
as long as the center remains closed
Black's King is virtually on the safest
Square in the entire chessboard
surrounded by this ridiculously solid
defensive Pond cocoon which control C5
and prevent the white knight from
getting to C5 and I think that is
exactly what Hikaru is thinking he says
that if I don't create counter play
right now it's really only a matter of
time before I get torn apart on the king
side the evil bar not the biggest fan of
that move but from a practical
standpoint Robert I think he car is
doing what he has to do in order to
muddy the waters right Brook E1 trying
to play E4 shutting off the light
squares I mean he's just not thinking
he's playing with intuition which is
fantastic but it's a moment where he had
the advantage and now it's all of a
sudden better for White and the move is
obvious right your point E3 to E4 so I
don't know
oh yeah sorry I think Knight H6 Knight
G4 should have been what nepo starts
with
because that's the maneuver you know you
have to play and that's a more concrete
thread now he's given Hikaru the chance
to play E4 and there's no sack on G3
there's no effective check when A7 can
be met with Bishop D4
what does Jana have in mind here
um rucksack on G3 does it work I mean we
know it doesn't work
well I'm curious make the move let's see
how the Evo bar reacts oh
whoa it's actually not going as crazy as
they thought it would I guess because of
Queen G8
because a king F2 right yeah I think you
have to go that way Rook G2 check or
queen Jade first king of three
can you go 986 now
if you took an F through there the
Knight was hanging on D2 right so that
that's
at least a bunch of material for black
with a pen that looks like a nice chance
even if white is better yeah because the
attack continues and the material
advantage has been diminished King E3 is
obviously the principal move
and the move I can't get out of my head
is Knight H6 and Knight G4 but
perhaps white has some way to zigzag to
finagle the king evacuated out of the
center I don't know how exactly
so maybe yeah maybe your queen G8 idea
is just the way to go just to you know
keep it
the piece is active and go for it at
which point
any point I'm not sure like here after
King F2 yeah Queen Jade now we're after
rookie two check both seem to be
enticing and I mean there's a king on E3
yeah there is and you can't play Rook G1
because there's always this Fork oh
that's me exactly perfect sound effect
and it's amazing like white is up a full
Rook white has two Rooks in black as one
but like you're saying it's not easy to
get the king out of the woods and I can
guarantee you that that is precisely
what Napo is calculating he's actually
thinking Robert
which is I know a shocker but he knows
that this is the last jumping off point
the ship is going to sail if you don't
take on G3 here white could even finally
eliminate that pawn on F3 and you're
gonna forfeit your opportunity once and
for all to rip open the king side he he
played E5 it looks like
oh
45
my Lance
the whole position is just wide open
it's exploding Anarchy and chaos
and he's slicing off the battery
the Queen Bishop battering may be
setting up Queen A7 check which is going
to be a heck of a lot more enticing if
there's no Bishop D4 he just played it
the queen A7 check so 0.57 okay
King H1 by Hikaru and while that Eva the
evil bar is like jumping up seesawing
getting a little more depth there
well the problem
for black is that this E4 Pawn is
ridiculously well defended it looks like
oh there's an x-ray there's gonna be
discovered check but no how are you
getting rid of this E4 Pawn
that's
the million dollar question or in this
case the 150
000 question to determine who will win
this event
so the good news for Jan is that
capturing on F5 is out of the question
so he knows that that's not going to
happen at least for the foreseeable
future but you're right actually taking
down this E4 Pawn is not happening
anytime soon
and I would amend the statement about
taking on F5 it might not happen under
the current circumstances but I think
there is a threat of E6 check drawing
the king to E6 and then you take on F5
with the Discover double check and if
the king moves back to D7 you could get
forked and later on white could block F2
check with 94.
okay very good point so there's some
tactics that you have to keep an eye out
for if you are Beyond the Palm machine
if you can take this Pawn on E5 directly
then the bishop 106 will free Itself by
stealing that pawn
and the King on D7 let's not pretend
like that's a safe King either I mean it
opens up the king can be caught in the
crossfire well I jinxed him I said the
king is on the safest Square on the
board but how could I have known that
the position is about to explode the
center is about to get dynamited
and Hikaru for a change the one getting
up from his chair usually we've seen
nepo be the only one to do it
it just seems like Jan
is getting confused again I think he's
gotten lost in the complications and he
doesn't have a follow-up in mind
it looked to me like he was about to
play F2 like the way he was the part of
the board he looked like his hand was
hovering over I sort of felt like he was
gonna go F2 I don't I it's possible
because the queen covers the square that
would force White's hand to play Rook E2
and the pieces are just all over the
place here I mean the King on H1 is one
check away from being mated just getting
that check
best way to start looking at this
position is by taking two Advil and you
know guzzling down some coffee how on
Earth do you do any calculation here
with this level of chaos but that's
precisely Robert where I'm so concerned
uh for Yan because for Hikaru he's got a
pretty straightforward course of action
you want to eliminate F3 you're
threatening E6 I feel like White's
threats and whites plans are so much
more clearly defined than Yan's
attacking chances
I agree I mean the thing is hikara's
goal is clear don't get checkmated Jan's
goal is let's go try to deliver a
chicken but actually doing that is very
difficult so in some ways Hikaru can
just react to the immediate moves that
Jan is playing that's typically not how
you want to play chess you want to
create ideas of your own while taking
into account your opponent's moves but
here it is the type of position where
Hikaru is focused on his King safety
that's currently tucked in the corner so
let's think about options for yawn
taking on E5 Pawn to F2 what come to
mind maybe like a rookie E8 type of move
just trying to open up the center and
have your Rooks there done E4 as the
pieces start capturing one another it's
a difficult moment even Brooke takes G3
can't be completely discounted and in
the same van and move like F4 uh is in
the mix as well trying to open up the G
file Rook takes G3 I think you should
almost start with because after the
trade black is threatening a hidden
Maiden one Rook H3 is Checkmate don't
forget about that uh Queen on A7 but I'm
very very skeptical about this I think
even the straightforward Rook takes F3
immediately repels any potential made
threats and white wins the game
so what do you think about this F4 idea
maybe combined with F2
like F2 and F4
oh
a possibility I think F4 right away that
white will take on F3 so uh steal that
with the Rook Rook takes F3 I think is
uh-huh yeah good defense
uh and then your E6 check is coming to
mind I don't know Queen A2 yeah and then
like Z5 I take and double check again
and there will be hell to pay for the
black king no this is
this is uh not an option so perhaps
starting with F2 makes sense then to
keep the app file closed as long as
possible and to force white to capture
the pot on a less desirable Square
right and F2 you know you have to play
rookie two and then F4 trying to pry
open the G file it's all getting here
here and here
so I guess you still take on F2 with the
E Rook maybe God the evil bar doing all
sorts of acrobatics there's still E6
check but then Queen A2 is a lot less
effective with the bishop on F6 actually
hanging
well it looks like it's all moot point
yeah it's important to calculate these
things so uh Jan was calculating just
those type of lines he takes on e4 after
all and now Hikaru is thinking do I take
back on e4 with what piece and he goes
Knight takes E4 he didn't think for long
and nepo's suddenly down to six and a
half minutes you've got seven moves to
make in a position this chaotic the time
has become a serious Factor here
for sure because with only six minutes
for seven moves to play uh this is
something that Jan is going to need to
figure out quickly so what moves oh
Able's right it's White's 23rd move now
black is on the clock for his F2 still
possibly D takes E5 still available Rook
E8 type of ideas trying to take on e4
get rid of the pieces on that diagonal
is another option for example I think
after Rook E8 if you play e takes D6 I
think black will be able to play like a
knight takes D6 at some point and are we
not here maybe because maybe first F2
yeah yeah F2 just open up the diagonal
and then Knight takes D6 great and
things are getting dicey and this is
where your point was so pressured about
opposite colored Bishops favoring the
attacker you can see why that is so
clearly here white has nothing with
which to contest along diagonal the king
is stuck on H1 and Black's attack rages
on so should Blackley rookie 8 your car
needs to try to keep this Pawn on E5 as
long as possible but what does he play
instead does he take on F3 does he chalk
the pawn with E6 I don't know it's
playing yeah he's gonna answer that
question himself rookie eight by Jana
palmchi and this is another moment where
we should say the eval bar suggesting
that white is just a little bit better
clearly indicates that black has a ton
of compensation black is currently down
one Pawn the E5 Pawn might be gone soon
the F3 Pawn is hanging in many positions
I don't know if you want to take it but
the ultimate point is neither player
knows what the number is next to the
evaluation they're like this looks very
complicated it looks like either site
can blunder in a single move so if a
blender is to happen it's hard to fault
the players it's such a complicated
position so far I have to say that
they've been handling it quite cleanly
neither side has made any significant
blunders
as nepo captures the pawn on E5 with his
Knight I would say that the smoke is
beginning to clear but it really isn't
in fact the position is filling with
even more smoke but we do have a couple
of Trades Bishop takes E5 has played a
knight versus Bishop scenario has
unfolded and a check on F7 Robert is
available to Hikaru
does he want to save this move for a
rainy day or is it time to start hunting
for blacks King
it's raining somewhere so Rook F7 check
is certainly I think it's probably
raining in Reykjavik usually is it often
is that's true I think something to keep
in mind is while you want to open up
this diagonal the move D5 not now not in
probably the near future but if you're
not looking carefully enough just to
kick that Knight out of there could be
disastrous for white so white needs to
come up with a plan I'm already looking
at ideas like to try to get my king to
safety so moving my H Pawn and playing
King H2 so here I think H4 well by King
H2 is something I would consider
um the evil bubbly defensive to hate it
okay I thought it was like a huge
blunder for a second nope not the worst
thing in the world but just trying to
get the king off the diagonal I think
that's a great defensive idea Hikaru
starts with a check on F7 now that does
not exclude the possibility of H4 but I
think it does make it more unlikely
because then you will have to reckon
with Rook takes G3 The Rook on F3 was
fulfilling a very important task of
defending the spawn I think Hikaru has
taken a more aggressive approach but
what is this follow-up going to be Jan
slides his King back to d8 or the time
being black has all of the bases covered
does anything come to mind for you
Robert Rook ef1 Maybe
and there's Rook takes E4 oh oh in
trouble oh there's no Queen eight shape
oh show that show that you should enjoy
Beauty
so this looks like Checkmate not only is
it not made black is the one who
basically delivers checkmate with rookie
a dropping back with a discovery
wow what a complicated position this is
and I was going to make mention that
Rook fhx something let me just keep
checking this King making a draw the
king can go to E7
like the Knight E4 is pinned so it's not
like there can be some immediate check
that the King has to deal with no Rook
trades and yeah Rook takes E4 there is
no mate for white the king zigzags its
way out of trouble back it goes to D7
and again the fact that black can step
back with his Rook delivering his own
check completely devastates White's
attacking options here
so you're right Hikaru can't simply bail
out with a Perpetual check he has to
engage Yan in these complications how is
he going to proceed I think a quiet move
might be what the doctor ordered here I
was going to say as a Warriors fan you
know all about that devastating step
back Steph Curry shooting that one but
Brooke back after taking on e4 could
catch a player by surprise not Hikaru
Nakamura though he is way too tactically
alert he's been in great form throughout
this event but this is not an easy
moment maybe he'll bring his Queen
closer to the king so a move like Queen
it comes to mind right just a way to get
your queen active and closer to the
king's defense but I do think that if
you play Queen C1 trying to end up on F4
um black may bring his own Queen towards
the middle of the board maybe there's
Queen D4 teaming up on this 94 some more
I don't know
yeah something like this merely adding
tension to the board Hikaru takes a very
similar approach he shifts his Queen up
to C3 attacking C7 Jana instantly
responds with Bishop D5 not only does he
defend C7 but he plays with Tempo
hitting the Rook on F7 and forcing it to
decide where it wants to live does it
want to stay on the seventh rank do you
want to give that check on f8 and let
blacks King out of the cage this is a
very very tough question that Jana is
asking Hikaru here and Hikaru may look
at that H7 pawn and say that looks
delicious but I would not grab that pawn
because if the Rook takes H7 that allows
The Rook on G6 to slide to F6 and the
Knight on e4 is pinned that's very
important and if that Rook gets to F6
maybe we'll go down to F2 or somewhere
along the line it just feels like
they're all these threats in the air and
he does in fact take the pawn I think
that's it it might be poisonous but a
car says no no no I am enjoying my two
Pawn lead and the eval bar still
hovering around the center so I like the
look of Rook F6 keep getting pieces in
the attack
ice water any hikaru's veins and he is
just investing all of his defensive
resources he is banking on this night on
e4 this Knight is the only thing that
stands between him and Checkmate Seven
Ways to Sunday the night and of course
the pawn that is supporting it in The
Rook honey one uh that is the final
member of The Supporting Cast and Rook
F6 is on the board you didn't have to
ask John twice he says give me that f
file give me that only Avenue to White's
King and in addition to Rook F2 Robert
there's even in some cases ideas of
playing Rook F1 distracting the white
rook and then grabbing the Knight on e4
I can't quite find a way to make that
work but I think you see what you see
what I'm saying oh for sure I do and
also King G2 that may look like a move
that helps your king in fact he gets in
more trouble because Queen F2 check
Queen F2 is a peripheral threat that you
can't play because the C7 Pawn is
hanging with check but if the king Walks
Into the Fire there the queen comes into
F2 with check you can't run away to H3
because Bishop E6 is probably
and they're problems Galore for that
white king so watch out at this moment
here because Hikaru his King may look
sheltered for now but if he doesn't find
some accurate responses Rook e to F5 is
on the table as well
I agree with the point that Rook takes
H7 was probably over optimistic I think
Hikaru having the wrong priorities here
grabbing that pawn and underestimating
the impact of black getting control of
the f-file I don't really see a move for
white I don't see a way for white to
solve the problems inherent in his King
position maybe you can try and move like
H4 to open up a little bit of Luft but
again that just puts a Band-Aid over the
problem it doesn't solve the issue of
black infiltrating and of the sacrifices
on e4 Hikaru
I think he's found a way to bail out
though
I think he's found a way to bail out
can't the king
yes C8 and then B7 if you keep giving a
checks that is a totally valid question
I honestly missed that
I think it most certainly can
oh goodness I think it most certainly
can we want to remind everybody this is
about to be hikar's 30th move so he has
plenty of time to make that one move
while he'll gain five minutes and a five
second increment so that sounds like a
lot of time but in a position like this
with your king ex it seems okay but it's
actually quite Exposed on H1 with blacks
pieces streaming in this is dangerous
territory for Hikaru Nakamura now this
is taking a turn for the worse ever
since icaro took that pawn 94 with his
Knight and now grabs the pawn on H7 and
he is hoping against hope that Jan is
going to repeat moves I don't think he
is and Yan doesn't even think about
repeating with King d8 he runs toward
the queen side King see it is on the
board and just to show everybody if
Hikaru keeps checking the king runs all
the way to B7 where it is the safest it
has been Robert in many many moves and
that is terrible news for black because
once the king gets for white rather
because once the king gets safe Queen F2
is now in the cards and all it takes is
one move like this for white tank to be
permanently devastated oh my gosh and it
may not seem like black has any threats
but a huge threat is Rook E5 to F5 the
Knight on e4 is still pinned because the
bishop with the Rook on F5 Rook F1 check
followed by Queen
flooding into G1 that could end with a
Checkmate or F2 as you're pointing out
so the the King on H1 is about to fall
victim to an attack and what is the move
here Hikaru it seemed like he was going
to grab his Rook on H7
okay he's still calculating he looks
like we're E7 his idea
Kevin trying to grab the Rook I think
he's trying to go Rook E7 and swap off
some material and after okay the move
makes sense because Rook takes C7
there's Queen takes F6 what white
wouldn't give to trade one pair of Rooks
here how much would that relieve the
pressure on White's King but my question
after rookie E7 could black stick with
your idea and position The Rook on F5
simply ignoring uh the white Rooks and
treaty
I think so because Rook E7 did we can
just show quickly that Rook takes E7 is
meant by Queen takes F6 here which
apparently is not the end of the world
for black but that's trending in the
wrong direction so instead of trading
Rooks keep more peace on the board
you're the one attacking Rook EF5 and
then Rook F1 check I mean how is white
dealing with this threat yeah no this is
it's crazy to say that this is almost an
Unstoppable threat but it basically is
and I just want to highlight the
incredible multi-purpose role that is
played by The Black Queen it's
protecting C7 so it is what stands
between black and Checkmate uh but it
also could potentially be the piece that
delivers Checkmate to the white gang
keeping White's King confined on H1
rookie seven is on the board and rookie
F5 is virtually forced and Jana's away
from the board right now but if he were
seated like he's going rookie to F5 he's
not training Brooks no and he comes back
let's see how quickly he makes the move
because there's no Universe where the
attacking player wants to trade pieces
white is up two pawns but it's not just
about when your head trade material it's
about creating threats Rook e to F5
threatens Rook F1 check and
I think the way a car is going to deal
with that is by pushing his Pawn to D4
to shut the queen out but that loosens
the defense of that night before so you
solve one problem but you create another
one in a really nasty looking way and
that is a dark and dangerous path but it
might be the necessary path which you're
saying is that after D4 the queen is
sliced off the king breeds a little bit
easier but now the Knight is like hey
what the heck I needed that pawn black
can even shift the king back to the
danger zone in order to dislodge The
Rook 97 and then setting up set up some
sort of battery against the night on
beast on e4 I get that the evil bar is
showing zeros I totally get that white
probably has some path where he can walk
on hot coals for 10 moves and secure the
draw but does hecaro have it in him to
find whatever this line is md8 is a
nasty move if we just show that really
quickly because yeah Instinct as chess
players after D14 d8 is to move the Rook
away somewhere and you can't stay on the
e-file so you'll Rook G or H7 but then
your knight is in huge trouble because
you can bring a rook to the E file and
win that piece or they're squint yeah
Queen B7 like you're showing and that I
think that piece is falling with Rook F1
check available as well I think white
might have to play no I guess Rook H7
isn't the move either what on Earth is
the move here
no this is this is insane I mean the
email bar is showing equality but how do
you get yourself to go for this line I
think Hikaru is in Mortal danger here
because if he doesn't play D4 Rook F1 is
a mate threat right that is not just an
attack on the king some something
open-ended
does it actually lead to maid I guess
that's an important question to answer
here
it might but like not and yeah because
the king somehow runs to H3 and
this Rook on E7 is nicely positioned to
prevent a potential check on E6 D4 it's
played wow
big move for cars apparently apparently
a good move but if Yonder Palms she
plays King d8 here now is where hikar
proves his medal like what is the
follow-up there is a rook simply hanging
on E7 and if the Rook slides over the
eval bar already showed us that there's
a win for black I'm guessing some kind
of Rook F1 check distract the pieces oh
actually that's that might just be it
that if the king d8 if the Rook moves to
uh anywhere on the e-file there's Rook
F1 check distracting white pieces maybe
bishop E4 check after Rook takes F1 and
ah yeah and you win a piece yeah and and
this is probably one of several options
you could maybe take an even slower
approach now I I did with the corner of
my eye spot this idea of King G1
in order to unpin the Knight but the
reason I thought it didn't work is
because after King takes E7 there aren't
that many effective discoveries you
basically have to take the Rook black
takes on F6 and black is down is up a
piece but somehow the Evo bar isn't
changing so maybe there is a way to hunt
for black skin with a move like Queen E3
creating some serious threats of Queen
E7 and queen H6
and John
of Rook F3
he doesn't play King d8
so he's gone Queen hunting he said you
know you're King whoa whoa whoa maybe
it's okay for now but after Queen D2
he's gonna play Rook F2 so I actually
completely understand what he's looking
at here he wants his Rook on the second
Rank and he's trying to do so with Tempo
that king d8 move I mean that looked
like it was a good option but not easy
to spot especially uh with the time
Patrol uh the way it is right now Queen
he's a rook F2 is like my immediate
feeling here let's bring that Rook to
the attack
somehow Hikaru seems to be surviving
this for the time being yeah Rook F2 is
so natural opening up the pin against
the Knight and forcing this queen
tossing it around the board so I have to
Rook F2 it is on the board if I are
creeping up in White's favor where is
Hikaru going to position the queen what
is the optimal defensive Square
you're asking the wrong person
we're just tossing the question around
like a hot potato let's toss it around
to Hikaru well Queen G5 looks viable
because it attacks the bishop on D5 but
it drops D4 so as you're highlighting
here the queen needs to stay in touch
with that pawn on D4 if you drop that
pawn you're crushed your knight is loose
your king is never gonna find a safe
zone so I think the move Queen D1 just
to cover F1 and not give up and attack
against the queen queen D1 the reason
that's a hard move to play is just
because it relinquishes any aggressive
intentions that you might want to
express with your queen but what you're
saying is that you need all hands on
deck white is up two pawns white has the
advantage that he needs right now the
goal has to be to repel all of flex
immediate threats
I just feel like the position is easier
to play for Yana because Queen from the
queen for black can go up to B6 and over
to C6 as well to pile up on the pink
piece attack the C2 Pawn so I feel like
while white is two pawns ahead the
material is good the black king is much
safer heading to B7 later but two
observations after Queen D1 white is
only one move away from shifting his
King up to G1 and unpinning the Knight
the same observation goes here he
removes his Queen up to D3
but the drawback of this move is that
Jan could slide the other Rook into F3
and push the Queen Once Again back to D1
and maybe that's what Hikaru wants
yeah I mean there's no attack on either
Rook because the Knight is pinned so
Queen B6 is just a useful looking move
to try to get Queen C6 next hitting the
C2 Pawn that is a loose Pawn in the
position it's not just about the Knight
on e4 the pan the king safety if you can
win that C2 Pawn you're cutting your
material deficit in half and creating
more threats as well so in combination
with Rook F3 as you're highlighting I
feel like there are many many threats
and ikaru is down several minutes on the
clock he has enough time he's absolutely
one of the best Blitz players in the
world how many title twosies has that
guy won but this position feels so dicey
for that King in the corner
it most certainly does and Jan has a
decision to make here he can keep the
tension I love the move Queen B6 it's
such an effective way of playing in the
opponent's time pressure making these
slow Quiet Moves where you're kind of
masking your intentions but Jan I'm also
positive that he's going to spend some
time calculating the move Rook F3 I
don't quite see the follow-up though
after the queen slides back to D1
why would you allow that Tempo that's
the big question I guess yeah that's a
rook F3 there might be Rook E3 just
trying to oh then the C2 Pawn is
supposed as well God this is terrifying
Rook F1 somehow the king slides its way
to H3 that does look at this line
and suddenly the king is perfectly safe
actually
was a new threat right
okay so giving the checks maybe he's
misguided he had Rook F3 so what is
hikaru's response and
I don't see why he wouldn't play Queen
D1 immediately unless his plan is here
to go rookie three
no he definitely sees the possibility of
rookie three another point in eon's
favor Robert is that if Queen D1 yes
that technically the Knight is unpinned
but you really still can't move it
because in this particular instance I
think the Discover check would be
devastating and rookie three is on the
board a trade on E3
and Jan goes for your line he just grabs
the pawn and C2 says give me that give
me that pawn why not the king is safer
for now for black but Hikaru plays King
to G1 slides that King over and after
Queen B6 the Knight is at long last for
me to move whoa whoa whoa and where is
it going to go
where is it gonna go
do you drop it back towards C3
dislodging the Bishop from its dominant
Central Square oh my God Robert after
Knight C3 black has to be very careful
not to get forked
with some sort of rookie 8 and Queenie
for action
oh my gosh so after 93 is the force move
like Queen C6 or something like that but
that might trade material
so is there a better way to execute the
same idea maybe Knight F6 but then still
worse comes to worst black as Queen C6
there is a queen trade available right
like there is
wait that actually might be bad for
black let's go through that line very
quickly Knight F6 or Knight C3 yeah sure
uh we can check on E8 first or second
doesn't matter Our Queen E6 I was trying
to trade somewhere right so if we trade
Queens white has these two unopposed
passers on the king side is black in
time the white can cut off from the help
the A3 Pawn would likely Fall but this
feels like practically speaking it
should be really good winning chances
for a CaRu and this is wildly on
appetizing given the position that Jana
has just had now to defend an end game
where he is on the cusp of allowing
promotion is the last thing that he
wants to allow Knight F6 is on the board
by Nakamura and that is once again the
top move this is just unbelievable level
of accuracy by Nakamura and after Queen
C6
are you telling me that there is an even
better option than taking the the bishop
on D5
uh feel like Knight 65 is automatic if
there's a queen trade but that's the big
if now that I look at it after Queen C6
Knight takes D5 there's Rook C1 check
where is the white king going if you go
to G2 there's Queen takes D5 check and
no Force get it oh my God you were right
Robert you have to give this check on E8
first and the reason precisely consists
in this move Rook C1 now after King G2
Queen takes D5 you slide the queen up to
E4 perfectly timing it with the
placement of black skin the queen trade
is forced the black king is as far away
as it gets and I think white wins the
game with these connected passers is
there like King C6 though in this
position funnily enough like can we
trade Queens on my term so if you take
me the king gets out to D5 you have to
try I think King C6 is by far the most
resilient but white says I'm training on
my terms oh moves are happening Knight
D5 first Rook C1 check oh missed that he
probably did but I still think that King
G2 and queen E4 is very effective no he
goes down to F2
well no the problem with King G2 Queen
E4 is Rook C2 check the queen is pinned
on the E4 Square so you have to be very
careful if you're a car here like you
might just say I'm up a point in this
match I can just make a draw like on
King G1 back and forth
no but this has been just ridiculous
defense the other option yeah he does go
back to G1 let's see if Hikaru repeats
moves obviously nepo at this point has
no choice
and I think Hikaru might be going for
the draw here yes he is yes he is
wow Nakamura if the match situation were
different he would have sat and thought
he's you know they're talking a little
bit but they know that they have two
more games to play so they don't want to
be too friendly towards each other but a
big save there by John de palmisi
because first he looked like he had the
attack then amazing defense by Hikaru
Nakamura and ultimately for yonda
palmshi to save that half point at the
end that's big news I mean I think we
should just take a look at that you were
mentioning yeah Rook C1 check King G2 it
feels like he could have played on a
little bit and if the match score had
been tied he probably would have but I
think the reason he didn't consists in
this move Rook C2 that you pointed out
this is a very scary move the king
doesn't have too many safe squares now
apparently and we have the benefit of
the eval bar after King G1 Rook C1 now
the king can zigzag over to F2 Rook C2
is no longer possible and after a check
on A2 white plays King F3 runs to G4 and
apparently white is safe but again
remember Hikaru does not see that evil
bar can you blame him for not going down
this ridiculous path with two minutes
left on the clock having just pulled off
the defense that he did I think the
answer is an unequivocal no I think he's
going to be thrilled with the draw and
thrilled with the fact that he survived
a furious attack by nepo to remain a
point up in the match with only two
games to go great game by both those
players let's head on over to Magnus
Carlson against noribeca busatar in the
third place matchup uh as we bring that
board up to match the camera we have
there look at this Magnus Carlsen Rook
on the seventh rank past Pawn on B7
black is actually up a pawn here Donya
but completely winning for magazine he
just needs to play Rook C8 check and it
feels like the game should be over in
the near future but maybe easier said
than done I I think that there's a
pretty line uh Rook takes b a rook takes
B8 Rook A1
so this is kind of the classic idea now
here's the funny thing if you take on B7
and say hey I'm gonna give up my knight
and win White's last remaining Pawn no
you will do no such thing because Knight
D6 picks up the Rook simultaneously
defending White's Rook
so that's not an option
black has to find a way to defend the
Rook with his Knight but if you go
Knight d8
well there must be a win here I don't
know yes no no rookie Rook takes DNA 96
check oh same thing so that just
transposes yeah
okay so instead Magnus he goes Rook to
E1
keeping both Rooks on the board I think
he's just heading for E7 you know it's
pretty simple actually yeah it does
Barry carlson-esque approach yeah it's
like okay why trade off some stuff and
win that way when I could just put all
of my pieces in attacking mode and yeah
Black's seventh rank is being mowed down
it's over I think Magnus is going to
rebound
that's an important game for the world
champion kind of showing his medal there
we obviously have been following the
Hikaru yanapanishi game but this looks
like a pretty smooth game by all
appearances
wow we're coming to E7 that's painful
and for abusot tarab he's down to 30
seconds on the clock his position is in
shambles he doesn't have time to
calculate the best possible defense so
Knight d8 runs into rookie eight
Checkmate can't even bring your knight
back there this is a nightmare literally
yeah 30 seconds
perked up
is Rook B3 trying to get that pawn and
Rook C8 check followed by EA check it
should do the trick yeah or you could
start with 96 if you want to be
political The Rook of ba was hanging I'm
like oh throw it oh oh it is yeah I also
didn't see it let's go 96 here wait a
minute just take the Rook no that's a
clean finish for Magnus Rook CA check
game over magnets once again resetting
the board uh he did that even after his
loss so he's just well it's actually
kind of funny he shouldn't reset the
board because they're gonna have an
entirely new position but either way
good sportsmanship from Magnus Carlson
he locks this match up in a tie one to
one two games to go and in the other
matches Matthias bluebaum is ahead one
and a half to half over he overstein
greterson and then Wesley so Vladimir
fetto say of uh that match is ongoing as
well one to one but all eyes on Nakamura
napomchi that's where the money maker
matchup is Dania one F to half in
hikaru's favor it's been a very great
matching epic one already and we still
have a whole second half to go listen we
are watching two players who are in
excellent form I think that's what it
really boils down to and when you have
two players of this caliber who are both
in really good form that's where you get
these incredibly complex games or the
sides they go back and forth we see
ridiculous sequences of accurate moves
by both players the way they handled
that chaotic position was it totally
mistake free no would it be fun if they
were just able to play like robots no
but they did the best that they could
both players came up with a resource
after resource a draw I think a very
fair result a frustrating result for Yan
and pomnishi who was hoping to deliver
Checkmate but the good news for him is
that hikaru's lead is still at one and
Yan is only one win away from tying the
match he's got two opportunities to get
that done you say Jan is winning away
from tying the match hikar Nakamura one
win away from winning the match and if
he takes home the 150 000 prize in
addition to the world championship title
and fish and random chess he may add
more later this week in Toronto because
right after he finishes his match here
he heads on over to Toronto Canada for
the finals of the chess.com Global
Championship it comes to Head Live
Wednesday November 2nd is when the
quarterfinals begin with five hundred
thousand dollars on the line we don't
know who will come out on top the upsets
we have seen throughout this tournament
it is a Wonder to behold it is anyone's
tournament and Fabiano caruana will join
the commentary Booth he recently crowned
U.S Champion the former Challenger to
Magnus Carlsen one of the best players
of all time you will not want to miss
the commentary along with players like
uh you know guys like Daniel nerdinski
myself Amon Hamilton Gotham chess Nemo
James Canty and the one and only Danny
wrench but for now we are gonna head to
a break the players they're gonna reset
get a hold new position revealed to them
but for now we will just take a quick
breather more from the official random
world championship this coverage on
chess.com brought to you by Brave
[Music]
I understand 18 seconds for black so not
too much time there either Rook C7 A7 is
falling uh it is E4 he pushes the pawn
this is getting a little messy takes a
knight F1
91
[Music]
move you know oh my gosh 0.9 seconds
when that move was played
it takes it right here
but this Checkmate in one for black
after Knight takes G3
oh my God that wasn't there and instead
he played here
oh my God A7 wins for white oh my gosh
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
action here at champion of Sunday at the
Fisher random world championship this
coverage on chess.com brought to you by
Brave and it's that time of day it is
the brave move of the day and Donya we
had no choice it was an easy one Hikaru
Nakamura in game one
yeah it really wasn't even a choice at
all the way that he played the entire
game just revealed his incredibly good
form his total control over the position
and it all came to a head when
janapamshi plays the ostensibly totally
natural Rook fd1 doubling his Rooks on
the D file Jan down two pawns but hoping
to generate counter play based on his
piece activity did Hikaru just move his
Knight away from d8 like most of us
would no he did not instead Robert he
finds a brilliant tactical shop that's
based on some gorgeous geometry talk us
through it oh yeah Rook takes E4
removing the key Defender for that King
on G2 it was already exposed no Pawns in
front of it but the G5 Square was under
its control so taking that Knight on e4
Dania it allowed not just for an
exchange sacrifice and some checks but
actually the winning material
yeah there's another natural move Queen
takes C4 check but no that's not the
point either he calmly takes the bishop
on C1 and whichever minor py takes
whether he takes the Knight or whether
he takes the bishop there follows the
same exact Fork the queen lands on G5 or
King C1 or four king d8 it's a very
unusual construction where the same
square leads to two different Forks
neither piece can be touched janapanushi
ended up taking on d8 after all Hikaru
picked up the Rook on d8 calmly stepped
away from nepo's check and he merged
with an extra piece this queen the
entire hero of the Soul combination Rook
takes E4 what beautiful geometry what
incredible form and that is what allowed
Hikaru to score a convincing victory in
the first game
there's beautiful geometry in nature
there's gorgeous geometry in a car
nakamura's chess games and that was your
Brave move of the day so time to make
your move from chrome to Brave try it
now at brave.com chess so Hikaru
Nakamura he is in the lead one and a
half over yonda palmshi Yan show that he
is not going down in this final without
a fight Dania in game two that was a
true battle between two juggernauts
Hikaru maybe out of the opening didn't
find the best plan young Elise on paper
according the engine evaluation had
maybe a little something something but
akaro defended well and in crunch time
he found a way out for his King he in
fact had the advantage when the game
concluded and if it were not for game
one's results he might have even played
on in game two but a draw was sufficient
to keep his lead it was and there is a
silver lining for Yan his strategy uh he
looked more like the Yanda pamushi from
yes yesterday in game two there were
some missed opportunities arguably the
biggest one was Jan rushing the natural
move Knight F3 check refraining for a
bishop takes you to a knight G5 which
would have yielded a furious attack on
White's King it wasn't winning on the
spot but it would have set Jan up for
Success With that being said so many
amazing resources found by both sides
Jan just needs more of the same that was
a 50 50 game that could go either way
and when you're playing a Hikaru
Nakamura who's the kind of form that he
is that's really the only thing you can
ask for you won't be able to beat him
wire to wire right off the bat you're
gonna have to outplay him in a gritty
tactical position I think Jan is going
to have to try to repeat that strategy
in the third game
for sure the players are getting wanted
and everybody wanted because there is a
huge prize front at stake they're trying
to take the all the fair play
precautions seriously and we see that
even for her Stein gretcherson who was
getting wanted when we cut over to this
graphic here he's playing for a five
thousand dollar difference between 7th
and eighth place and as you can see in
front of you the big prizes at the top
150
000 hikar Nakamura with the inside track
to that payday yeah give me some of that
says hicaro and it's not like he's going
to Canada afterwards to play for two
hundred thousand dollars so what a
Payday this could be for Mr Nakamura he
is one win away from securing that top
purse if he wins this next game he
scores two and a half points and the
final match concludes so Jan with his
back against the wall and we see the
players literally with their backs
against the wall you see Magnus Carlson
there not in the greatest of humors
today as Wesley getting wanded a little
chat going on to his left a nice little
waiting area there
always nice to see camaraderie between
the players that's fedes and greterson
there in the background all smiles
all smiles nothing much on the line let
me tell you Hikaru young they're
probably not smiling they're focused and
they can't wait for this next position
to be revealed
no they are very curious and where the
knights will be or the Bishops be in the
corner what's going on but the players
many of them talking to one another I
think hikar is talking to Federal save
over there we see Matthias bluebound
with his second Alexander donchenko
Wesley so joining the trio of phariseev
and Nakamura Jana palmchi back with
Nikita there he is yeah he's ready to go
and I'm talking about Nikita vitsugov
the Iceman the legendary Grandmaster
from Russia one of those players maybe
not as well known as he should be given
how strong of a player he is such a long
period of time God is so good he's like
27 30. life he's like a 27 30 lifer
right um he's like one of those NBA
players who averages 14 points a game
since his rookie year and contributes to
whatever team he's on vitagov has not
talked about enough not to mention that
he's a massive French expert probably
one of the leading in the world yeah I'm
a big Nikita guy when I played him with
white and Gibraltar a couple years ago I
was like I am making this draw right off
the bat I'm not even going to try to
test them well here we see Henrik
Carlson the father of Magnus Magnus he
doesn't seem to be particularly happy he
did win game two it looked like a nice
game and he will need to find his form
some more in the next two to take down
the very hungry Uzbek teenager notary
Beck Abdul sitarov he just dominated the
group stage of this event it wasn't
close it looked like he was going to run
away with the event but Hikaru Nakamura
was his Kryptonite and will Yanda
palmisi be able to stop Hikaru he's a
runaway train he's not looking back and
he's looking ahead to find out what this
position is going to be in games three
and four it yup and there we have it as
the pieces get placed we have a knight
in the corner once again
followed by The Rook I think that's the
king yeah I'm pretty sure that's the
king Grand Master can't identify pieces
the queen on its normal Square
then the bishop Rooks on the f file
Knights where they're supposed to be and
the Bishops in the corner so a couple of
similarities here Robert with uh the
regular chess configuration but still
unmistakably Fisher random-esque as the
players are gazing at the board there
we're looking from Notre back's vantage
point
and I'm wondering who neurobic is
standing next to over there but yeah it
seems like they're writing down the
where the pieces are trying to figure
out they're going to go find a spare
board to analyze this position for about
10 minutes before getting seated these
positions it just scrambles your brain
you're like wait I'm gonna play E4 wait
no actually that's a bishop on H1 not a
rook and there's my Rook over there and
you really need to have your head on
straight trying to map your way through
uh you need to be a cartographer to get
through these positions that's a great
comparison and you have to be able to
wipe the memory of the previous position
from your mind because it is going to
mess you up one tiny difference the
bishop on H1 instead of G1 completely
changes the nature of the position it
adds new Tactical patterns new geometry
and the players with their work cut out
for them in these next 10 minutes or so
for sure and while they start analyzing
the position Donnie and I will do the
same we need to be able to present it to
you so we will take a brief break and
when we return we're getting set for
game three here on Championship Sunday
live from Reykjavik Iceland it is the
Fisher random world championship this
coverage on chess.com brought to you by
Brave
[Music]
you guys this is a new variant it's
called duck dust chest but with a duck
quack quack how to play duck chess the
duck is a brick pieces cannot move
through the square occupied by the duck
click on a square to place the dog
oh he put the deck to prevent moves of
opponent not yourself
Yeah so basically you do this and this
cannot move I'm gonna go Knight F6 and
I'm gonna put the duck in the most
inconvenient place for my opponent to
move no Bishop no Queen so no londons
can permanently stop the London capture
the puns King to win oh wow though
there's no stalemate but still wait
there is still meat but the still made
the player wins ooh if only that was
real chess I think I'm getting the hang
of this game I think I think I actually
am getting the hang of it
I think this works oh that's a horrible
blunder oh my God I just blundered I
have to move something else first then
dark and Knight will take my king this
is the best way to lose the dog chest
[Music]
there are some real bullet skills right
there boys this is a fast time winning
duck chest so exciting
fighting oh no no no no no no slip no no
no no no no
yeah duck chess champion give me those
points baby
[Music]
all right
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and we have the scene from Reykjavik
Iceland this is the Fisher random World
Championship the coverage of chess.com
brought to you by Brave I'm Grandmaster
Robert Hess alongside me my very good
friend Grandmaster Daniel narodisky
Dania Hikaru Nakamura Yanda palmshi the
championship match Hikaru with that one
point lead but we do have the position
revealed so why don't you walk us
through the possibilities here and Jan
will have black in game three
great thank you for putting me on the
spot okay uh so happy to do it
the first thing that I like to do is
just sort of take a bird's eye view of
what the development is likely uh to
look like and some things we can kind of
say for certain for example we know that
if the Knight on A1 is to be developed
it'll probably come out to be three we
also know that both sides are probably
going to prioritize the development of
their light script Bishop because that's
some pretty low hanging fruit Robert so
immediately one first move that comes to
mind is G2 G3 we could see G3 G6 but
sometimes we see we see G3 and then the
other side tries to grab more space so
I'm curious to see how they're going to
arrange their pawns on the king side the
other thing I'd say is that it's
actually not so easy to handle King
safety the King on C1 is a little bit
awkward of course the easiest way to
Castle is Queen side but then your king
remains on C1 and it's obviously a
pretty flimsy Square you pointed out
during the break that castle in kingside
is a Herculean task here that would be
the ideal spot for the king but you
would have to basically clear the entire
first row in order to do that so those
are couple of observations that come to
mind have I done a halfway decent job I
think you've done a great job partner
and a couple things I would add is you
want to look for loose ponds A2 and H2
in the starting position not defended
how many games have we seen where
somebody just doesn't notice it and they
lose that pawn in fact Hikaru Nakamura
against nordebec abusatara in that first
game of their semifinals match hickar
had a sacrifice the pawn his position
was not very good but those pawns are
often loose and people lose them with
regularity so I'm with you with G3 ideas
another idea I would point out maybe is
F2 to F4 by advancing that pawn you
might put your knight on F3 behind it
controlling more of the center and then
G3 and so on so it's very difficult for
me to figure out where this dark Square
bishop and for white the light Square
Bishop for black E1 and E8 where those
Bishops belong that I am not positive
about but otherwise I think it's just a
fascinating position and the players
will really show us how to venture into
it it most certainly is and I'm going to
predict move one G3 on most boards
Knight B3 the other sort of initial
candidate that comes to mind I don't
think we're going to see too many early
Center Pawn pushers just because the
position is so undefined and you want to
be very careful about playing a move
like e2e4 just out of General
considerations because move like that
already carries the significant drawback
of blocking in your own Bishop so it's a
move that I assume the players will save
for a little bit later on the position
becomes a little bit better defined but
curious to see how they handle the
question of castling will both sides try
to clear the first row ASAP get the king
over to the king side or are they going
to keep this King and chill on C1 and uh
surround it with the Knight and the
Queen and other pieces
difficult question to answer and sort of
a game strategy and I'm wondering about
is Jan gonna take his same aggressive
approach like he did in game two or will
he say you know what I just need to hold
on game four will be where all the
nerves are I'll have a chance there as
well it's unclear to me how Jan is
strategizing for this game
yeah I I'd be very curious to know that
as well I am positive that he is
conferring with Nikita vitugov and
nikaru is conferring with himself
speaking of Hikaru and conferring we had
a an interesting feature chat question
uh as the players continue to analyze
and get ready for the game I think it
comes from Jake riegelman Robert and
Jake was asking our opinion on the
question of whether Hikaru is the true
rival Madness or if Yan has made a case
for himself as the true rival in the
last few years and I think the answer
depends largely on the time control but
I wanted to know your thoughts on that
uh it certainly depends on the time
control and Hikaru went on the Lex
Friedman podcast and he said that his
match that you know hotel room match
that people didn't really know about
it's kind of one of those urban legends
it's a a myth but it happened and Magnus
beats Hikaru in that match and ikara was
saying I probably shouldn't have played
him there because then he was able to
figure out my weaknesses what openings I
kind of played off-handedly where my
strengths were and Hikaru of course
struggled with Magnus over the years in
classical chess now if we're talking
about Blitz chess uh quicker tide
patrols then that they really scrap they
go Toe to Toe I think that Magnus he
doesn't really have a true rival at
least he hasn't historically he has just
been Head and Shoulders Above the Rest
of the Chess World and that's no
disrespect meant towards janapam
shirakara Nakamura just Magnus Carlson
as in the highest rated player by far
winning tournaments left and right
um that said so contextualizing it a bit
I do believe in the last bunch of years
where we've seen more access to these
players in these online formats Hikaru
has shown he can duke it out with him
and John Duda is a name that wasn't
mentioned in the question but he is
somebody who has beaten Magnus
plenty of times in the World Cup in 2021
in Sochi in the Champions chess tour
he's knocked him out a few times so a
youngster stuff dude I think has to be
added to that list even if he's not the
highest rated or near really the top few
highest rated players in classical chess
I think that's a great Point especially
in the context of His World Cup victory
over Magnus Carlson we have Jeffrey
Zhang the birthday boy in the chat happy
birthday to Grandmaster Jean He suggests
that he thinks that Hikaru should be
considered the main rival to Agnes and
if you reason in the narrow framework of
online chess especially during kova
times all of those Magnus tour events
like you said they were going neck and
neck they were going back and forth and
if they were to play let's say a three
plus zero blood smash maybe that'll
happen one day uh I think that they're
gonna go to that would be absolutely
fascinating uh but like you said it all
depends on your frame of reference and
in the classical time control I totally
agree with you Robert I think the whole
point of why Magnus is such a legend is
precisely because he's truly unrivaled
at the top of Chess Olympus and we see
Mr napomnishi taking his seat Crossing
his hands over his chest and studying
the board intently
okay well Jan getting ready for the
final stretch of this match two games to
go well it could only be one if he
happens to lose game three Magnus
Carlson will certainly have two more
games it is one to one against noribbeck
Abdul sitarov and I'm still thinking
about this rivalry question
um I it's funny because dingley Ren is
the number two rated player in the world
and yet
he hasn't really had a rivalry with
maggots they haven't actually played
that many times so it's just strange how
the Chess World plays out uh but there
are
potential people who can be claimed as a
rival for Magnus it just is Magnus he
has been the best for a long time and so
I don't know if he quite has a rival
like we've seen in other disciplines and
sports
yeah I agree completely I think that's a
great point on Hikaru taking his seat at
the white pieces adjusting them
carefully
the game should begin very very soon I
think Magnus needs a haircut I think
that might actually be the hidden
problem
I tried a good new Barber a couple days
ago I think I can refer him
I think the hair is is interfering with
his with his brain operation
well I think they're clapping for your
joke here
good one Donya way to be I've even made
that typical yawn fish that was
impressive
well John will have to play some
impressive chess in this next game and
uh we have seen players with the black
pieces doing quite well in Fisher random
and that's because the first move
Advantage is out the window when you
don't have an opening tree to work with
now we see a scandi where's John
Bartholomew when you need him this is a
Scandinavian type of idea trying to get
the queen out in the center but Hikaru
says no no no if we're gonna trade pawns
my Bishop is going to come alive I was
wrong but not like too wrong they do
play G3 and he did start with the move
E4 which I will be honest comes as a
surprise to me but I guess Jan just
prioritize our rather prioritizing
central control now the bishop opens
back up and white is not against
spending a couple of Tempe in order to
open up the center black has the move
Knight F6 in his pocket but Robert we
keep coming back to this point you don't
just want to develop with the same kind
of abandon that you do in regular chess
because these natural developing moves
almost always Block in another piece and
Knight F6 is the case in point you might
want to play it but you want to invest
some time before you decide to put your
knight on that natural Square
for sure and some other ideas that come
to mind for Jan napalms here is like
playing F7 to F5 now in the standard
game of chess you almost never push your
F Pawn so early it's the golden Pawn but
here F5 can be followed with E5 and
you're just throwing your pawns forward
in the center opening things up I still
don't like these knights in the corner
A1 and A8 so I would be tempted to make
a move like Knight B6 right now for yawn
so it depends on the style of position
that he wants right here because he can
just move his pieces or he can thrust
his pawns forward
weaned to D6 instead what an
unconventional way of playing is he
threatening like Queen A6 with some sort
of a fork
that be his idea taking a page out of
note Rebecca mrsarov's book but you know
what giving the pawn away on A2 is not
inherently scary giving it away with a
bishop capture now that's a different
story but I don't think Hikaru cares
about black spending too Tempe to take
this with his Queen
I just wanted to point it out as a cute
little pattern well while we're talking
about it let's show Knight B3 and if you
play Queen A6 with that double attack
have fun snack on that Pawnee too
because it's gonna be your last supper
very good one I'm actually trying to get
some sort of a rook sacrifice to work
but forget that for a second after 92
Queen takes A1 Queen takes A2 don't go
Rook A1 there's something called
Checkmate here but white doesn't even
need to trap the queen Robert White can
go for example Knight C3 and are you
really going to give up this lead in
development and this central control for
a measly Pawn the answer is probably no
and we're never going to find out
because Hikaru does prevent Queen A6
with his move Queen to e two what do you
make of this I really like that move
because you're just centralizing your
pieces now his Bishop is going to
retreat after Knight F6 I don't think
you want to give up that piece Bishop
slides back to G2 and then you see
White's control over the position you
have all the correct highlights in all
the correct colors uh the E5 squares
under White's control and so for Hikaru
the gameplay seems relatively
straightforward
I don't like nepo's position in the
early going this bind on E5 is actually
a very serious positional asset for
white and I think this is where the
players will have to return to the
question of King safety is right about
that time where a decision has to be
made from Black's perspective I think
okay black already can Castle kingside
but Castle in queenside might be a way
to spice the position up just a little
bit the drawback of pushing the pawn F4
is that White Castle in kingside is not
something that should be undertaken
lightly what do you think Hikaru is
going to do with this game or is he
going to put that off until he's got all
his pieces out
yeah the big question is whether he
trades Bishops or plays Knight F3
immediately I kind of like the look of
Knight F3 first uh just because the
bishop trade you're not going to grab
this E7 Pawn I think we really need to
show it because it's constructive Bishop
C6 Queen C6 Queen takes E7 I believe
would be a mistake because after Rook E8
you can say oh give me another Pawn I'll
take F7
G2 and your rook's under attack if your
Rook moves your Knights Lost Queen C4
look at the lack of development here for
white you actually don't really have
easy moves to make and after Queen D3
probably your only move Castle Queen
side
oh you can Castle Queen side oh
beautiful and look at this position this
is like the most one-sided position of
all time the queen continues jumping
around and Rook takes C1 Queen takes C2
finishes off the attack with track but
this is exactly how the game is gonna
end Hikaru usually loses games like this
uh he needs a refresher and uh you know
basic opening principles first of all
that queenside castle is awesome it's so
easy to forget that it's Leo because
typically your King has to go through
the D file but here I thought it was
illegal that's why I wasn't making the
move I was like I was like wait it would
be nice if you could Castle but you
can't the king is coming from C8 so
you're not Crossing d8 right and that's
exactly how you lose Fisher random games
you don't want to just grab material
because the development can come quite
quickly so Knight F3 is hit car's Choice
uh he's controlling that E5 Square I
think Jan will just go Knight to B6 and
the question becomes what is Jan's plan
to control important squares F4 Knight
F3 Queen E2 all cover E5 white has more
space in this position so I just like
the look of hikaru's setup thus far and
the one thing I like for Yan is he's
ahead in the clock I think that has
served him well throughout this Fisher
random championship
it has indeed and what I want people to
sort of understand is that it's not like
the E5 square is going to give white
victory in the next three moves but left
unchecked after white solves the problem
of his king after white gets the Knight
out of A1 a knight on E5 could inflict
tremendous damage on Black's position if
you have this permanent clamp on the
center it impedes the coordination of
Black's pieces and it just gives white a
powerful long-term advantage and it's
the exact wrong kind of there's no
advantage that you want to allow Hikaru
to get but I mean the worst kind of
position to have against icaro is this
kind of positional squeeze where he's
playing without risk and he continues
twisting the knife that is not upyan's
Ali I think he's going to have to take
perhaps even drastic action in the next
couple of moves to change the course of
the game and somehow contest as you said
hikaru's control over key Central
squares
and now Jan is going deep in the think
tank so this is bad news for him his
position is not favorable he is spending
time and I feel like Hikaru can just
simply develop right now after Knight B6
he can play Knight to B3 follow suit he
could push his D Pawn probably just one
square because I think a lot of people
think let's go D4 let's be as active as
possible push our pawns forward but you
want your dark Square Bishop to shine
and you want to cover those important
light squares so the pawn on D3 covers
E4 as in the green highlight and allows
your Bishop to go to C3 to contest for
the long diagonal whoa I gotta see that
again
it's a replay spaceship air nepalanishi
Airlines Flight 101 cleared for takeout
Castle's Queen side
unfortunately the the pleasure of this
move is short-lived because Hikaru your
response to the bishop F2 and he says I
think I want some of that too now he's
ready to Castle kingside and he's ready
to shift this Bishop over to C5 and get
this Queen off of the center
wow big moment here for Yan I mean
Knight A4 is an odd way to deal with
that threat Knight E4 attacks the bishop
on F2 and cover C5 but then the bishop
just moves out the way and then D3 is
going to become an annoying threat so I
feel like 94 is not the solution you may
initially think it is
and an apple solution is to drop the
Knight back to D7 this prevents Bishop
C5 and his dream of course is to
liberate uh himself by pushing the pawn
up to E5 essentially clearing the blind
that is the only way to address White's
vine on the E5 square but he is a very
long way away from doing that and Robert
White doesn't even have to panic and
play this D4 move white and Castle
kingside black is not ready to play E5
and if necessary white can put a rook on
you on a bishop on D4 there are a
million ways that white could reinforce
his control over the E5 Square
for sure
um the one downside I would say about
castling kingside is what often happens
in regular standard chess Knight G4 when
you've pushed your f-pawn your dark
swear has become a problem so is this
bishop uh you know really oh here yeah
of course good tactic to show uh black
would win a piece on D4 with check very
importantly and is the bishop gonna go
back to E1 I don't think so you're not
going to take on A7 that looks terrible
so it feels like black is suddenly
springing to life
yeah that's a very good point so if you
want to play Bishop D4 you kind of have
to do it now before the Knight moves
away from F6
uh of course that is not
obligatory either I mean Hikaru could
keep his King on C1 the king for the
time being is quite safe I wouldn't rule
out the possibility of White Castle in
queenside but my intuition says that
that kind of gives black the imbalance
that nepo really wants in a position
like this
it's so crazy to me that just a couple
moves ago we're like oh I don't see a
plan for Yan and then I'm like wait I
don't really know what Hikaru does here
that is what Fisher random does to my
brain I'm like oh I like the look of it
wait a second the king went to the other
side of the board forgot about that this
is what it looks like now E5 is an idea
Knight G4S comes to mind make yourself
right at home nepo yeah he's ready for
his nap don't get him a blanket someone
gets him
get him a neck pillow you know he's uh
getting on the Jet Plane but Bishop D4
done it if Hikaru plays that I think Jan
might play Bishop D5 in response and
follow up with C7 C5 kicking the bishop
out of the center I feel like Jan has
very good opportunities in this position
to Parry off the initial threats and
then expand his pawns which we've been
sort of complaining about
yeah I agree that I like to separate you
know the position in terms of current
and potential energy in terms of the
current energy White's got control over
the center White's got the good position
you mentioned that fisher random does
this to your brain and that's part of
the reason why sometimes when you look
at a position in its current form you
see the awkwardness among the ranks but
it's harder to sort of prognosticate
what's going to happen when all of the
pieces are brought out onto good squares
and I think what you're saying is that
once yon solves a few of the immediate
problems in his position his pieces are
actually really well coordinated he
doesn't have any weaknesses and we
shouldn't overstate the case just
because white controls one square I
think John is doing a good job of this
so far but he's gotten many more
problems to solve starting with the
question of where to put this bishop is
Bishop D5 possible or is there some sort
of a trick here
well we're about to find out I was
actually thinking I was listening I was
calculating C4 okay C1 we have to remind
everybody that that King can quickly
dart on over to G1 like White's next
candy King picked up and put on G1 so
that is what Hikaru is likely relying on
here and I'm kidding you could even do
it here if you wanted to but it is
important to show that uh what the plan
is so C4 that really was not what I was
expecting
um
what what would your response be it
should be four I have an idea D3 and I
was thinking maybe bishop takes D3 okay
Queen takes
C5 then just castle and white has to be
yeah that's the problem at the end of
the day you castle and I keep forgetting
that I keep thinking I'm opening up the
queen side I'm gonna start attacking
your king it's like white has the cheat
code and so black cannot put all of his
eggs in one basket nepo
takes on F3 okay that's a big move
I wouldn't want to part ways with that
Bishop but at least he keeps the
initiative going
and maybe he wants to meet Knight F3
with Knight G4
whoa Bishop takes F3 allowing E5
and E5 white does have the tempo move
Knight B5 hitting the queen on D6 A7 is
also hanging like I I was saying earlier
you don't want to take that pawn but
there could be a time where the bishop
snags that pawn A7 and then runs right
back somewhere to like E3 so I like the
look of E5 practically speaking it gives
yon very good chances he is sitting here
calculating uh the Knight on D4 is also
a little bit loose so if you could time
a knight jump correctly and simple chest
from Beyond the Palm machine great move
and the engine approves
great patient mature professional move
right there C6 let me blunt the bishop
let me cover the B5 Square let me not
rush with the movie five because that
move ain't going anywhere white has lost
a lot of his control over the E5 square
and I think you called it I think the
trend of the game is squarely in Black's
favor would you agree with that I
co-signed it like if you Castle kingside
get that King out of there go to G1 then
E5 is still a very good move and one of
the biggest problems that's the hugest
problems like this sounded weird a huge
problem for white is this Pawn on D2
it's a backwards Pawn so if you trade
pawns on E5 now the Knight gets in a
rook comes to d8 you're not gonna get
the move D2 to D4 and that's what you
really need great tactic that you're
showing here that the uh three is lose
but the D2 Pawn would much rather be
where the Knight is on D4
yeah if you could move the Knight back
push D4 and move the bishop away and
play H3 to cover G4 okay that's a mere
four Tempe everything would be in order
but why does it even close to getting
one of those things done this position
could deteriorate even further once
black puts a rook on the eight and
x-rays the queen
there's Knight G4 in the cards that
Bishop on h8 is rearing to go jumping
out of its cage it's crazy how
everything changes the moment that white
relinquishes his control over this key
Square this game has been a battle of
square control and right now black has
jumped out in front
oh that's right I just don't like the
look of this position the Contour is are
just not in hikara's favor and look at
the clock by the way now it's opening up
into a two and a half soon to be three
minute lead for Jan his play is easier
and that pawn on D2 is a long term
Target it's gonna be stuck in place and
Hikaru is probably not enjoying the
sight of his position right now well
hikar is trying to decide what he should
prioritize he can temporarily prevent E5
but I don't think he can prevent it
forever if he plays Ricky one Jan just
Shadows him with rook fe8 and that makes
the threat of E5 even stronger do you
think that white should white the bullet
and Castle or should white maybe drop
the Knight back preemptively so that E5
doesn't come with Tempo does that help
I just feel like I'd be scared scared
here with white yeah cause the king's
still on C1 so let's say you move your
knight to B3 or something and then black
plays E5 anyway
if you take on E5 the Knight just jumps
out he played Knight B3 so he might see
us no Bishop C5 because Knight D3 check
great point is still out in the open
it's not covered on G1 so this would
allow tactical shots and John's not even
in his chair right now after a car is
moved he'll come back and I'm guessing
he'll play E5 quite quickly all that
caffeine and that coke is settling in
the Anna has to jump around the playing
Hall he's feeling confident here you can
just tell he seems somewhat relaxed to
this game and this is the kind of
attitude that brought him success
yesterday you can see Hikaru there
hunched over the board studying it
intently trying to figure out what to do
if Jan shoves that E5 Pawn E7 Pawn up
two squares to E5
I could have said that in a much less
verbose manner but you know
gotta gotta commsky
I'm glad you said it because I didn't
want to interrupt you with the FFL the
famous effin Legend but right now Hikaru
Nakamura he's got his head in his hands
he's trying to will himself to
appreciate his position more I mean that
pawn on D2 is an issue so if you play E5
for black your pieces are coming to life
and one more important thing done this
let's say E5 chop shop and D4 so like I
want to get D4 and Robert keeps telling
me I need to push that pawn there the
problem combination to put that pawn
yeah yeah that you could take on F3 and
when the queen takes back you no longer
will be able to Castle uh King side if I
put a rook on E8 so I can say no
castling for you to that way and if you
Castle King up to the queen side where
the king currently is again your king is
not in a safe spot you don't want your
pawns out on C4 like this when your
King's on that side of the board
and blackened contribute to the problems
with the move B5 carving out this
incredibly uh Dynamic and strong outpost
on D5 this is a classic idea in a lot of
karokon lines where you get the this
type of opposite side castling nepo you
didn't have to ask him twice E5 is on
the board and hikara responds with the
patient and the
quiet move Bishop E3 I like it he keeps
keeping the tension and obviously he
takes F4 not possible because the bishop
recaptures skewering the queen and the
Rook so if Rook comes to E8 there's
something that Hikaru can rely on here
so obviously just like Rook
FEA B8 I'm not sure which one but let's
say FEA
Castle's King side for white he takes F4
it doesn't actually hurt what you would
think you can't take with the bishop
because the queen is hanging but Black's
Queen is also hanging and that's a
problem
and to add insult to injury here both of
the Rooks are hanging so maybe in the in
this narrow sense it would probably be
better to play Rook B8 but then both
Rooks are hanging anyway
because at the end of the line there's a
rook on f8 that's some funny geometry
and look at nepo a7a5 as he strikes at
the other side of the board and he
threatens to push this Knight into
Timbuk2 with the move A4
wow this
big moment in this game right now
because A5 is a wonderful shot just
trying to distract the Knight pawn count
isn't as important as king safety and
Jana palmchi has shown that time and
time again I guess Magnus Carlsen
yesterday he gave away two pawns on the
uh GNH files and the F5 Pawn as well he
had no pawns on the king side and then
he launched a devastating attack and
look at him he is like all right I'm
feeling this A5 how is Hikaru gonna deal
with it and he may play the move Pawn to
D4 just to try to open the position up
finally get rid of that backwards Pawn
but I'm worried about the king that's
really the problem that I'm seeing here
I think that's going to be an issue that
remains yeah this is such a hard move to
play because just optically after e
takes D4 can't really take with the trip
because of A4 if you take with a knight
you walk right into this nasty pin what
makes this pin so much nastier is the
fact that the bishop on E3 lacks support
so does the Knight your pawns aren't
defending any of the minor pieces and so
everything is loosey-goosey the night
jumping out to C5 black is a lot of
these obvious improving moves and I
agree that this might be the Lesser evil
perhaps you can Castle queenside here
and keep everything together but that is
just such a hard sequence to play
especially in a rapid game with your
time Limited Hikaru with his back
against the wall here I I think
objectively the position might still be
perhaps even close to balanced according
to the email part but there is such a
wide golf Robert between what the engine
says and how you feel when you have this
position of the white pieces right this
isn't King and pawn versus King and pawn
and uh just making a draw this is
dynamic equality somehow if you find all
of the Right Moves and after the move d4
it's not like black even has to take on
D4 though I like the look of that you
can thrust your Pawn for the E4 follow
up with Dania as a B5 just open this
board up there's a king on C1 that's
typically what we call King and it's
starting place in the center of the
board but it's close enough to the
center the Rooks are not connected look
at the coordination of Black's pieces
sure white has a pair of Bishops top
level Grandmasters love themselves a
good Bishop pair but when your pieces
are all over the place your Pawn
structure is a bit odd and black has
this harmony going on the bishop on h8
in the corner defending the 996 looking
down the diagonal the Knight on D7 ready
to spring forward to E5 the Knight out
of six covering the E4 Square Rook ready
to go to E8 this A5 Pawn red distract
the Knight on B3 blacks pieces are so in
tune with one another White's pieces
discombobulated and I think that the
perfect operative word that you used
there was Harmony Black's pieces are all
fulfilling easily identifiable roles
there are more roles to be fulfilled
zero unemployment among Black's ranks
after the Rooks get to E8 and d8 all of
the pieces even some of the pawns are
doing specific work white spaces they're
performing tasks and roles but largely
those roles are defensive and this
bishop on F3 kind of lame just sort of
staring at the C6 pawn and Hikaru
Nakamura deciding on the move d4 it's on
the board the position's starting to
heat up Tabasco sauce being added after
black takes on D4 which nepo does
without further delay
wow and the Knight captures back on D4
so I like to move rookie E8 that you
pointed out before Rook F to E8 looks
very good if white decides to Castle
Queen side your king is going to be out
in the open if your king Castle's King
side you lose a piece in the squad as
you show that variation of night before
oh I guess any move order works but the
point is the E3 Bishop is captured and
then Bishop takes D4 with the queen
takes that Rook you lose your queen
there because of the pin so uh now there
are tactics in the air castling
queenside avoids the loss of material
but your king will permanently be unsafe
and
oh you might see two a car can't Castle
now that's a terrifying game no you
can't oh it's the same it's the same
thing that we saw in Black gasoline
Queen inside both of us again have this
instinct to say oh the D file is cut by
the Black by The Black Queen but the
king starts on C1 all you have to do is
shift The Rook around 2d1 but if I may
make a quick philosophical Point Robert
you like to point out that one of your
favorite aspects of sports is when
offense turns into defense to kind of
piggyback off of that and that Rook
takes E3 Knight G4 line that we just we
just saw we saw one of White's formerly
greatest strengths the pawn on F4
guarding E5 turning into the bane of
White's existence and so I really think
that this represents the multifaceted
nature of Chess how something uh that
allows you to control the game and
potentially win the game turns into
precisely the factor that loses you the
game just a couple of moves later
because the position changes you've used
the word control in this game and to
describe Hikaru Nakamura as felt like an
app sorry descriptor but in this
particular their game I feel like Hikaru
has already lost control from an early
stage it doesn't mean he's going to lose
that doesn't mean his position is beyond
repair but even a move like B5 for
janapanichi here he says you can bring
that Rook from B1 to D1 but are you sure
you want to do that if the B file is
about to open up so I just feel like hit
card does not have control over this
position and Beyond the Palm Street
despite giving away key squares in the
center early on once he was able to
strike with E5 and gain space the bishop
pair who cares let's go with the open
board and blacks pieces are doing good
work
and I think there's no question that
white is going to Castle Queen side
Hikaru has committed to that with his
last move he's not going to Castle
kingside if he moves The Rook from F1
then he cannot Castle kingside once uh
The Rook in question has been moved so
my guess is that we're going to see
either Knight C5 or your excellent
suggestion B5 preparing to open up the B
file and if black can get that done that
Bishop that Rook they're looking at one
pawn and they have blood on their mind
man oh man is this an unpleasant
position the one thing Jan has to avoid
Robert is getting into time pressure
here he has to do what he has done so
well throughout the tournament and
against Magnus trust his Instinct and
find that happy medium between
calculation and intuition
for sure I mean this position it looks
like it's ready to explode the barrier
it's going to open up and there he goes
B5 engines
this is just a problem for Hikaru and
maybe he has a way out I think for
Hikaru he needs to untangle and he made
a quick move there he castled Queen side
and he says I literally don't care about
the opening of the BF file you could
have it but I actually feel very
concerned for his King safety Bishop on
h8 that is lurking in the corner
and it's not just the B file that
presents problems if white goes C5 to
try to close it down then the e-file is
the reason that white collapses after
Knight takes C5 he's pinned and skewered
and attacked all over the place on all
sides of the board so I just don't see
an easy way uh as you said for white to
untangle if the queen just calmly drops
back to C7 it is important for yawn to
keep this C6 Pawn defended because that
pawn kind of anchors the entire position
you don't want to go Queen f8 and give
that pawn up I can make these moves on
the board B5 castles why involve
yourself with these complications would
you agree with that I certainly agree I
mean you're just giving away a bunch of
Pawns and then you have to prove that
you have enough compensation so if you
can keep the material as is well you
know you're better your pieces are all
looking in the correct direction and C4
is about to be captured opening the B
file you mentioned C5 not available
because the pin on the e-file I don't
know Queen C7 for sure is the way to go
keeping your queen uh nice and tucked
away while defending the base of your
pawns and a point that I like to make
frequently is a point made to me by
Yasser many years ago that really stuck
with me yes sir pointed out that
endortment in 1970. Yasser pointed out
that very often you think of the queen
as the leading attacker well the queen
should be involved it should be you know
at the front lines but if you look at
how very strong players attack
oftentimes the queen is actually
directing the attack from a distance
because it's such a valuable piece you
want to make sure that it doesn't kind
of stumble uh and bumble around and
often that means keeping the queen back
back and waiting for the perfect
opportunity to strike right now
blackstroke black snipe and the other
rook and the bishop are more than
capable of handling the attack the queen
lies in weight and fulfills a crucial
defensive role that is no less important
than the attacking roles fulfilled by
Black's other pieces and there are
already so many tactics that white needs
to keep an eye out for because if you
just pick that Knight up and he was
Queen to D3 so B takes C4 and now we can
actually just see this bc4 queen takes
C4 and then pick up the Knight F6 I'm
not sure where it goes but hold it up
for a second the B2 Pawn is loose
because the Rook on B and the bishop
Nation maybe Knight E4 maybe Knight G4
I'm not sure if it's enough to give away
a full piece but the point is it looks
like an attack is about to hurt White's
King I think Knight G4 should be
seriously contemplated here if we follow
this line real quick Bishop takes B2
check okay King B1 I no wish upon
exactly I wouldn't wish upon my worse
than enemy you have to take a dip in the
center and here it actually is hard for
black to find a follow-up maybe Rook bd8
maybe moving the Knight away with Tempo
to open up the D file is the way to go
if you can get rid of this Bishop Robert
then the king is essentially toast
because it will be cut off along the
e-file so in pageant having this
position with white with less than 10
minutes on the clock if there's one
player I trust with their intuition in a
tactical Skirmish down a piece but
against an open King it is yon napomishi
this guy is amongst the best has always
been and you can hear all the top
players go back in their interviews talk
about Jan as a generational Talent so he
is knowing that this is the moment he
took on C4 Hikaru took back with his
Queen and you know he just wants to pick
up that Knight somehow he wants to put
it somewhere anywhere and win this Pawn
on B2 This Is The Moment of Truth there
are so many tactical possibilities we
haven't even talked about the sacrifice
on E3 followed by Queen B6 attacking
both the Knight and the pawn at the same
time it's not quite the devastating Fork
that it appears because the White Queen
can slide back to E2 and guard both of
these uh liabilities at the same time
and for Yan once again it's so important
to make a decision relatively fast to
leave himself with enough time to
conduct the attack but at the same time
this is obviously a crucial moment where
the correct decision is the difference
between
critical win and a very painful loss
wow Rook takes E3 is also a nice looking
move he has so many options here he
knows that that King on C1 is unsafe and
Hikaru he's probably saying let me just
get one free turn you mean that one
chance because then he can make sure
that his King ultimately finds safety
but Knight G4 I really like the look of
that one Rook takes E3 is hard to pass
up Dania I mean now that you know
yeah
no I mean I was just going to say that
the Soviet School Boy Inside Me says you
know what if you don't want to calculate
you want to keep yourself with enough
time I wouldn't rule out a move like C5
okay defend the pawn prevent Bishop D4
technically not preventing it but it
doesn't look all that appetizing and you
know keep all of your potential tactical
opportunities alive do you agree that a
case could be made for a slower move
like this as tempting as it is to go
down the rabbit hole of these sacrifices
I kind of love C5 because
you're gonna bring your knight to B6
and you're just gonna attack attack
attack if white plays B3 just to make
sure that B2 isn't lost look at that
diagonal and look at the bishop on h8
that is the money piece in this game and
even if there's not an immediate
Checkmate you can't line the queen and
Bishop up like the queen going to G7
would be awesome your Queen's not
getting to the diagonal yet but A4 C4
ideas to blast open where the white king
is and the side with the safer King is
typically the side with the advantage
who cares about the bishop pair look at
this King on G8 shielded no attackers
against it the King on C1 I don't like
the look of that
I don't like the look of that King
either and I think neither does Hikaru
and I think a lot of people in their
minds they associate the words attack
and sacrifice almost as synonyms they
think of them as part of the same
operation that's not always true you
don't always have to attack by
sacrificing you can just attack by
attacking and I think C5 is a great
example of a move that may not look all
that sexy but gets a lot done but
yanepam Nishi he cannot resist and
secretly Robert I love seeing this we
have our first sacrifice of the game
Rook takes E3 and queen B6 is on the
board here we go what strap yourselves
in what a try here for yonda palmshi
Hikaru Nakamura better be resilient
because once again this king's gonna
come under Fire I just want to give a
shout out to the over 45
000 people watching on Twitter YouTube
thank you so much for being so great
appreciate all the subs and primers out
there who make these shows possible and
right now the impossible might have to
happen for a car Nakamura how do you
save your king because there's a queen
of Rook barreling down the B file a
bishop on h8 waiting in the wings the
Knight on E3 is loose Donna you pointed
out that the queen can move back to
defend somehow like Queen B3 covers the
B file also protects the Knight but then
the black queen steps out the way to A7
and there's still tactics available or
A6 whichever way you want to go the
bishop on h8 that's the best piece it is
better than a rook I would argue and the
B2 Pawn is still a huge Target
and notice how patiently that Bishop is
lying in weight yawn resisting the
temptation to move this Knight too early
he's waiting for the perfect moment for
when the attack on B2 reaches ahead as
he knifes his way into White's position
with this last slide of the queen from
C7 flicking it on 2b6 hitting it where
it hurts and for Hikaru you're right the
big choice is between two queen moves
Queen E2 defends from the center Queen
B3 defense from the queen side and
forces black screen off of the b-file
but obviously carries the drawback of
kicking the can down the road after
black speed moves away you pointed out
that again White's Queen will have to
find a safe haven and I don't know if
there is a single safe Square to be
found on this entire board also last
thing notice that black screen from A7
once again following yasser's advice
directing the attack from a distance and
playing as crucial of a role as all of
the other pieces combined
it's true and right now Hikaru he's
digging deep the eval bars hovering
around the center and white is up
material but the king is not safe and
Hikaru under eight minutes so yawned
with a slightly in the clock only 21
moves have been made so nine more turns
for these players to reach move 30 gain
an extra five minutes and the five
second increment and Donya some
positions easy to make nine moves a
series of Trades uh it's an end game
whatever right here nine moves in seven
minutes and 20 seconds eternity good
luck Santa Cara Nakamura because his
King is going to come under Fire but if
there's a player We Trust in a Time
scramble it certainly is Hikaru and
Hikaru fans might be saying well why
isn't he moving why isn't he leaving
himself with enough time if he knew what
to do he would be moving he understands
the gravity of the decision that is in
front of him he understands that Queen
E2 and queen B3 they may look similar
but they lead into entirely different
positions after Queen E2 you have to
consider every single night Sally you
have to consider Knight D5 and rookie 8
and Knight C5 there is so much
calculation to do and not enough time to
do it in kikaru is going to invest as
much time as it takes for him to be
absolutely sure that he is making the
practically best decision about where to
put his Queen I don't know what the
practically best decision is that's why
Hikaru was sitting there in Reykjavik
I'm sitting in my heated room in
Charlotte you know
um giving giving wrong lines and
sacrificing other people's pieces well
let me ask you a question in the event
of Queen E2 the most natural move that
comes to my mind is Knight D5 hitting
the Knight on E3 hitting you where it
hurts on B2 with that Bishop oh and I
guess that is what it is you know it's
just a winning attack for black it would
appear basically so how the eval bar
reacted okay Knight takes 65 you want to
grab B2 I would love to grab B2 oh my
gosh and after King C2 I think there is
this uh at the very least this
Intermezzo check on C5 driving the king
further into the center we don't have to
analyze any further that should be
pretty obvious to everybody and the
worst thing Robert is that black hasn't
even sacrificed that much black has
sacrificed in exchange for a pawn big
deal
so black can have his cake and eat it
too in a lot of these lines
that's what Hikaru is trying to work out
here like if he doesn't have Queen E2 in
the live position Queen B3 but he knows
Queen A7 is the auto reply and then he
needs come up with an answer after that
your point Queen D4 but being in line
with that Bishop on eight shade that
looks scary you know it's the same thing
as Queen B3 yeah black queen will not
trade it will move out the way and then
you need to find you're following I
think that's what Hikaru wants Daniel is
he wants to make move one and then when
the black queen moves out the way he
makes his second move right away to put
yawn on the clock yeah without question
and he will have to because now he has
dropped to five minutes and now below
five minutes as he leans in studying the
position in tally John he has his Coke
on one side he's got his water on the
other he's taking sips of each he's
watching Hikaru suffer and now he
watches Hikaru move his Queen back to B3
the decision has been made and I have a
feeling as does the evil Bart that this
is far more prudent and far more
practical of a defensive try Robert than
allowing that Knight D5 idea after Queen
E2 for sure and you see a card was ready
to move his Queen but he didn't move yet
he's probably a bit nervous considering
the stakes and the attack that is about
to hurt his King on C1 so where is he
moving that Queen to he moved it to A3
oh wow
and I think we're gonna see Knight D5
and I'm looking at that C4 the eval bar
hated that move you can't really blame
the car he's keeping an eye on B2 but as
you said Knight D5 yeah
you do the honors Rook B4 you're just
kicking that Knight around because if
the Knight moves B2 hangs
and if it doesn't move well the question
how do you defend it B3 is oh again I
almost want to say let's not talk about
it I'm sure black has to still be
accurate probably Queen C5 is the
winning move setting up a discovery
White's Queen is literally no squares
you could take on A5 does it help Rook
takes E4 still eliminates the defender
so that's out of the question if you're
not playing B3 well then how are you
defending the Knight maybe bishop B2
keeps black a lot keeps White alive but
after Knight B6 black is gonna Force
this Knight off of C4 Bishop takes B2 is
going to come and it's gonna win West
Queen I think Jan is one move away from
potentially gaining the decisive
Advantage Knight D5 has been played and
Rook before I think will be played
without any further delay Rook B4 is
such a logical move and I think there's
one line that illustrates your earlier
point that black has not given up a ton
of material for The Rook if Rook before
happens and white takes this Knight on
The Rook before just play it does Bishop
D5 where a car grabs it cd5 you have to
take back Knight E5 let's start trading
pieces to save my king but after the
swap on E5 an eventual Bishop takes E5
it is a bishop and one Pawn for the rook
and the white king is in worse shape
oh that's a great point and B2 is still
hanging and Black's attack rages on for
the foreseeable future this is happening
95 is on the board now no question
Robert that this is a much better
practical chance uh as opposed to
something like B3 which really is not a
chance at all loses immediately at least
here Hikaru keeps his King alive and we
have seen for so many years how he's
able to come back from the dead
regardless of how much time he has on
the clock or how weak his King asicaro
is impossible to Checkmate in a lot of
these positions and janapamshi he's now
down to uh six minutes and change still
ahead in the clock that was White's 26th
move it's not gonna be an easy next set
of moves for Hikaru Nakamura but so far
he's hanging in there the evaluation bar
has been swinging in yonda palmistry's
favor the B2 Pawn is the Target that he
needs to build up pressure on and Jan
takes that Knight 95 immediate capture
back and my big question question here
done it is Queen C5 no he takes back up
you brushed it a little bit
I think he should have given this check
I'll show this really really quickly
after Queen C5 the difference is that
after Bishop B5 Rook D2 there would have
been Rook takes B2 check game is not
over white grabs The Rook with the queen
maybe Jan evaluated this position at
that well I'm probably gonna lose my
deep on no question that white has great
drawing chances here but I think this
was the top computer recommendation
instead he keeps his options open but
now Queen C5 check Robert that ship has
sailed if you give the check now white
has both Rook C2 as well as king D1 and
obviously Queen C5 doesn't come with the
same luster as it did on the previous
move
well I actually think that Rooks this is
a beautiful variation
um I believe that Rook C2 doesn't quite
work out for when Bishop takes B2 check
and after Queen takes B2 Queen
giving you that check taking on B2 so
King went to D1 Hikaru scurries away
into the center of the board that's
something you typically want to do when
pieces are attacking you but he realizes
that Rook C2 didn't work King B1 fell
for the tactic so now the question for
young the Palm she can he actually take
the pawn on B2 I believe the answer is
yes the Tactics still favor his ability
to capture on B2 but with four minutes
and 30 seconds look at him he is over
the board he is trying to make the
tactic work he's looking at the B2
Square he set his beverages aside and he
is calculating your recommendation
Bishop takes B2 and the reason this
works is that Rook takes B2 meets with
the devastating discovery on the queen
and again White's King is the bane of
his existence your wife has to keep the
stroke as the only protector of The King
and I think white can keep the game
going by sliding the queen to the other
side and suddenly Robert it is black who
has to deal with the main thread on F7
and the check on C1 might not be quite
as devastating as it appears somehow the
white king zigzags and Maneuvers and
jumps its way around the obstacles and
stays alive
wow what a position we have here in a
chip chip match and that was White's
29th move King to D1 so black has this
move and the next to make to gain five
minutes on the clock but even once those
five minutes are gained and the five
second increment is allotted to the
players per move after move 30. it's
still such a complicated position yes
Dania you showed the right continuation
Bishop takes B2 Queen F3 but even if
black just brings the queen back to E7
white king is going to be in trouble for
the remainder of the game until the
Queens are traded off the board but Jan
is not going to trade Queens no no no no
you will most certainly not unless it
can take three or four pawns with him
but this is beginning to remind me of
the previous game now nepo's down on the
clock you can just sense the change in
his body language you can sense that I
feel like he was hoping that there would
be a knockout blow that there would be
some winning move and he's really gonna
kick himself if he doesn't win this game
for not giving that preliminary check on
C5 for rushing Bishop takes E5 which you
can't blame him for but Queen F3 is on
the board and this is a tough tough spot
for nepo he does not want to lose either
of these pawns definitely not F7 but
losing D5 could also result in a
deterioration of his winning chances
right no that's a fair point especially
if a queen trade can be offered in the
process so if you play Queen E7 to
safeguard your Pawn F7 Queen takes D5
already threatens Queen d8 exactly with
the queen so Bishop F6 looks like a very
nice defensive resource because uh sorry
after well actually
wow I was really going for Queen E7
Queen takes D5 and then Bishop F6 just
to protect the d8 square and open up the
B file thinking that black has great
chances to go after the white king and
White's big threat was eliminated agree
completely but psychologically this can
be a hard line to go to because here
nepo is saying yeah listen I'm not going
to Checkmate you in the next couple of
moves although Rook B1 is indeed
virtually a Checkmate threat but he has
to come to terms with the fact that this
is probably going to be a long game
ikaro is going to keep defending for 10
15 more moves John has to abandon the
hope of finding a knockout blow and keep
some time on his clock this is however
his 30th move so he can take the
remainder of his 90 seconds because of
how important this moment is and then
Robert we will need to strap ourselves
in extra tight because we will be
playing a Blitz game from this position
here we go Queen E7 is on the board
yes he Retreats it's just a sensible
decision he now has six minutes and 26
seconds
pen final with go Wesley he always says
that no matter if Wesley's playing or
not he is playing so we should remind
everybody that there are other matches
going on right now Wesley's taking on
Vladimir Fredo said but we are going to
keep our eyes don't worry the
championship matchup is Nakamura
napomnishi and right now this D5 Pawn
can be captured but akaru is not grabbed
it yet he might be thinking about
another move to throw in here but Dania
it's currently a bishop and two pawns
for a rook so if we just do the math
three plus two equals five so the bishop
of the two pawns equal that rook and
with the Kings the way they are this is
clearly in Black's favor so Queen 65 you
take one of the pawns you're up material
but with the King unsafe on D1 black
remains better despite the material
deficit and I agree with you completely
I think if you don't take the pawn on D5
that pawn can be reactivated Born Again
from the dead as an attacker you could
push it down to D4 and create an anchor
point for that black Bishop on C3 I just
don't see a reason for white to inflict
any further pain on himself when Queen
takes D5 doesn't lose immediately and
forces the bishop back from B2 I would
be shocked if Hikaru doesn't take this
Pawn so you might ask well why is he
thinking guess what look at his King
look at the number of blacks threats he
has to ensure that he sees a defense
after Bishop F6 because Robert Rogue B1
is actually not that easy of a move to
Parry if effectively no it's not and he
might be thinking about like a rook sack
exchange sec I should say for that
Bishop 106 trying to trade Queen let's
show that very quickly Bishop Queen D5
Bishop F6 Rook F6 Queen F6 and queen
check this end game if the a pawns were
gone it would be a draw if the queen
yeah King G7 looks good whatever but if
the Queens are traded on F6 without the
a pawns this would be a draw with the a
pawns much more difficult for white
because Blackfoot A4 A3 and white can't
just sit the king over on G2 because the
A2 Pawn is a problem and The Rook can go
up to B2 with the pawn coming up to A3
for black so this is not that simple
it's not a straightforward a set of
decisions for akaru and that is why he's
using his time wisely right now great
point I think this is such an important
line to highlight and it's so important
to highlight that The Rook on B4 is
optimally placed in the context of the
same game you mentioned A4 A3 the other
idea is to position the Rook on A4 and
tie white down to D2 I I think this is
an absolute Last Resort for Hikaru I
feel like he would only go for an end
game like this if he truly feels that in
all other avenues he essentially gets
checkmated or he loses all of his pieces
he would much rather seek his fortunes
especially in the framework of a Time
scramble in a position with the queen
still on the board and with a material
advantage still as something to suffer
for if you're playing with the white
pieces and we agree with you rodrigovich
these this is one of the many games that
remind us of why chess is such a great
game this started as Fisher random the
pieces were all over the place but this
is chess at its finest and we have two
of chess's finest Hikaru Nakamura and
yawn the palm tree now Yan he may be
swiveling in his chair but that's
because the tactics are swiveling around
in his head he's trying to figure out
when this bishop leaves the B file is
Rook B1 going to be a knockout a car
saying can I grab this Pawn on D5 down
here another idea that comes to mind is
maybe throwing in the move Rook D2 to F2
first just to pile up more pieces on the
F7 Pawn the problem is black and play
Rook B7 and the orbrook D4 check I guess
you know I was thinking of retreating
move a queen D5 is not available because
Rook D7 with the PIN and you can't even
get two Rooks for the queen if you say
oh let me take the rook and let me take
the this shot you're in check and again
and again we see that King on D1 costing
white the game in a lot of these lines
another question that Hikaru might be
tackling here is which piece to take on
D5 with I somehow forgot that Rook takes
D5 is very much a possibility and the
Zen behind this move could be to keep as
you were suggesting the queen of The
Rook on the app file in order to at
least somewhat limit the mobility of
white screen of course the problem here
much the same as in Queen takes D5
couldn't be connected to the bishop
dropping back opening up the B file and
black is just harassing white on all of
the Avenues on all three sides of the
board what an unenviable task fighter as
he drops now to below five minutes
we knew it would not be easy for him
even when he reached the time control
gaining five minutes on the clock you
could give him 55 minutes an hour and
five minutes three hours it would still
be a difficult position to work out so
Rook E1 attacking the queen on E7 the
bishop can slide back to E5 opening up
the B file but Jan has to be certain
that's a good idea because you're
walking into a pin of your own so it's
not the simplest move to play in fact he
plays it is retreating he plays Bishop
in three three
what a deep defensive idea about your
car and I stand corrected
I said I'd be shocked if he doesn't take
on D5 well I am shocked
but the more I look at this the more I'm
beginning to appreciate the sort of
underlying philosophy between behind how
Hikaru has chosen to defend this Robert
are you with me
wow I mean he wants to hide his King on
E2 so The Rook is pinning the bishop no
checks along the e-file and if you throw
in the move Brook B1 check King E2 there
is D4 so The Rook cannot leave the IFA
but Rook takes D4 might be available
because the bishop is wow and if you
give the check on B2 The Rook slides
back down to D2 now in this position
black could consider uh a move like
Queen C5 which keeps the tension I would
be absolutely terrified here but Jan has
started with the move d4 the drawback of
that move is that after Rook B3 white
has shut off the avenue to B1 I think
that Jan's fingers are starting to slip
from The Ledger he's still not really
risking again black S2 pawns for the
exchange but if Hikaru can get a trade
of Brooks Robert I don't think he's
going to lose the game Black's Bishop is
not enough of an attacking Force anymore
how the mighty have fallen surrounded as
it is by pawns on the wrong caller to
win black the game the attack is
fizzling out
right but for yawn right now the big
decision is do I allow The Rook trade or
should I move my Rook over to a square
like C4 keep the Rooks on Rook B7 easily
met by Bishop Retreat to C7 cutting off
the seventh rank so I don't see the
attack I don't see the Checkmate I love
the defense so far from Hikaru and you
are right to point this out time and
time again and Brook trait is not
devastating for yawn he actually still
has even material with a bishop and two
pumps for Rook but he chooses to keep
the potential attack going with Rook C4
and I like that choice and ikaru is
ahead on the clock and Jan you know he
is trying to push push push but Hikaru
is being a tenacious Defender
he has not lost a single game in this
entire tournament and we are beginning
to see why anytime Hikaru has had his
back against the wall he has turned on
beast mode he finds every tricky
defensive resource in the book
my lands and for yawn he has to keep the
match situation in mind this is not
technically a must-win game if he gets
into a situation where you can force a
draw or you can go for a highly
speculative line that runs the risk of
losing white will have the white pieces
in the next game now it's not as big of
an advantage in fish or random but it's
still something and I think Jan has to
be wise here about the amount of risk
that he is taking on Rook B7 Queen E6 on
the board
okay and the evaluation still in Black's
favor I think from a practical point of
view down here though I think Young has
great winning chances a car is playing
really good defense here but black is
all of his base is covered now F7 safe
the queen on E6 doing all the work not
only in attacking positions but also in
defensive positions the Queens are doing
the heavy lifting and so for Jan right
now it's how do I continue this attack
at Fred Karu is a move like Queen F6
please trade these Queens off available
but at the problem with Queen F6 is the
black queen slides back to D7 down here
right and you have Queen A4 check so if
white is not careful you may be hit by a
check out of nowhere and that could cost
you the entire game yeah rookie2 Queen
E7 a case in point as you're
illustrating by the way uh Vladimir
fedexv has won the third game against
Wesley so he leads by a point and Magnus
Carlson has defeated Notre backup
docentre for the second consecutive game
he leads with a score of two to one but
back we go to this game Jan's last move
Bishop C7 slicing off whites Rook which
is on the seventh rank I'm with you I
think the Plex practical chances are
immense and they are increasing
exponentially with every second that
ticks down from White's clock
for sure I think the resulting time
scramble is only good news for young to
promise his King is very safe it has
been this whole time and every decision
is taxing for Hikaru he's digging deep
he's working really hard at the board
here but at some point you know you just
get tired but Hikaru Nakamura has proven
himself to be a guy who can defend any
position no matter how difficult it
seems so right now Daniel I'm struggling
to come up with the move rookie two the
queen just moves away Queen F6 you're
all opening up Queen G4 check or a
simple Queen Retreat so I just don't see
a three move sequence for white that is
my struggle yeah it's so tilting though
wherever you go you're opening up some
sort of Avenue to whites King and Hikaru
he has played rookie too and
interestingly Jan slides his Queen not
to D7 but actually to D6
so that might be in order to keep the F6
Square under control and limit White's
activity there is a check on E8 but it
seems totally innocuous the king
actually in some senses wants to go up
to G7 in order to avoid background
Shenanigans and you know what else he
might want is Queen C5 the queen of D7
could not get to the C file Queen C5
immediate threads not just Rook C1 but
D3 opening the diagonal to G1 so hikarus
to be very careful in this moment
multiple threats are Uncorked with the
move Queen to C5 and he's taking his
time yet again because how can you not
there are so many things to keep track
of as he drops now to two minutes on his
clock and Yanda Panda she has opened up
a two and a half minute lead that is
going to be so crucial if Hikaru makes a
decisive mistake John does have enough
time to honk her down and essentially do
as much calculation as he needs Hikaru
looks like he's about to move but how is
he going to coordinate his defenses here
can't he use this heavy pieces to keep
all the bases covered 90 seconds now on
his clock
and you might want to make a move like
Rook C2 trying to trade but even Rook C3
is a viable response let's trade on my
terms if you take my Rook on C3 it opens
the D file with check and your king is
under Fire Rook D2 was instead a car's
Choice oh Queen C5 Queen C5
he didn't defend against Queen C5 and
after Rook B1 I think he might have
missed D3
oh my God that's just three
oh my God Robert there's something crazy
wait D3 Queen F2 and then I think the
queen can drop down to the other side of
the board with a devastating check on H5
and Yan you didn't have to ask him twice
my goodness what a game this has been an
epic struggle Rook C1 check will be
followed with a bunch of other checks
likely leading to Checkmate or the Widow
material so Rook B1 looks like akara's
best move but D3 opening that Queen up
the G1 square is blacks for the taking
and once the queen lands there there are
too many threats to deal with ikaru now
he's at a barely over a minute King E2
played and Rook C3 or Rook C1 both are
tempting he plays Rook C3 I think Yan
should slow down a little bit here I
think he should take at least 10-15
seconds per move but he seems totally
confident in the winning approach Rook
to D3 by Hikaru
desperation as the white king is getting
surrounded by Black's bloodthirsty
pieces but what is the finishing blow I
think Rook C2 check the King has to step
away I feel like and then once the king
sepsis take on H2 give me a third Pawn
for that exchange then G3 is loose
Quincy one check is a threat and white
still has no attack against the safe
black king on G8 and that's such an
instructive idea Robert so many people
forget In the Heat of the Moment that
you don't always have to finish an
attack off in Checkmate you can use the
weakness of your opponent's gang just to
take all of the pods to produce a
massive material advantage and he plays
Quincy for okay reasonable bar didn't
like that though at all
when a car down a minute please oh he
let him get back to B2
ah that was a big mistake that was
very sloppy for Yan
Rook C2 Robert was just asking to be
played there I think what Jan can do
though is Play Bishop E5 King G7 and say
so what's your plan Hikaru you may have
survived the first Avalanche but my
pieces are gonna continue to attack you
and there's a pin on this Rook on D3 so
I feel like Jan still has the edge and
he can just play Simple chess while the
car hovers around a minute
but Jan has to avoid getting flustered
he clearly over overlooked Rook B2 and
if we can nitpick the one area it seems
that Jan has struggled throughout the
tournament when he gets into these time
scrambles he's made a bunch of these
uncharacteristically sloppy moves Rook
C2 seem to end the game on the spot but
Jan gathers himself together mature and
calm and collected and Bishop td8 I love
that move Robert I think the bishop is
heading for G5 and Hikaru says no you
are not heading for G5 I won't let you
get there and he pushes the pawn up to
H4 yeah Bishop G5 would have covered the
D2 Square so there'll be no blocks or
protection of the Rook on D3 now H4 is a
good move because this stops Bishop G5
but if we think bigger picture then the
G3 Pawn is tender now white can also
play H5 at some moment if you're not
looking carefully at trying to put that
pawn on H6 keep that King on the back
Rank and maybe a back ranked Checkmate
so now there are chances for both sides
Bishop E7 com chess from Yan that's the
best thing he has done throughout this
event and on see the last couple of
years he doesn't just you know make
these huge decisions throwing pieces
forward and not thinking about his own
King and uh the way the position goes
from there he's just making good
improving moves even if he has spoiled
some of his winning chances and I don't
think he spoiled just some I think he's
spoiled maybe even most of his winning
chances because if Hikaru can keep
himself composed and avoid making any
one move blunders and what that
basically means is just maintaining the
status quo your car just looks up at the
Devil says hey how are you going to make
progress you're not dislodging my queen
from E4 and F3 you're not moving my Rook
away from the second right so what are
you going to do nepo can make a bunch of
cosmetic improvements in his position
you can play H5 maybe it's worth getting
the pawn to A3 but then the Rook is
going to slide over to D2 I think Hikaru
is very close to setting up a fortress
but that clock of his that might be
ultimately what brings him down clock
does him no favors at 40 seconds left
John on the other hand he is above 145
and now after Rook to D2 The Rook on D3
is defended
A3 going after this move
and how does Hikaru defend that pawn
Rook takes a two this is a rook trade
that nepo will not mind when he has
three pawns for the exchange that would
be a winning position with that
additional passer on A5
under 30 seconds he's thinking about the
h-pawn move but after H5
maybe I'll just take it
oh yeah you can just take it there's
also Bishop G5 that whole point of
playing H4 was taking away the G5 Square
Bishop G5 ensures the black king will be
safe and The Rook on D2 is being kicked
around he goes King G7 he lifts the king
up and prevents the back rank checks and
prevents the check with the pawn on H6
down under 20 seconds
but now GH instantly by now give me that
and how G4 I think G4 is the move
no it's not it's Queen f55
he can just grab this Pawn A2 that was
his point of Rook A3
oh what a tricky move H6 of a bishop G5
Queen takes HVAC and Bishop G5 also
functions as a way to prevent Perpetual
check anytime I checks on G4 black can
cover with a bishop seven seconds by
Hikaru Nakamura he's running out of time
he plays King F2 and now Rook takes A2
why not and now we're going to takes A2
give me a fourth Pawn for the exchange
Yan grabs that pawn a cargo exactly
brings his King over some more to G2 but
is it time to run that pass Pawn forward
Sprint to the other side of the board A4
A3 trade Brooks and A2
get that pawn as far as it'll go because
white still has to spend a Tempo the
king to relative safety on H3 these are
golden Tempe that black has to put to
use you don't know if you'll have the
opportunity to push that pawn if white
is able to coordinate his pieces yeah
now dropping to below a minute he's
deciding whether to play A4 I absolutely
think that he should and he does
yes he doesn't there is a slight delay
coming from the live event in Reykjavik
you see the player's hands move after
the board has changed Queen takes H5
that does not look like it's a good move
Rook takes D2 Rook takes D2 and Bishop
G5 just start pushing all your pawns a
pawn d-pawn you pick him it's gonna work
out
the one trick I thought after Bishop G5
maybe Queen back to G4 to pin the bishop
and attack D4
oh I missed that he plays it
oh he plays the immediate Bishop G5 okay
we see 15 seconds under that for Hikaru
I can't believe he's been holding this
for as long as he has but what does he
do now
oh oh and that's got to be a blunder but
why
um
Queen D5 check
oh and then F5s
queen queen D5 and F5 ends the game you
got it oh goodness and can yawn find
this and he plays it plays Queen D5
check
and we see the players on camera eight
seconds four hit cards
Hikaru sees it
brings King to G1 and now young at five
27 seconds will he play F5 that is the
big question it is winning here because
you break also pin on the G file you
could probably even take on D2 first but
he plays F5 and he finds the clutch move
and it's over takes and Bishop takes D2
even
just don't play Bishop E3 check and
there's resignation yonda palmshi ties
this match up one nap one and a half
Hikaru Nakamura put up amazing defense
but yonda Palm sheet was not to be
deterred in his quest for a victory in
this Fisher random World Championship
Dania that was a game between two
absolute stars of chess
two giants indeed and what may have been
most impressive to me Robert of course
the way that John played in the middle
game the way that he attacked the way he
kept his phone on the gas pedal but the
way that he recovered from that mistake
he allowed Rook B2 it seemed like Hikaru
was knocking on the door of a fortress
and no Jan kept his calm he didn't tilt
he found every last chance until he won
that a pawn and then when push came to
shovel and he had to find the winning
sequence he spent the remainder of his
time and he pushed that pawn to F5 and
he has tied the match this is
unbelievable it has not only lived up to
its promise it's lived up to his promise
and then some this is a treat let's go
back a little bit in this game because
one thing we were noting that while some
of the advantage slipped in fact
according to the engine a lot of it
slipped that decision even once the edge
was lost a bit short there were some
ideas when The Rook went back to B2
around this moment here yeah we were
saying wait a second White's King is
feeling safer but we kept reminding
ourselves more than anybody that there
was a bishop and two pawns for a rook
that is even material so Jan did not
have to freak out he did not have to
panic and the way he did this bishop d8
inducing H4 and then slowly but surely
improving his pieces Donya that was
wonderful stuff from John de Palm Street
going after the a pawn as well
going after the a pawn and just always
finding the right Square for the bishop
and not panicking after Hikaru pushes
this Pawn to H5 this is a scary looking
move it ain't easy to take on H5 and
weaken your king in the way that Jan did
but this Exquisite technique H6 creating
an anchor Square for the bishop and then
grabbing A2 at the right moment and
pushing the pawn and every single time
he had to find a critical move in a
clutch move he did and it culminated in
the move F5 dislodging the queen from
the G file and leaving D2 as a Sitting
Duck what an unbelievable game and what
a finale we are in for seriously knotted
up one nap one half and it would be a
disservice to Hikaru to sort of get
under the microscope and look where he
could have saved it he had mere seconds
on his clock he was defending all game
it just is credit to Jana pomdishu
winning game three this match is tied
one half one half so when we return We
Are Gonna See Yonder Palm Nashi and
Hikaru Nakamura we've seen many wins
with the black pieces done yeah is it
really an advantage for Yonder Palm
sheet to get white in game four
it's impossible to say but I think
largely the answer is no we have seen so
much unpredictability in the openings
that I really think it almost doesn't
matter who plays white and who plays
Black because in Fisher random what we
see so often sometimes we see copycat
chess but a lot of the time we see
players pursuing their own agendas and
that greatly dilutes uh the
effectiveness and the meaning of having
the first move so I can't wait for this
game whoever you're a fan of Robert
let's take a moment to tip our hats to
these players for putting every single
thing they've got every last ounce of
energy after such a long tournament is
out on the playing field today and they
have to give up their remaining energy
for this final game they're gonna have
to Brave the storm
it's the last game of the season they're
gonna hold nothing back and as you say
Brave the stone we should give a shout
out to our presenting sponsor brave
because Brave means private browsing and
so much more by default Brave blocks ads
and trackers on every page and video you
visit even on YouTube no ads means up to
three times faster page loads faster
streaming and faster playback it means
35 longer battery life while saving on
mobile data and internet bandwidth for
Android iOS and desktop get the best
browser for gamers streamers and
creators switch in 60 seconds at
brave.com
and I will run around our rooms we'll be
right back because when returned it's
game four here at Championship Sunday
live from Reykjavik Iceland the Fisher
random world championship this coverage
on chess.com brought to you by Brave
chess kit is fun chess is great for the
brain but it's also fun to play and
chess kid makes it easy to have fun
whether your child is a total beginner
or a prodigy they can hop on and find a
well-matched opponent from around the
world at any time chess kid is the safe
parent-approved way for your child to
play chess online
chess kid is educational
kids it feels just like playing the
chest is a great way to learn patience
strategy and critical thinking chess kid
features a comprehensive training
program that guides kids to level up on
their way to Mastery there are more than
fifty thousand chest muscles and a whole
library of entertaining videos that
teach strategies tactics openings and
end games specifically for kids
chess kit is easy whether you're a
parent helping your child a coach
managing dozens of kids or a school of
hundreds signing up is free and easy so
what are you waiting for
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause] [Music]
as we return to the Fisher random World
Championship 65
000 and a world title is at stake in the
matchup between janapamshi and ikar
Nakamura I'm Grandmaster Robert Hess
alongside me my good friend my buddy my
partner in crime grand master Daniel
neraditsky Dania that was an epic game
three
I'm still processing that I'm probably
going to process that all throughout my
time in Canada I don't like to make you
know these General Global pronouncements
but in terms of like all-time matches
all-time mini matches this is definitely
top five and we haven't even played our
last game
no we haven't and Jana palmshi he's
demonstrated in multiple matches now
against Magnus Carlson against Hikaru
Nakamura that he is The Comeback Kid he
would like to be the comeback King and
be the world champion of Fisher random
if he can win this game four that's
easier said than done yes Hikaru is
probably upset that he just lost game
three but akaru Nakamura he is an
unbelievable player he is determined he
has a hundred and fifty thousand dollars
in a world title in his sights but if
this game is a draw they will go to
Armageddon so it is anybody shot Jan
Hikaru I don't even know who to call the
favorite
oh my goodness Robert I mean your form
is often measured by how difficult it is
to beat you Hikaru has lost only one
game in this entire tournament it was
just the one we just saw and how many
times did yandere palmichi have to beat
him over and over and over again how
many times did Hikaru rise from the dead
in that game it was a staggeringly
difficult task for janapamnushi to
defeat him once and to defeat him twice
and to do it On Demand right now is
going to be even more difficult
good luck to anybody trying to take down
Hikaru Nakamura but in this time Patrol
right 25 minutes to start with no
increment you got to reach move 30 to
get that extra five minutes and the five
seconds at it per move I feel like
janapamshi is probably happiest of all
the players in this format he just moves
at a blazing Pace but a card Nakamura
has matched him and I think he's matched
him on the clock he's matched him on the
board and that's the reason we see this
one half one half tie both players are
taking their shots they're playing
exciting chess and hikara Nakamura he
may be regretting that decision to agree
to a draw in game two but the past of
the past you should only focus on game
four now
yeah I just Echo what you said the time
management has largely been excellent by
both players You could argue that the
last game was the first one in which the
clock really was a defining Factor but
even then I would argue uh that even
with a lot of time on the clock you made
this point White's defensive task would
have barely gotten any easier so this
again is a testament to the player's
form to their level of confidence that
they have built up throughout this
tournament and it's going to be
important if you're on if you're young
to adhere to the strategy that he has
adopted against Magnus and that he has
successfully implemented after losing
the first game against sikaru quick play
relatively quick decisions and critical
moments trusting his intuition but
taking his time when calculation is
actually required such as before he
sacrificed on E3 it was just excellent
excellent time management or yeah in the
last game and there's a word that we
keep coming back to and for good reason
the word is control we felt like Hikaru
Nakamura throughout this entire event
was in control he didn't lose a single
game he was in trouble yesterday game
won the semis against nordeback Abu
sitarov he ended up winning that game
and the two others to make it through
here but he didn't have control after
the opening stage in game three then
yonda palmistry was able to seize
control perhaps of the match so if
you're Hikaru this is your first loss in
your entire stay in Reykjavik what do
you do who do you consult how do you go
right back into studying this opening in
a position you've never seen before
except for that game you just lost it is
very difficult stuff there's a lot of
psychology that comes into play and if
you're yawned upon the she well you've
got on that wry smile ready for game
four
and obviously I'm nobody to give Hikaru
advice Hikaru is one of the greatest
players of all time in terms of coming
back from losses he channels the
frustration into playing even better
chess but I would avoid obviously in his
shoes making over generalizations or
trying to cardinally modify uh the type
of Chess that you are playing he played
an excellent game in the last round his
mistakes I don't think were due to a
false approach or were due to something
psychological they were mistakes on the
board and I think he needs to try to
play the exact same way he's been
playing this match and you know let the
better player Prevail I have a feeling
that we are going to get a topsy-turvy
back and forth nerve-wracking epic
struggle in the final game as Jan we saw
him pacing there he can't wait for this
game to begin these players they just
want to be sitting at the board and
moving the pieces there are six other
players nerdy back abusotarov he now
Trails against Magnus Carlsen already
back one game one Magnus has rebounded
with two straight wins and in the other
matchups Vladimir perrosev actually
leads Wesley so two to one and for the
Seventh Place Matthias bluebaum he leads
two to one over the Local Hero the
number one player from Iceland here over
Stein gretcherson but our attention will
not leave the top board Jana pomshi I
believe he's got T in that cup here his
jacket is off the gloves are off as well
and Hikaru Nakamura takes the black
pieces and he is going to look to stop
the freight train that is Young to
promise you and the players they're
going through their routine both
adjusting their pieces John
taking his first sip of tea he's gone
through all of the beverages caffeine
was the focus in the last round right
now I think he's trying largely to calm
his nerves they are as caffeinated as
they need to be the game itself is
caffeine enough
oh my goodness I've only had one cup but
I feel like I've had seven that was
something else
you know I don't drink coffee but I do
feel the hype and I hope everybody who's
watching feels it as well this is
potentially one game for a world
championship title now if they draw we
do go to Armageddon we tie two to two we
will get another game but janapamshi
after a win in game three he might want
to end it here if you're Hikaru Nakamura
you can rely on the fact that players
with the black pieces have done quite
well throughout the Fisher random
Championship we see all eight players uh
some of them laughing a first move made
in the game between fedocia and Wesley
so ceremonial first move uh but all eyes
should be on the bottom right rare thing
to say when Magnus Carlson is in a
tournament taking on the world's rapid
Champion the Olympiad Champion that
Uzbek teenager noribbeck abdusitarov but
Yonder palmshi or Hikaru Nakamura those
are the names that we etched in history
as the Fisher random world champion
ladies and gentlemen this is one for the
ages as the handshake takes place and
the first moves are made and we see
Hikaru and Yan on camera and the
important first move is indeed G3 that
is the move that I predicted originally
and should Jan play E4 we would have had
a transposition to the previous game but
a fundamentally different approach from
Jan Robert I feel like throughout this
tournament he has put an accent on
largely playing on the flanks he has
shown a predilection over pawn pawn
moves of the A and B pawns as opposed to
a direct kind of central campaign let's
see how he continues here and we see the
players are settling into this game four
I liked hikara's position I thought the
planet E4 just trading there playing F4
I liked how that looked out of the gates
but then when Jan was able to bring his
King from C8 all the way over to G8
let's remind everybody of how castling
works that if the pieces clear out
between uh the black uh king and queen
there so if the queen moves The Rook can
go from B8 to D and Castle but if all
those pieces that Don is highlighting on
the king side are gone then the king can
fly across the board to G8 so that needs
to be kept in mind we see Central moves
so far down you said before we got into
the last game you didn't really like the
strategy of pushing Pawns in the center
yeah I personally like flank play I like
I'm also Kings Indian player so I like
openings where you apply pressure in the
center and despite what I just said
about Jan he does push a pawn in the
center I think they are taking a far
quieter more solid approach insofar as
you can play solidly and Fisher random
and just the definition of that Robert
is is greatly diminished in the context
of Fisher random given how unbalanced
and chaotic the position is from the
very first moves but in so far as you
can play solidly I think they are in the
position already beginning to resemble
something out of a grunfeld especially
if both sides find a way to Castle
kingside we might literally have almost
a transposition into a real grunfeld
position obviously with the inclusion of
Bishop H1 Bishop h8 but maybe they'll
bring their Bishops back to their
regular film kettled squares yeah it's a
funny looking position and it's a bit of
CopyCat chess and how is one side going
deviate from the other and that is up to
ikaro he can keep copying uh Jan and
Yango's Bishop G2 or Bishop before but
should be five Bishop G2 Bishop G7 and
so on so at some point uh Jan will have
to find a strategy that hikar cannot
copy and he plays Knight C5 here so if
Black Goes Knight C4 then I think Jan is
ready to kick that Knight out of there
with a move like B3 so he will be first
to the action so no more copycat chess
and for Hikaru let me ask you Dania the
Knight on C5 is that really threatening
do you feel worried about that piece or
it's just kind of a paper tiger
it's a paper tiger for the time being
but it could become a real tiger if
white makes uh more improvements to his
position such as putting the other
Knight on 85 and maybe supporting the
Knight with Bishop B4 and again it's a
question of priorities for Hikaru
priority number one you need to figure
out what to do with this King priority
number two do you want to deal with this
Knight on C5 and priority number three
what is he going to do with his own
Knight on V6 how is he going to sort
those priorities if he prioritizes
trading the Knight on C5 then I think
we're gonna see him drop his own Knight
into E4 or maybe do so in a more
conservative manner by pushing his own
eye back toward D7 benefit of that move
might be that he's also preparing upon
push on E5 and there we go he goes
Knight B6 to D7 taking care of two
priorities at once he uses the Knight on
B6 to dislodge John's knight from C5 but
I have to say I don't like the move and
the reason why now Black's pieces
fighting for similar squares when you
have more space like Yan does you want
to have more pieces I I would Retreat my
knight to D3 because now I control the
pawn breaks on C and E5 and I feel like
with the knights and F3 and D3 you are
more advanced than blacks Knights on D7
and F6 so I just think that the Knight
on D7 doesn't look great Yan instead
decides to develop the bishop to B4
can't fault him for that but I just like
keeping more material on the board but
my opponent doesn't have the same
breathing room but I I completely agree
with that I thought Knight D3 would have
really highlighted emphasized the
awkwardness of the night placement on D7
and maybe Jan was worried about a
Superfluous night situation where both
Knights are competing for the same
square but no they're not really
competing for the same square the Knight
on D3 has plenty of prospects on F4 or
B4 I thought that this was a clear Edge
for white but instead I'm following
through on his original plan and playing
Bishop before and if I'm Hikaru I am
snapping that Knight off the board I am
not letting it Live Another Day on this
board
right you could take the Knight on C5
then put your knight on e4 I guess what
Jan is relying on is that he has the
first pressure in the position it's not
a huge deal the E7 pawns defended but he
at least is creating the first semi
threat and that means that Hikaru can
just capture bring his own Knight into
the center things like that or he can
make Quiet Moves Like Bishop G7 continue
his development
um I I like taking on C5 I think
ultimately that's the easy decision to
make
is there any case to be made for a yawn
recapturing with the pawn and vacating
the D4 Square for his night I
instinctively think the answer is no but
I'm just trying to figure out
I mean Bishop takes C5 black plays
Knight E4 and it seems like black really
has solved all of his problems taking on
A7 is really Unthinkable due to Rook A8
so could Yan be cooking up something a
little bit more creative what do you
think
oh now that you mention it it's
viable I don't love it because the
bishop on h8 just seems to benefit more
than any other piece on the board and we
saw what that Bishop did in the previous
game so there is a little bit of recency
bias in my calculations here well black
just controls the center C5 might be a
long-term Target so it does open the D
file for white gives the D4 Square to
the Knight but I think he'll take back
with the bishop on C5 and this is making
me ask you this question who is happier
to make a draw and head to Armageddon
who is happier to make a draw man that's
such a hard question
I would guess that it's ikaru but only
because of the fact that nepo has won
the last game I feel like that bad taste
in hikaru's mouth could allow nepo to
build up some momentum and I just feel
like Hikaru is so clutch all throughout
the RCC and all of his online events he
is just a nightmare to face in any game
that decides a championship this game of
course also decides the championship but
I think you know what I mean I'm gonna
have to go with nepo but these players
are so ridiculously evenly matched in a
tournament where both are in good form
that I think it's virtually impossible
to say
well you mentioned the RCC I think yonda
palmshi ultimately has the happiest
memories of that event yeah he won the
rapid Chess Championship Finals hosted
by chess.com and he won the grand prize
and he looked dominant doing so so
Bishop B5 uh hikari's Bishop it sees the
light of day putting pressure on E2 just
like white dark squared Bishop is
putting pressure on E7 and the copycat
chest may continue here Dania Knight E5
to my eyes looks like the most
reasonable move and you're now staring
at the knights in the center at some
point one might be captured
to my eyes as well and white now has to
solve the same exact problem that black
had to address a couple of moves ago
when white had the Knight sitting on C5
and fundamentally the question is do you
want to trade this Knight on e4 or do
you want to kick it away with your Pawn
if you want to trade it then you'd love
to play the move Knight D2 so maybe
starting with C3 would make sense to
blot the bishop and to reinforce D4 but
that just seems passive to my eyes and
C3 is a weakening move especially now
given that white is not yet ready to
Castle if I had to predict a move I'd
predict 95 but no Napo does play the
move C3 do you see why I'm a bit
surprised at that move yeah it just
feels like it weakens more than it
defends the Ponzi Frank was not in any
danger whatsoever he may want to play
Queen C2 and then Castle kingside so
that might be his main plan right now is
to get the king over there oh Hikaru has
something to say about that that is an
amazing move
oh my Lance he wants to go Bishop H6
and he exploits the fact that the Rook
is pinned can nepo address that
effectively yes he's Oh I thought he was
going to go to E5 but the point is that
with the bishop trying to go to H6 you
have the move F4 so I thought the Knight
could have just gone forward rather than
back but the point still stands he is
working his way to a defense on the
diagonal
in the early going it seems to me that
nepo is playing in somewhat more flimsy
manner he's got to be careful the next
couple of moves I think he should be
able to breathe easier once he's able to
Castle kingside and get this Knight off
of V4 which now seems to be imminent now
Hikaru still could play Bishop H6 he
could play it not in order to win the
Knight but in order uh to invoke
positional weaknesses Force white to
play F4 and then maybe ensconce his own
Knight on e4 with a move F5 not entirely
sure how Hikaru should handle this
these kind of f-pawn pushes in standard
chess you refrain from doing that for
the most part but here you want to keep
your knight in the center trade on your
own terms we can show that F5 if white
takes the Knight on e4 that would be a
mistake I think because Knight takes E4
F takes E4 uh sorry before Bishop H6 so
instead of oh the immediate F5 okay yeah
so immediate F5 94 fe4 I just feel like
that pawn on F2 there's a happy Rook on
f8 and a sad Rook on F1 I don't think
it's the end of the world where white
can continue developing but I just feel
like that the Brooklyn f8 gains the most
but Hikaru actually going for our
original idea he does throw in the move
Bishop H6 and meets F4 with F5 so the
position remains largely symmetrical and
once again white has to decide whether
or not to take on e4 now Robert I think
you'll co-sign this Knight takes C4 is
more appealing to me now that the pawn
is on F4 but I would still be very
guarded about making this move because
now the bishop is blunted black is this
relatively nasty idea of chipping away
at the F4 upon with the move G5 and the
fact that this Rook is pitted to his
pinned is so tilting for white because
the Rook just doesn't have any safe
squares on the f file if it moves up to
F2 you're potentially running into the
movie three
yeah G5 is a nasty threat so I my first
instinct is can I play in the live
position to stop G5 uh so instead of
trading I was like can I play Knight F3
and he does that but you could still
play G5 and what I'm now coming to terms
with in this position is that white
doesn't have to Castle like at some
point you could just like King up to C2
if your king is in check
you can but G5 creates the immediate
threat of taking twice on F4 and it is
on the board and John is so hurt by the
fact that he can't play E3 you could
move the Knight and maybe it's finally
time to put it on E5 he's shown a
resistance to this move what catches
your eye here what do you think is the
safest way to defend the pawn wow 95 is
more than just answer well if you go
back before 95 what I was trying to say
was I could take on G5 a bunch of times
like FG Knight G5 Knight G5 Bishop G5
check and I could just play King C2 it's
not the end of the world it looks like
you've castled Queen side
um I don't prefer White's position but
it's not that bad but I like what he's
done with Knight E5 instead because he
is actually safeguarding the F4 Pawn
it's hard to team up on it anymore
so finally he has a breather he has
essentially a move that he could invest
on improving his position or does he
that move Queen it's really really
sneaky because you might think oh he's
creating a battery maybe he wants Bishop
A4 but no look at the other side of the
board and you will see that the queen
has far more violent intentions it is
threatening to swing to H5 and White's
King side is not well protected that
pawn on H2 is a Sitting Duck the pawn on
E2 is going to be targeted so I think
nepo has yet another threat that he has
to address in this position how do you
think he's going to do it there's one
bit of good news for young the queen on
E8 is protecting the E7 Pawn so while
Queen H5 will cause some serious
problems with Bishop takes E2 and queen
takes H2 as you've been mentioning there
is that pawn hanging so maybe he has a
useful move here maybe he can actually
give up like the H2 Pawn by like Queen
C2 Castle Queen side and say have my H2
Pawn have my king side but your king is
still on C8 and E7 is hanging in many
different variations and you could even
grab it here
uh Castle's Queen side exists on demand
you could Castle queenside but then
you're running into Bishop takes E2 so
this is a very tricky position another
defensive resource Robert is a timely
Bishop F3 you can say the important Pawn
is E2 go take my H Dupont as you're
saying and in the blink of a night black
could get into a situation where his
pieces are alt uncoordinated the Rooks
are not connected and this could go
south really really really quickly for
Black so you go back to think twice cast
and queen side was there Rook H1 just
there
Rook H1 I take it can I take your bishop
or no okay Queen takes a four yeah maybe
it's uh I'm asking for Trump I think
yeah I think you do have a move here but
it's probably maybe to Castle now
actually just give up all your pawns I
mean it's serious strategy because yeah
look at White's pieces yeah the H file
is open The Bishop's hanging H7 will
fall if the bishop moves now this is
actually something that doesn't look
that appealing to my eyes we have the
eval bar going up and down criticizing
our every mistake well it's saying
Bishop E4 is the move
ah that makes sense and then you can
take on H6 right because after Queen
takes F4 check you can block it
somehow the white zigzags and swings his
way over to C2 and it's so important
that Bishop A4 no it's not mate white
always has the resource B3 but this how
hard is this to calculate in a real game
oh it's nearly impossible I think some
of it will rely on intuition where
you're like just take H2 I'm gonna
Castle I will have the necessary
compensation Hikaru by the way is ahead
on the clock right now by a minute and
we've been harping on the clock the time
management and Jan has almost always
been ahead except for game one in this
match which Hikaru one otherwise it felt
like Jan throughout the entire
tournament was leading on time so Hikaru
he's sitting back in his chair he's
coming up with some Queen H5 ideas Jan
needs to find a way out and queen C2
opening up the door to Castle queenside
seems like a good start yeah I don't
think you're getting out of this without
at least putting yourself in a position
where you are ready to castle queenside
at a moment's notice it's with a
hamstring White's chances greatly if
Queen H5 were already on the board and
your king would be stuck on C1 you made
an important point the problem isn't so
much that the king itself is weak but
rather you want to connect the trucks
you want to move like Bishop takes E2 uh
the effect of that you want to be
diminished you want to be able to play
Rook H1 in the event of Queen takes H2
and all of that uh the only way to
achieve it is to Castle and get the King
get the Rook to the other side of the
king that's really the point of Castle
in this position the king is already on
the castle Square
right the Rooks just need to be
connected that's a big deal here for yon
and he's spending a lot of time he's
weighing his options and he understands
that this is a critical moment because
it's not just oh I make one move that
car makes one it's will his King find
safety will his Rooks be playing a part
in this game and is E7 an actual problem
for black and the queenies to stay put
or can Hikaru continue with his Queen's
Journey over to H5 and icaro I mean he
does not look amused he's calculating
yawn we have the close-up on him there
he's really working his way through all
the possibilities and I can guarantee
you that he is calculating the queen C2
Queen H5 and he decides against it a
very committal Choice there whoa whoa
whoa he takes the Knight on e4 and that
is a type of idea that we have
criticized in a similar position what do
you make of it now instinctively Robert
this looks like a pretty serious
concession
it does and Hikaru he hasn't captured
back a pretty positive he has to take
with the F Pawn on e4 well if you I
would say definitely yeah if you take
with the d-pawn queen B3 already looks
like a huge problem
then we could have something out of
Carlson's game where he smothered mated
the black king yeah this this is out of
the question
so that means F takes E4 but why is he
thinking
is he thinking about G takes F4 first no
that's ridiculous just Bishop takes D5
and again and again after the King goes
up tc2 this is never effective because
of B3 so I just think he's surprised I
think he's surprised that nepo's move
maybe he's trying to figure out what
nepo's follow-up is the F6 C4 and
frankly I'm wondering the same thing oh
after F takes E4 I'll play Queen D2
right and just defend F4 I thought maybe
he wants to have G
whoa maybe well your idea move the king
up to C2 and say hey my king is safe
Black's King is the one that experiences
some problems but of course black kid
also Castle queenside On Demand
that's true and I think ultimately what
the dynamic shift has been is if the
dark Square bishops come off the board
white is strategically winning pretty
much the light Square Bishop against a
knight on E5 that's a disaster waiting
to happen from hikara's perspective so
of course that requires the bishop on A3
to somehow trade for its counterpart in
H6 that's a long ways away but it's
something to keep an eye on
yeah this is a very thorny situation for
Jan I mean the eval bar expressing its
relatively strong disapproval though
it's going back and forth Testament to
how complex opposition is you were
absolutely right Robert yon prefers to
keep the position closed with Queen D2
and the smoke beginning to clear just a
little bit especially if both sides get
a chance to Castle the Kings will
finally finally become safe surrounded
by friendly forces and the battle will
sort of shift perhaps even to some
positional kind of tone
right and I feel like white can more or
less pre-move Rook B1 jumping over the
king to D1 and then the annoying part is
you still need to move your Rook to play
E3 so it's not the end of that story and
black has some pressure on White's pawns
but the fact that E7 is loose that is
what's holding Hikaru back if E7 were
just defended by some piece Queen H5
would be a huge threat and one that I
don't think white could successfully
deal with
and what complicates the situation even
further is that if black Castle's Queen
side not only does that not solve the
problem of the E7 pawn it exacerbates it
because then Bishop takes E7 comes with
a fork so this is a long-term issue and
Hikaru has no easy way of solving it
no he does not and that's why he's
spending his time here and I think
you're right he was surprised by Bishop
takes Knight on e4 and that's why he
didn't recapture immediately and where
is he going or kind of looked like he
was grabbing something over there on the
queen side and he's shaking his head he
does not look happy about how this game
has gone and transformation of structure
yeah looking at the evil bar is totally
meaningless because look at white snipe
whitesnite as someone in the chat
pointed out is a monster rights Bishop
on A3 aiming at the E7 Pawn from a
purely peace placement standpoint white
is doing great and all nepo needs Robert
is a couple of moves Rook F2 then you go
E3 you Castle Queen side once he has all
of the bases covered on the king side
from a purely positional standpoint he
holds most of the Trump cards here icaro
has to do something decisive and perhaps
something drastic to highlight the
temporary weaknesses in White's position
right because strategically black is in
trouble as you're putting the Rook on F2
Pawn E3 the bishop on B5 the light
Square Bishop is not a particularly good
piece it will be staring into nothing
right into the abyss so Hikaru it's a
vintage acara face I'm you know digging
the shirt that he's wearing he's come
ready to play but he doesn't seem very
happy with the last bunch of moves and
now he's the one down on time
now it should be pointed out that in the
future if he kind of wants to try to
bail out he can drop his Bishop I know
the bishop on H6 is such a nice piece
but he can move it back to G7
potentially trade it for E5 but we
should resist the urge to say oh if he
does that the game will enter the drop
if white controls the f file then white
will be uniquely poised to benefit from
that move and in the resulting position
that pawn on E7 is going to become an
even bigger problem with black lacking
the only piece that can effectively
defend it the dark squared Bishop
right no this is not an easy moment for
Carl he takes this Pawn on F4 I think
that Jan can simply take oh what whoa
they're allowed to offer draws
since when they are yes
I hope so
I was sure there was a 40 move draw but
I guess there isn't I don't remember us
talking about it
and I think
what the players are
talking about or maybe what their
thoughts were is that Hikaru would bring
the bishop back to G7 and take the
Knight on E5 and just have opposite
colored Bishops and well that's what I
just yeah
right like hovering around even but that
is surprising a game for reminiscent of
the final game of Carlson caruana World
Championship when all the action was
still to be had when there's a lot to
play for they agreed to draw they're
talking with the Arbiter right now so
actually you know we can see that Jan
and Hikaru are talking with the Arbiter
about this decision and about what's to
come
and don't shovel dirt on this game just
yet obviously if there is no 40 move
draw rule then this is completely within
their right you can criticize the
decision but you cannot criticize it
from the perspective of following rules
and obviously assuming that this uh draw
offer stands they're simply putting off
the action to the arm again one way or
the other this match is going to have to
be decided so I guess both players just
wanting more of a breather and uh both
of them believe that they benefit in the
event of the Armageddon your question
from the start of this game was
incredibly Prussian and it looks like
we're going to be returning to the
question of who benefits in this what
seemed to be unlikely events of a draw
nepo hadn't made a single draw and well
what do we have here
that's sad that his draw has to come in
the last deciding game of the final
and I've said this a million times and
we're getting words that Chief Arbiter
might not even be around to discuss
what's happening but I have you know
hoped that organizers would ban the draw
offer there's no reason why that game
should have ended there but we still
have chess and we have a great matchup
and we will see more from Nepal machine
Nakamura in the Armageddon but now our
eyes will turn to world champion Magnus
Carlson taking on World's rapid Champion
Olympia Champion teenage Superstar
sensation
where we sit about even on the clock
Magnus with a one point lead in the
match and not a single Pawn has been
traded only a dark Square Bishop from
White is off the board and one of blacks
Knights and we remind you that Notre
back down one to two he must win this
position almost looking something like a
rosalimo I I quit Carlson is doing here
he's got that Bishop on h8 aiming Down
The Long diagonal both sides of Castle
Queen side
I don't know if I really believe in
notorbeck's winning chances in this
position Robert
no it's hard to imagine him out playing
the world champion but he has already
done it once in this match he brings his
Rook to E1 pieces lined up against the
E7 Pawn seems to be a theme in this
starting position in the fish are random
uh so what should Magnus do here he can
simply take on e4 but that opens up the
D file we'll probably see a series of
Trades but Daniel the H7 Pawn that is
hanging over there he's got the eleven
in the room here I don't really think
that you want to grab it too soon
especially with the queen on D7 eyeing
the pawn on G4 but if Black's pieces
move around H7 can be captured at some
point yeah that is a pun and you can't
just fall asleep on a pawn just because
it's a corner Pawn uh that doesn't play
a direct role in the sort of middle game
struggle but definitely something that
Carlson has to keep in his peripheral
vision but again with Rook fe1 notabeck
tosses the ball back into Carlson's
court and says hey I have the center I
have my pieces on relatively compact
squares how are you going to make
progress what are you going to do with
this uncontested dark squid Bishop that
you have yeah it looks pretty absolutely
but I'm more than capable of Defending
B2 and defending all the squares along
the long diagonal and Carlson is taking
a significant chunk of time Robert he
has spent
Oodles of time all throughout this
tournament he has experienced really
unprecedented problems with his clock
someone who is just known for his
unbelievably filigree time management he
just never experiences the issues that
he's experienced in this event
yeah although after games two and three
in this match you might feeling a bit of
a Revival a Renaissance yeah the guy
played two great games to take down
Abdul sitarov and here in game four you
are right he has been a little bit
slower more deliberate than he has in
many of the other events he's played in
but Fisher random can do that to people
but this no longer looks like Randomness
this looks like actually just a better
position for black and he's just trying
to figure out what is my move here and
all right let's talk about move Candace
I mentioned you could take on e4 you
said A5 I like the look of that I can
move my king from C8 typically want to
move my king away from the center but I
don't really like the look of King B7 so
I don't want to put on the diagonal I
think A5 yeah your move
checks out I mean it depends if Carlson
wants to take sort of an active approach
or if he wants to make these small
improving moves that bite his time I
think both strategies uh are totally
valid King B8 is kind of a carlson-esque
move he he likes these semi-weighting
moves uh that Force his opponent to make
decisions but given Carlson's frame of
mind he's feeling aggressive he wants to
end this tournament in style and he
doesn't want to leave anything to chance
I think we're going to see an a-pawn
push here
looks good the Knight on B3 misplaced
dominated by all the pounds around it so
A5 keeps the position closed for long
enough instead
he pushes the other Rook Pawn with H6 so
wow Pawn is off limits Queen takes H6
will give up the G4 Pawn we just talked
about that so I wouldn't grab it uh but
what about e takes D5 and going after
the E7 Pawn is that something to
consider well you're forcing my hand
here Knight takes D5 would follow and
are you eyeing the E five square for
your knight for sure I am
so let's keep this line going Bishop
takes E5 I assume takes I always think
of the pawn because F4 was a little
tender true but I thought maybe you want
to keep the E file open yeah Pawn takes
C5
okay I think the position is totally
decent for white actually I really don't
like the prospect of black giving up is
darks were Bishop unless it's for a
really good reason and I don't think
this really qualifies as such a good
reason
you see what I'm saying I 100 see what
you're saying so what is that
yeah well I was just trying to go 95. so
what does Magnus have in the works here
that's the big question because H6 was
completely unprovoked and for Abdus
atarov e takes D5 it changes the nature
of the position but it's also quite
forcing and maybe he doesn't want to you
know liquidate to a position he may feel
that Magnus will hold without difficulty
but I do think it gives white the best
chances but I think this position is
sufficiently unbalanced and it's also
completely forced I mean they are very
likely to get this position if in fact
Notre back takes on D5 and guess what
there's ideas to go E6 the pawn on H6 uh
is still quite loose the pawn on F7
could get loose if white shifts The Rook
to F1 the knight from V3 has a lot of
prospect in the center it can shift back
to D2 and then jump forward again to C4
the dream square of course is indeed E5
uh so I kind of like the look of e takes
D5 offense gives Notre back practical
chances we're not talking about
objective Advantage I have no doubt the
position objectively speaking is equal
but you don't have to ask the respect
Prodigy twice he is going directly for
the Robert Hess approach and last thing
I'll say Robert Carlson's move H6 it's
almost like the roof is falling off of
the house you know and the water heater
isn't working and he's working on a tiny
section of the wall that has some
discoloration like I would have expected
him to fix the major problems in the
center but instead he tries to take care
of his Corner pot all he was doing done
was make sure the TV still worked how
could you blame him that's who cares
about the rest of the TV yeah there you
go H6 is irrelevant here but H6 is a
pawn that might be captured at some
point and look at this kind of blockade
that he has set up he does not want to
allow white to ever push the pawn E6 he
plays Queen E6 himself and now Queen
takes H6 is not so good because the G4
Pawn can still be captured or Rook h8
first so I think that he's making
Novak's life
difficult even though the position
seemed to be improving from G5 for black
is the next turn
let me push back a little bit and ask
you what happens after Queen takes H6 so
you want to take on G4 straight away or
you want to throw in Rook Hade I get
that the evil bar is laughing at me I'm
used to it um I'll play rookie changed
sure my idea was to meet Queen takes G4
I really think a lot of white success
hinges on his ability to play six but
maybe after F6 c66 the point is that
there's simply no follow-up
I don't know and and C4 there's always
night before which is very important
defending the bishop
yeah so I guess this is just unclear and
black isn't even obligated to take on E6
well I could play the move F5 to keep
the Integrity of his Pawn structure so
okay I I stand corrected
um E6 is just not as impressive uh as it
may appear in some positions
yeah it's just an interesting moment I
mean queen E6 allows for G5 it also kind
of threatens your A5 A4 idea because A2
is loose and with the Knight hopping
over to B4 eventually that could be a
serious problem for white to deal with
so Queen G3 is abdusitaro's decision he
wants to avoid G5 with Tempo he's taking
control of the F4 square but shouldn't
black just now trade pieces like night
before anyway yeah looks pretty good
yeah given the match situation I think
Knight before is almost automatic here
once the Bishops are off the board uh
especially if the Knight can reroute
itself to D4 if the knights are also
withdrawn from the board and traded I
don't think the Magna should have any
problems holding his own in that
position if I had to choose the side I'd
probably still choose white just by a
smidge because of the benefits of having
this pawn and E5 and claiming the small
space Advantage but you know the world
champion just doesn't really lose uh
these types of positions like ever he
doesn't lose simple positions
no it's there's not enough play really
not enough to be a struggle and we are
17 moves into the game so uh black 17th
move about to happen they need to reach
move 30 before they get the extra five
minutes and the 30 second increments so
magnus's clock could be an issue for him
if he doesn't start making moves a
little bit more quickly he may find
himself struggling to get to move 30.
and he takes uh the same approach that
we discussed but the night shifting back
to C7 and the idea is totally
unequivocal after the trade of Bishops
he wants to vacate the E6 Square for the
night that's a nice blockading square
that night from the center contesting
the D4 Square just sort of stabilizing
the whole position and the principle of
two weaknesses comes into play could say
well look at this F7 Pawn that's a
backward Pawn black has sufficient
resources to defend this one weakness
and there are zero other Targets in
Black's position
that square for the night is common in
many different Sicilians so
um this Knight rerouting itself into
Russell limo the most notable time that
happens and yeah it's the night is such
a good block hater because it peers over
the pawn so it's stopping the pawn from
pushing and looks to the F4 and D4
squares it might jump there eventually I
see you highlighting C5 to C4 that is a
push that I don't think uh White really
wants to deal with but black is spoiled
for Choice with Queen side play
yeah I mean white can prevent C4 by
moving The Rook up to E4 maybe slide him
the other Rook over to F1
I think at some point white should put
at least one of the Rooks on F1 uh to at
least aim at the only serious Target in
Black's position
but again an evil bar is showing a small
Advantage for white but I'm feeling very
pessimistic about motorbike's chances
I think that's a good move though it's a
good start for him in his attempt to
even up this match because it just
prevents some of Black's ideas and 96
what's Black's next move down here
what's magnus's actual plan well I
wouldn't rule out A5 although at this
point you might argue that you now have
A4 to fix the weaknesses on the queen
side or maybe you'll say that A4
isn't that scary anymore oh maybe I
should let you talk so I'll find out
what you have to say you have to say
about A5 no I was enjoying what you were
saying so A5 it doesn't feel that scary
but if you can carve out the D4 Square
for your knight then yeah I'm with you
A5 A4 but G5 giving him the F4 Square
that's what Magnus wants that Knight on
E6 is super strong where it sits and I
don't see a plant for white actually
oh and after H5 if you play Knight F4
you're already carrying this massive
threat of Queen takes E4 and that threat
is not addressed by a move like Knight
D2 because the problem is that there is
a fork on E2 and that actually just wins
the queen back
so that's not an option white would
probably have to move the queen you
can't move the king either because if
Queen takes C4
so are we going to see this on the board
H5 has been played pretty nasty Fork
idea that you just showed there uh the
E2 Square needs to be covered and in
Knight F4 seems
I kind of like your A5 idea I know I was
saying it doesn't seem as threatening
but I don't really believe that white
wants to play A4 himself
right because A5 A4 like if you just put
that on the board for a sec yeah yeah
then you can even play Knight D4
and already you're threatening not just
this queen sack on e4 winning the queen
back on G3 but the A4 Pawn is loose
that's exactly right and the B6 Pawn yes
it's a cosmetic weakness but it's so
close to Black territory inside of the
word it's totally unattackable so when
you're evaluating weaknesses it's not
just about the sort of academic
definition oh this is a backward Pawn
you always have to ask yourself but can
this weakness actually be attacked in
the near or distant future and Knight f4
on the board Magnus refraining from
pushing that a pawn for the time being
just trying to stay as flexible as
possible I think he's just saying hey
Notre back how are you going to make
progress the position totally locked up
black has all of his bases covered I
refuse to believe that black is worse
here I don't care what the Evo Bar says
yeah what is White's plan Rook fd8
magnus's move and where is Northern back
going he needs his Knight involved so I
see the argument for Knight D2 but it
actually blunders in the spot right
Knight D2 is met by Knight
brutal bang bang bang
and the Knight on D2 is lost
you can play Knight F3 there
but yeah your king is in trouble
King C2
Queen E4 no no I'm just blundered the
queen over there no you're distracting
The Rook so that the Bishop from h no
okay there's no Bishop on H7
okay well I guess Queen D5 is the move
uh simple and strong don't need to take
anything don't even give a check
sometimes the threat is strong in the
execution as they like to say don't
worry Chad didn't hear you we're just
gonna pretend
I appreciate it briefly possessed by the
spirit of a beginner
I just wanted to be honest with
everybody from the very beginning I
would let everyone know that I'm
transparent and letting
my mistakes be shown for the world to
laugh at it's very admirable you're
gonna bring me to tears with this level
of honesty
I mean F2 played
okay Queen F2 what's the idea
something juvenile like Rook C7 I take
C5 I wonder if Carlson would see the
threat after Rook C4
probably not have a queen E6 here for
Magnus can you just go after the G4 Pawn
yeah that's a lovely move maybe white
will slide back up to F3 then okay
protecting and threatening on the
diagonal I see you and I'm hoping for
this move Rook takes that four
but at this point white is sort of
relying on these one move threats and as
long as black side steps the the prosaic
traps and tricks
again it all comes back to the fact that
black has all of his bases covered where
are the targets and how do you attack
them
there are none
yeah that felt like a rhetorical
question which is why I wasn't going to
answer regardless well I answered it
myself I appreciate it I appreciate it
but it just I think we're both saying
that with this stronghold of the F4
score that Outpost
I don't see how black could possibly
worse there's not something to attack
the files are closed you know Rook D5
just protecting C5 preemptively that
Queen can Shuffle around from E6 to C6
later if it wants the black king can go
to the corner King B8 I just
what's the plan how does white win this
position it's not like wise position is
bad but Abdus needs to win and in
another Universe if they had this in a
classical game and this could very well
be confused at this point for a position
that comes from there's not a single
element of the position that stems or
directly resembles something out of fish
or random if Carlson had this entire
steal he would be playing for a win with
black I think he'll co-sign this point
he would not just be shuffling his
pieces back and forth if anybody has an
active plan it actually might be black
maybe I'm overstating the case here but
Carlson is going to draw this from a
position of strength
yeah and I mean he might win this game
because at some point has to go all in a
draw is a loss so uh just like Magnus
lost game of four to yonda panchi it was
the same as drawing at that point and
all right let me try to think of
something anything all right I thought I
don't see a plan for white you need to
break through you need to create tension
between pawns the knight in F4 upon G5
configuration is too powerful
no this is just and sacking The Exchange
is totally out of the question because
that doesn't actually do anything it's
like oh you open the fo congrats
I can defend F7 very easily
mighty one but okay
I like your arm of Queen E6
oh look at how quickly Carlson's playing
Rook D4 seizing the opportunity to trade
Rooks and white cannot refuse
you just showed nothing exactly what was
wrong with his last move the Knight was
covering that square it goes back to C1
and he immediately takes advantage of
the knights Retreat and if you just say
all right I'll go back Knight B3 then
we'll start swapping pieces and I just
don't know where the wind is going to
come from
there is no Queen E4 just show that
there's no back rank mate yeah that's an
important point because of Knight C1 and
sometimes if the White Queen were to be
on G3 here you would have Rook take C1
and 92 here the queen covers E2 so no
need for shenanigans C4 doesn't work for
the same exact reason but this is all
unnecessary Queenie six is fine
still our old friend A5 could very well
make an appearance and to add insult to
injury notorbeck is imperceptibly now
down three minutes on the clock the time
was even Carlson was down all of a
sudden it's notabeck uh who is
burning into the remainder of his clock
time I think the Uzbek youngster's days
in this tournament
are coming to an end well so are
magnuses but that's the wrong way to put
it everybody's days in this tournament
are coming tonight but you know what I
mean they have no choice this will be
the last day that they play in the
Fisher random Championship but Euro stop
making these wild conjectures and
spreading conspiracy theories where are
you getting all this information don't
you put that on me but right now I think
that Magnus wants to play Queen G2 to
try to trade Queens he will be concerned
about his Pawn on F7 that is hanging
after the Queens are swapped but G4
Falls that gets a pass Pawn white gets
some past pawns maybe it's messier than
you would want
but I think you're absolutely right now
I think Queen G2 is incredibly strong so
first of all here you could actually
defend D7 if you so desired with King D7
Queen G2 is on the board great call by
you and you might say but wait a second
Rook H7 Rook takes the forward takes H6
I think the big problem for white is the
total passivity of his Knight black
could drop the Knight back to F4 this is
the simplest move and there is a massive
threat of Rook q1 there is no way that
black is losing this game black is
actually winning it just by pushing the
pawn to G4 and G3 and G2 the pawn 100
becomes a queen there's hardly anything
that white can just stop it and black
can easily stop white spawn this is the
problem when you play without a piece
the Knight on C1 is not helping out in
the position so Queen G2 played if you
play Queen E1 just to avoid the queen
trade you're going in the wrong
direction and after that move G4 can be
captured just steal all the Pawns of the
king size G4 and then H5 and Black's
king is not in any danger
and I have to give a lot of credit to
Magnus for the way that he has handled
these last three games he's not playing
a pushover he loses the first game in
the kind of uncharacteristic style that
has cost him a lot of games this
tournament and it would have been easy
to lose motivation it really would have
been easy to tilt the rest of the match
but Magnus got himself together and he
did what world champions do no he's not
playing for first place but yes he's
playing for additional money and yes
he's playing for pride and Magnus puts
pride in the way that he plays
regardless of what's on the line I think
a lot of people have to realize that and
I'm impressed I'm really impressed with
the way that he's handled these last
three games
Great Signs from the world champion
after an initial loss he was
disappointed he saw him as overlooking
these tactics and we usually call it
uncharacteristic but it has been
characteristic of this tournament
against Hikaru Nakamura blundered a rook
against Vladimir feloussev simply
dropped in exchange against Abdul
sitarov in game one of this match
overlooking tactics whereas King was in
trouble so Magnus I mean he hasn't been
the Magnus from
well really just before this tournament
like the Megs that we know just kind of
beats everybody but Fisher random is a
different variant it might cause you
some headaches and confusion yeah I
don't think Max is confused right now he
knows he's gonna lock up third place in
the 55 000 dollars
and one aspect of Chess discourse that I
don't quite like as much is the sort of
reactive uh period of discussion that
ensues after let's say a bad tournament
by the world champion where the
questions begin is he in a slug is he
passed this Prime you know what's going
on it reminds me of this article I saw
on my NBA team the Golden State Warriors
who won the championship last year
they've played four games and they were
two and two two wins two losses and the
article's title was something like
what's wrong with the Golden State
Warriors what's going on relax they
played four games Magnus had one bad
event he had a shaky event prior to that
in AIM chess I was able to play him in
that tournament uh but this is way too
small of a sample size and the fact that
Magnus has arguably you know one of his
worst tournament performances in recent
memory and still comes in second place
or I guess in third place third place
it's still pretty ridiculous when you
think about it like this is like the
lowest of the low and Magnus still gets
third
that is how strong he is B4 played by
Abdus atarov I think Magnus just take
that pawn and not only is you know Rook
G1 pinning that night before it could be
some Checkmate configurations helped by
that pawn being on B4 for black so C
takes B4 seems like a pretty good move
but he might have them more precise as
you're highlighting Rook G1 G4 G3 G2 and
get a new Queen yeah I would definitely
Lobby for the immediate Rook G1 I simply
think that once the pawn reaches G2 uh
that defense uh goes to the Knight and
then the Rook is free to roam about the
cabin move away from G1 it's the classic
mechanism and White's H1 is going to be
too slow so Magnus both for Choice here
uh I wanna quick quickly update the
viewers on the other two matches we
don't have to go to the games but
Vladimir freto save is knocking on the
door of a victory against Wesley so he
won the previous game with black and
with the white pieces he has virtually
an unusable position that would be a
huge final round of it win for Vladimir
fedesev and Matthias bluebound similarly
I think is on the cusp of defeating
Yoruba gretzerson for the final spot
okay so seventh place for blue bomb
fifth place for federusev is likely and
here we see no Rebecca on camera the
world rapid Champion he is faced with
this move Rook G1 done good call there
and for him like 92 is a threat so he
brings his King up to B2 but gp4 G3
you wanna do it together
you know it's that game where you it's
best played with a bunch of people where
you have to go through the entire
alphabet but two people can't say the
same letter at a time
no never played that game I have um
that's actually a really fun game we
should do it sometime maybe during the
coverage no I I'm gonna not do that and
instead pretend like I have but we've
reached past the time Patrol it's moved
34 B65 played and I think Magnus there
he goes he doesn't care about anything
captures
I don't care get off me he's gonna go
King C7 and then he's gonna go G2 and
Knight D4 what's funny is that Knight D4
actually creates a made threat so he had
to calculate this accurately here here
here if you just play any Rook move you
get checkmated in two moves but Magnus
saw the move Rook V1 check and not only
does this promote with Tempo but the
Rook covers the B5 Square so King A3 is
futile and King takes B1 this is check
this is a fork and I think this is how
the game is very likely to end yeah
because the alternatives are way too
obvious If instead of the Knight going
out if you play Rook somewhere rookie
shade and then G2 and play Rook G8 like
yes I stopped your Pawn you remember
that 9 F4 is protecting the G2 Square so
The Rook just gets out of the Pawn's way
the path is cleared and then width
apology two and The Rook sliding over to
H1 you simply get a queen next turn so
there's no chance here for busitarov I
can show this line here very important
in this position to avoid the temptation
to play like Rook takes you one that's
actually a horrendous move because the
Knight won't be able to stop the h-bond
in the end no no no you want to keep
your Rook you want to just slide it over
to H1 Notre back one final try Rook G6
oh that's a nice move but it ain't gonna
cut it you can just go G2
you can go G2 you can even take the Rook
it's actually
one beautiful well no no if you take a
C1 and there's oh yeah actually guess
that does work
what were you thinking I just thought
slime work anywhere like Rook F1 or
rookie Rook E1 sorry to stop 92.
oh but I think this is better because
you're doing the same thing but you're
winning the night no yeah no completely
actually rookie one might lose I I'm I'm
yeah yeah I go G7 and E1 you think oh I
stopped everything there's some 92.
wait but I don't understand why not G7
G2
uh then 92 yeah
all right oh I see what you're saying
wow
no this doesn't work I go G1 oh my God I
give up it's been way too late we need
to abandon this line this line is not
we're not going down the right yeah
that's okay it's okay I saw it forgiven
precisely zero good moves in that one
um just just letting everybody know not
using the engine over here
that's okay I wanted to make that as
clear as possible it's been a long day
and the day is not over for those just
joining us the final between Yonder
promise and Hikaru Nakamura has ended in
a 2-2 tie and no they are not gonna
share first place they are going to play
it out in an Armageddon game that will
be contested after the other consolation
matches are over and it seems by the
looks of it that we won't have any other
Armageddon to play
what
it ain't over yet Magnus I think this
was the final move of the game rookie
one played
is there any reason for Notre back to
keep going
no because once black gets the queen The
Rook will slide behind the h-bawn and
stop it in its tracks so Magnus Carlsen
he is going to take this one home and
for Norbit abusotarev it's going to be a
disappointing finish the way he
obliterated his group that consisted of
yonda palmishi and Wesley so and here
overstein gretcherson and then to come
to the semifinals lose three nil beat
Magnus in game one and then lose three
straight games to him it just it feels
like a disappointment even though if you
take a step back it was a successful
event
it absolutely was and again we can't
repeat the cliche enough he's still 18
he's young he's going to acquire
consistency we know what he is capable
of as he extends his hand and resigns
the game we know what he is capable of
when he is in top form we saw that in
the preliminary group we saw that in the
Olympiad he's proven himself time and
time again and as the years go by and he
gains experience playing with the top
guys he's gonna be more consistent and
he's going to only become more
terrifying as that experience shines
through and makes him even stronger and
even more consistent
absolutely so we will see more from
nurture of not in this event the only
people we're going to see more from are
Hikaru Nakamura and Jan napomnushi they
are tied two to two after a pretty
topsy-turvy match game four they agreed
to a draw gives them a chance to get a
break relax those nerves they must have
the Jitters but when we return the
position will be revealed the players
will get set and then the title for
Fisher ran World Championship will be up
for grabs so we're gonna take this quick
break we want to shout out to our
sponsor Brave helping us present this
coverage and we return the finale of the
Fisher random World Championship
one for my life okay
what's up man hey just solving some
puzzles
get my coffee
oh shoot
which one is that is that our new one
yeah
I can't get this one man
oh shoot
what's wrong with you man
this is hard
you sure you're feeling okay
uh one got it oh shoot
thank you
95
1
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
and we are back here at the Fisher
random World Championship matches for
fifth place and Seventh Place still
ongoing you see Wesley so studying the
position against Vladimir fedrosev
fedexev needs just a draw to move on but
look at Wesley with the black pieces he
is trying to earn a chance at Armageddon
and a tie break to get the fifth place
prize but on behalf of chess.com I'm
Grandmaster Robert Hess with Grandmaster
Daniel daradiski we are excited by all
chess but we will keep our focus on the
Armageddon matchup between Hikaru
Nakamura and Jana pomsi after these
matches are done the bids are going to
be made the players gonna get set but
that only can happen once these games
finish
yeah and it seemed to be a sure-fire
victory for Vladimir felicev in the
match it was a totally symmetrical
position which only white could win of
course fedes doesn't need to win he
needed a draw but a shocking series of
blunders has led to the position in
front of you black is up a pawn but more
importantly the pawn on e4 is collapsing
Vladimir to say of doing what he can to
create threats against Black's King but
it appears that this match will
similarly go into on Armageddon barring
another miracle here
yes the queen on h8 saves the day
because
there is a background Checkmate but yeah
the Knight is under attack and if it
moves D6 Falls so this is not an easy
situation for Wesley so despite having
an advantage Knight F6 might be met by
almost like Bishop H4 at some point not
yet because the queen can actually
capture it but the point is that there
are threats in the position that black
guys be careful what what no
no there's no way you played that
he he played it
he blunders the knight in one move
and
he wants queen C5 check and then take on
C4 with check but Bishop how are you
expecting to win that
I don't expect him to win it I'm just
saying what he might have been going for
what I'm saying that just look at
Federal save though he can take a knight
on e4 he has about two minutes on his
clock he is making sure that's the best
move there could be an argument on you
for Bishop Bishop
because Queen D7 is only one check and
the King goes over to A5 I there's not
just an argument I think you might be
right this might be the way for white to
get an advantage which is crazy
absolutely crazy and look at this line
after Knight C5 if white wants to draw
take a page out of feather save Carlson
takes takes Queen
oh no no say what am I saying there's a
T-bone Robert it's been a really long
day I'm sorry no I'm glad that you know
you're just making me look better that's
why you did I know but you're trying to
go for a stale mate trick oh my god when
the D5 Pawn is free what happened oh it
doesn't work oh I saw such an
interesting trick I was thinking D6 F3
okay here white is winning but I was
like thinking Queen E8 and D7 almost
leads to a draw but unfortunately of
course black doesn't have to take the
pawn black and just like we did and you
have these darn squares on this diagonal
anyway sorry to go down the rabbit hole
Bishop before has been indeed played and
Vladimir friendship I think is gonna
pull off the ridiculous comeback and
hold at least a draw yeah this actually
just looks terrible for black you're up
on two pawns if you're Wesley so but D6
drops then E5 will fall as well and your
King on B8 it's not any safer in a in
fact it'll probably just get checkmated
along the a file so this is really bad
news for Wesley so he is actually you
know the previous Fisher random world
champion in 2019 he beat Magnus Carlson
and he did so quite soundly it was a
one-sided match but fedo save he has
been a force online for years and during
the pandemic and the surge in online
chess he's become a household name
somebody who's always there to take care
of business and people forget that he
while he's had a bit of a downturn in
his classical career in the last couple
of years at his speak he was 27 30. I
mean the guy is knocking on the door
of you know the top of the top I have no
doubt in my mind that he will return to
the 2700 Club in short order and he
keeps proving time and time again
especially in the rapid and Blitz format
that there is a reason he is always
playing on equal terms and sometimes
even on better terms with these top guys
and what a disappointing performance it
is for Wesley so all Vladimir fedexev
has to do is I think make the move yeah
Queen F6 is good enough
and okay I think Wesley is just going to
resign here this game turns into Pac-Man
like E5 Falls then F4 Falls C5 is going
to be loose just grab everything there's
nothing that anyone can do to stop it no
matter if you're over human
and the worst thing is that Vladimir
doesn't even need a win he is going to
get a win
and he's going to get one perhaps not
even by capturing any of the pawns but
by promoting his deepon Queen C70 6078
resign
yeah that's over
yeah Queen C7 is game
okay very simple the pawn is ushered to
the other side and Wesley that's it
queens that might even just throw in the
towel he does and he does Vladimir
fetusaev gets fifth place and what that
means is that there's only one
Armageddon game we thought that for a
second we're gonna have Federal say of
Wesley so as well that means for real
this time we can focus our attention
only on Nakamura Napoli and this game is
over better say of you know he concludes
a successful event he qualified from the
online events on chess.com
he did and what a successful performance
of course he was hoping to qualify into
the finals he has very high standards
for himself but to defeat Wesley so in
the final consolation match to claim
fifth place really below you know the
top guys the nepos and the Carlsons it's
an impressive performance we
congratulate him heartily and finally
Matthias bluebaum the German Grandmaster
has indeed defeated fiorvar greterson to
claim the penultimate spot also an
impressive Victory not the kind of
performance he was looking for but blue
bomb just lacks a little bit of that
consistency a little bit of that Pizzazz
but I'm sure that this is an experience
that he's going to cherish for a
lifetime as we see better save and so
all smiles they're on friendly terms the
tournament is over
and Wesley very graciously analyzing the
game with
veloda
but yeah all eyes on Carlson on Hikaru
nepo well Vladimir should be very happy
fifth place finished here at the Fisher
random World Championship you know he
was not guaranteed Wesley so knew he was
playing in this event because he is the
previous Champion so Vladimir had to
fight through a gauntlet of a field in
the online qualifier and then he had to
get through his group stage he didn't
make it out to the semis because Magnus
and a car were there but still success
for better sale and as we see the final
scores from the third place matchup
Magnus Carlson is in third Notre back
abusarman fourth Vladimir federusev
takes fifth while Wesley so is in Sixth
and then Matthias bluebound he wins
three to one over eighth place finisher
jorva Stein bretterson so Iceland's
number one finishes eighth in this very
very tough field so let's now move on to
the Armageddon that's what's about to
happen that's what everybody wants to
hear about and the format of the Fisher
random are again consists of a bidding
system so
we don't know yet if Hikaru or if Yan
will get the whiter black pieces but
white will get a Time Advantage based on
the bids but we'll have to win the game
so that is why uh players like to choose
black they only need to draw now Dania
Fisher random is different
it's a totally different variant I feel
like having a Time disadvantage and draw
odds not quite as meaningful as it is in
a standard game
not quite as meaningful meaningful in
the sense that you mean it is more
advantageous to the side withdraw odds
or the side playing against rods I would
rather benefit I would rather have the
white pieces and more time
actually kind of disagree so I have
played Fisher random Armageddon once
when I play the qualifier for this
tournament fortunately I didn't get in
but I did manage to win an Armageddon
game with black I definitely felt the
time deficit and I think one of the
reasons you might be saying what you're
saying is that you need all of the time
you can get to get the hang of the
position to adjust to whatever unique
opening your opponent is playing but on
the other hand I would offer the
argument that the just concept of
playing white as we've discussed by now
many times is less meaningful right
white black the position is often so
unbalanced that you have no idea who's
better out of the opening so from that
perspective I think playing Black really
isn't a disadvantage at all so you're
really only dealing with the clock
disadvantage
and that's where my concern comes in is
I'm with you I don't care about first
move Advantage I don't even think there
is one because nobody knows what to do
they're all scrambling for ideas and
that's what happens after the bid
they'll get only five minutes to look at
the position so I don't care about
having the white pieces in first move
it's just the clock and without
increment I feel like
you know the time Advantage is very real
and with the speed that Jan and acara
play with that's why I'd be worried to
say have six minutes to somebody's 10.
that's where I start getting worried
about so the humor there I think the uh
is getting set up in the lobby I think
the players are about to make their bids
the one clarification that I have is to
determine how much time white starts
with so the sides bid but is it 25
minutes or is it 15 minutes let's see if
we can find that out how much time does
the player with the white pieces have
and remember that white always has the
same amount of time just because they
let's say yon bids 11 minutes and Hikaru
bids 12 minutes the player with the
lower bid gets the time that they bid in
the black thesis but the player who bid
the higher amount they don't get that
amount of time they get a set number of
minutes the bidding is just to determine
who has the black pieces the side of the
lower bit has black the side or the
higher bit has white and a set number of
minutes regardless of what they actually
bid
okay well we see they're big 15 minutes
I was right placing envelopes yes 15
minutes for the player who gets the
white pieces so you know if I were
making a bid right now I think that I
would go no lower than something like
11 minutes I already feel like yep
that's cutting it a bit close it really
is because there's no increment and this
is perhaps the most important change
there is no increment after move 30. the
main tournament time control was a five
second increment after move 30. there's
no time addition there's no increment do
not pass go do not collect 200 flagging
is very much in the mix we might see a
sloppy time scramble at the end of the
game which is why you don't want to miss
this
I completely agree Robert in the context
of an OTB game I am probably not even
going lower than 12 to be completely
honest with especially when you're
playing Hikaru
right no pre-moves you have to be very
careful with what your bid is the
players are walking around it looks like
the Arbiter is talking them through this
oh we have audio so let's listen yeah
well it seems like we had uh somebody
talking not in English so I couldn't
understand what they were saying but
hakar was asking some questions as well
so it's uh seems a bit chaotic there uh
probably not expecting Armageddon but
that is where we are and Chaos will
ensue maybe on the board as well so I'm
just curious who is going to have the
white pieces what the time situation is
going to be and they're actually
revealing the position right now so
let's check in on the peace placement
then a bishop on A1 a rook on B1 King on
C1
Rook on D1 so castling kingside will be
very interesting in this one yeah
Knights
bunched up together and the Bishops in
the corners okay this is a really good
Fisher random position this is a rich
position and I love the fact that the
players only have five minutes to study
this because the whole point of the
Armageddon is that they are supposed to
think on their feet you want to minimize
the effect of preparation and there goes
Mr napomnishy determination on his face
he Carlo a little bit in front of him
and just lovely camera work there we
have the position
have the players already bid or are they
now that's what I'm trying to figure out
so maybe we will take a break and when
we return we'll have all of that
information that seemed like you know
the uh players would love to know that
want to know their times and they have
the position so they're going to study
that we're gonna take this short break
and win return it's Armageddon time
Nakamura to Palm should here for the
Fisher random world champion title this
coverage brought to you by Brave
the only thing better than chess is more
chess so don't miss a moment of the
Fisher random World Championship or the
women's candidates we will be Squad
streaming both events so you don't have
to pick just one simply click this
button at the bottom of our streaming
panel to watch multiple events at once
click again to switch back to a single
screen don't miss a moment of top level
chess with Squad streaming on twitch.tv
chess
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
there are the two players they are
fighting for first place It's a 65 000
difference if Yana palmistry can at
minimum make address where in this game
right here the Pod pushed to F5 lots of
tension in the center and again the
position is entirely symmetrical copycat
approach adopted by both players now
nepo has 13 minutes he started with 13
minutes he car with 15 minutes draw odds
for black so if the game ends in a draw
Yanda palmnushi wins the Fisher random
World Championship there is 65 000 on
the clock and their essential tension to
explore he takes F5 by Hikaru and Robert
both Bishops are currently hanging at
the same time which one of them does
Jana Pandey capture is he already worse
looks like it because right now it's an
extra Pawn if we freeze seven pawns for
white six for black so each one is
hanging because of the bishop stare down
and the bishop on E5 is also under
attack so I feel like I would take on
oh H1 he's the question for me
thankfully
and we're gonna get opposite colored
Bishops now Hikaru with an important
decision about what he takes on E5 with
I would not automatically take with the
bishop in fact taking with the queen
might result in a clearly better end
game I think white is better in both
cases
what do you think he takes with
I think if he wants winning chances I
feel like taking with the bishop makes a
little bit more sense just because you
want to keep the Queens on the board and
Hikaru still is ahead on the clock by a
couple minutes just like the start 13
minutes what nepo started with but the
presence of opposite color Bishops
should make Jan feel pretty good in the
early stages here yeah regardless of his
damaged kingside positive structure and
it will be damaged after he takes on F5
this the queen side structure is totally
symmetrical APA solar Bishops this is
beginning to look a little bit on the
uncomfortably drawer side for Hikaru and
I think that is why Nakamura is spending
as long as he is making the decision
about what to recapture with Robert one
of the motivations behind taking with a
queen is that after the trade and
Blacklist you have I'll try not to make
too many moves on the board so we can
follow the live position white can jump
out to E3 and if white wins the F5 Pawn
then you would agree white will generate
significant winning chances but that's
much easier said than done
for sure especially because there's a
light score Bishop that will venture
back toward the center the knights will
get out I do feel like hikar has a clear
Advantage here that's undeniable both
players would acknowledge that but
winning chances that's the hard part and
we saw Hikaru looking at the position
with Wesley we saw Jan look at it with
vitsugov you can only prepare for five
minutes so there's not so much you could
predict and in this position Donya the
Kings can still Castle in either
direction what does that look like the
queen has to move out the way and if
you're gonna Castle Queen side you have
to move the D1 Rook first and for the
castle kingside to the queen and the
Knights Justin Bieber King to the other
side of the board your entire Army both
of your horses have to move and only to
Castle to a side where you're already
incredibly weak it's safe to say we
won't have kingside Castle what we might
have is a queen shiny car drops this
bishop back to C3 and this is not some
sort of admission he is trying to trade
on his own terms he's saying listen I
don't mind the queen trade but you're
gonna have to give me the only open file
on the board that is a a major asset for
white and with black sliced off along
the e-file nepo would have had a hard
time defending F5 so he says no we're
trading on my terms and Hikaru says hey
you didn't want the queen trade you're
not getting another chance the Knight is
on E3 can nepo successfully defend this
weakness of his
okay so we see that the queen just slid
out to F2 covering the H2 pawn and in
this position if I'm young up there he
goes he's nice out to age six the live
camera feed a little bit delayed there
but the Knight comes to H6 protecting
the pawn on F5 and later in the game if
Weiss not looking out Knight G4 becomes
an option you're pointing to Bishop G7
done here I think you want to remove the
defender
I'm trying to remove the defender white
has to focus all of his efforts on
winning this F5 Pawn that is the only
target but you could also play this a
little bit more kind of conservatively
gradually you could try to get the G1
Knight out of the gates send it either
to F4 or uh to D4 to hit the bishop and
the F5 font so how is Hikaru going to
manage this pressure on F5 but I like
this opening for yawn also if we look at
the clock the time Advantage has uh
dwindled to something like 40 seconds
yes and that's not good news when you're
needing to win the game and Jana palmchi
he moves at a lightning speed and he has
everything defended now the move Bishop
G7 it's tempting you're trying to win a
pawn but I actually think we've seen in
Fisher random that the players they
prefer the activity over the material
lead you on the Palms in particular how
many times have we seen him jettison
upon here sacrifice one there he did
against Magnus he's done against zakaro
and that's why he cards goes Knight E2
love this must prioritize our
development a rook and slide to F1 Dania
you seem to like it as well I like
ikara's position he's not panicking just
because they're opposite colored Bishops
but neither is Giannis he brings his own
Knight out to E6 and there's Rook F1
Hikaru not mincing his words not hiding
his intentions and nor should he because
there's only one thing that he can
really attack right now and only one
thing that Yan can defend I think we're
gonna see The Rook sliding over to f8
another important consideration Robert
is the clock there is no increment added
after move 30. so times scramble is
entirely possible you have to avoid
getting below a minute any situation
where Hikaru let's say has three minutes
and John has won the car can simply flag
him it doesn't matter what position you
have yacht has to stay relatively even
on the clock and he's doing a good job
of it so far and we just moved D4
threatening of the baby for D5 Bishop
though and Knight Bishop B5 is a good
way to avoid a fork while giving a pain
to your opponent
Knight G4 actually looks very
interesting just removing the defender
of the D5 store I like that most it was
just the plan that we had been drawing
up and Jana Palm she agrees he brings
his Nike to G4 and if you take on G4 F
takes G4 the bishop on C3 looks silly
while the Bishop on C6 looks very
powerful now this is bad news for
Nakamura I think Hikaru might have
forgotten that here he doesn't have the
move D5 any older and here's the
important thing if he takes on F5 you
say I gotcha well John says no you
didn't get any but Queen takes up five
nine out of five and the H DuPont Falls
and this is not an end game that Jan
Napoli is going to lose if anybody is
better it is now black D4 an incredibly
committal move by Nakamura but it was a
panicky move and I think Jan has
punished it effectively Robert am I
overstating the case here by saying that
nepo is already knocking on the door of
a successful result no this is a great
position for young objectively speaking
he has the advantage why because both
sides of isolated pawns on the king side
but G3 seems like an easier Target and
white has to spend another turn bringing
the king out to B2 the bishop on C3 is
blocked by its own Pawn the bishop on C6
stares down the length of diagonal so
I'm loving this position for Jan to Palm
Tree maybe Knight F3 bring the Knight
back first bring your Rook over to f8 as
well just to attack that Knight may
bring your Rook to F2 afterwards I feel
like you're spoiled for choice if you're
nepo whatever he does he has to be
paranoid about falling behind on the
clock and I think he is he realizes that
ikaro is not going to hesitate to flag
him and he continues to play quickly
don't miss the fork on D5 if you're
gonna punishi how is he going to deal
with it you mentioned I think moving the
bishop away and nepo does exactly that
Bishop centralizes on e4 and the knight
from H2 can evacuate back to an even
more active Square on F3 Robert this is
really bad news for Hikaru he has to
find some way of mixing it up
introducing some complexity to start
milking John's clock back down
but yawn just continues to move clearly
Knight to G5 now his Knights will
connect with one another on the F3
Square Bishop on e4 defended upon H7 is
also defended so the good news for car
is he has good squares first pieces
these dark squares are under his control
but he can't actually attack anything so
now we have to win on the clock because
you've seen the time difference at 45
seconds that may not seem like the
biggest deal I guess I jumped ahead now
it's about to be 45 seconds but for
Hikaru Nakamura who's among the quickest
players in the planet there is no shame
at this point if you flag your opponent
you get the world title there is zero
shame in fact it would be ridiculous if
he didn't rely on every Advantage he has
to try to win this game Jan he realizes
it he probably talked through this exact
scenario with Nikita vitukov he's
focusing more on keeping even on the
clock is that necessarily making the
best move and here's that attempt to mix
things up Hikaru pushing the pawn up to
D6 saying here take my Pawn but ruin
your entire structure and give my knight
to C4 Square that's a great practical
decision by Nakamura and Robert how many
times have we seen him successfully
complicate positions that too many of us
will seem unwinnable
oh countless times and Jana pump she
knows that he pushes the pawn to C6
quickly does Nakamura play the moment C4
here comes that Knight to E5 hitting the
D7 Pawn so watch out for rookie seven
watch out for Knight E5 and there we see
Jana Palms you bring his Knight to E4
attacking the bishop on C3 and putting
pressure on the pawn on D6 I love that
move 94. yeah nepo knifing his way into
White's position attacking G3 Hikaru
responding by attacking D7 this is the
pawn that Hikaru has to focus on right
now and nepo has to decide whether to
defend that pawn with a move like can
see it or to start trying to liquidate
by let's say taking White's Bishop
somehow he car is able to keep all of
his pieces under control if black
eliminates the bishop then The Rook
steps up to defend the Knight this is a
really powerful construction by Nakamura
he's suddenly up a minute and a half but
we won't really focus on the clock until
nepo gets down below five minutes he
still has plenty of time to think things
through and just like the arrows you
have on screen black is doing the same
thing if Knight takes F3 from White the
Black Knight and the E4 Knight is
defendable on E8 so there is a ton of
tension down the center here where all
the pieces are just perfectly placed to
defend one another allowing King see it
as a possibility now there are some
tactics that you have to watch out for
because you may want to move your Bishop
no your knight on e4 is hanging so you
just have to look out across the board
1963 was the choice and after King takes
Bishop G4 he wants to defend his
opponent D7 that way the Rook on E1
can't slide over to H1 without dropping
the knight in E5 so for the moment black
has everything under its guard
I don't know if I'm enthralled with the
decision to give up that 94 but I get it
that's what I was saying is hey you've
got these good-looking Knights on F4 and
E5 but my Bishop is a major defensive
asset because it's anchored to the pawn
on D7 and it's incredibly hard to
dislodge from the c8h3 diagonal I think
nepo my Park is Bishop on F5 but Hikaru
is saying I don't care about your Bishop
I care about the E file I'm going to
bring my other Rook to E1 and eventually
once the Knight moves away from E5
there's gonna be a potential Rook
infiltration to E7 I'm going to take a
stronger stance I really really dislike
nepo's decision to take that uh Bishop
on C3 and he might be slipping away from
the ledge here
wow an H5 what a move Rook H1 looks like
it traps the Knight on H2 but look at
the Tactical Vision that's why rookie
one if you just go for a second back if
Rook H1 were played Black had the
resource Rook to H1 actually
I was trying to tell you to play page
one and there's a knight on E5 is pinned
it's pinned you can't take with the
Knight you can't take with a rook
because of the fourth but Rook be one
Hikaru obviously not falling for that
trick and I think what nepo might have
overlooked he might have been relying on
the Move H4 he's saying hey I'm gonna
undermine the Knight on F4 no you're not
Knight takes G4 wins a piece because the
Rook hangs and the very same night can
now take on E3 nepo has lost his mind in
the last couple of moves
I think this is looking really bad for
him all of a sudden how did her do that
it took him like five moves to take a
clearly worse and symmetrical end game
and turn it into basically a winning
position right because if you move the
bishop down goes the H5 Pawn that's an
extra Pawn that a car will play with for
the rest of the game and now it's a
nearly three minute lead on the clock
Nakamura I think there might be drastic
measures here how do you like this
exactly you knew where I was going that
Rook takes I did sacrificing The
Exchange and once the white Rook takes
H4 trying to dislodge the defense of
this Knight on F4 I think that actually
is John's best chance because his next
bunch of moves will be easier not so
many pieces will remain I don't see a
single alternative if you move the
bishop away you drop the pawn on H5 you
cannot keep the status quo and be down
three and a half minutes he has to
gather the guts to take on E5 and play
H4 try the trick Hikaru in the tactics
but with every ticking second his
chances continue to dwindle he's
frittered away both the position and the
favorable time situation Yanda palmnushi
has not been able to keep the tension in
the last couple of moves does he have it
in himself to take on E5 and complicate
the game tactically yes he does and the
game is not over after Rook takes E5 and
the problem for Jan is he goes does that
isn't that rookie eight
Rook E8 Rook F6 I guess he wants I don't
know about this now he's down in
exchange it does make sense though he's
gonna have to D6 Pawn which is the
biggest thorn in his side and for now H5
defended F3 defended the bishop on G4
doing great work covering the entire
board so I don't hate the decision even
though we had a preference I don't
either and we should not forget that
he's not obligated to take on D6 the
idea of playing H4 still persists
especially if White's Rook moves away
from the first rank that pawn lands on
G3 real fast so maybe he cars should
consider playing the more prudent move
Rook H1 and he does and now the effects
of H4 is greatly diminished but maybe
John wants to play it anyway but if H4 I
think it car is going to bring his other
Rook G8 simply the bishop lost his
Defender so Jan takes on D6 all right
and now if a car takes up H5 they can
give me an extra Pawn Rook H6 pins and
wins that night there's no way defend it
so good decision making from both
players right now but Hikaru is now
playing perfectly what the problem is
Hikaru smells blood and we know what
happens when he smells blood he won't
let you go Rook G8 is an excellent move
Knight takes H5 is ready I think Jan's
Last Chance is to send the Rook down a
D2 full send on the queen side take
advantage of the temporary awkwardness
of White's rook and try to go after
White's gang and look at Yanda Palm Desi
fighting tooth and nail exhausting every
resource but it might be too late as his
clock shows four and a half minutes Rook
C2 on the board and Bishop F5 is coming
next what a good move to the Knight on
F3 covers that Rook on D2 so the bishop
can go to F5 to a taxi too he does I
don't care give me the pawn Rook C1
defense and Rook H2 attacking that
Knight and making sure the Black Knight
is free so you better watch out if
you're Hikaru D5 D4 can hit you before
you know it and the King on C3 is out in
the open and this is a strong initiative
by NEPA which is why Hikaru tries to
gain the tempo with Knight G7 attacking
the bishop and the bishop doesn't have
that many good squares anymore along
this diagonal once it was the most
stable piece on the board now it's the
least stable Bishop H7 runs into Rook h8
Bishop G6 walks into a discovery Bishop
B4 just puts the bishop in the middle of
everything and the Knight can travel
around from E8 to D6 I think nepo is on
the cusp of losing this game he needs a
major turnaround he needs a blunder he
needs a gift from the heavens right now
to avoid losing this Armageddon well
here's a major idea for you if Bishop H7
Rook h8 there's C5 followed by Knight D4
you're just carving out that square for
your piece which threads not just the C2
Pawn but a fork on E2 so I think that
there's a chance here for Depo if Hikaru
is gonna hope for a pin the Knight
coming to D4 is the rescue but I'm still
I'm starting to look at the clock my
eyes are pegged to the clock three and a
half minutes for yawn at some point
we'll get to a situation a place where
the objective evaluation won't even
matter as long as the car will keep
pieces on the board he will simply be
able to flag his opponent he is up four
minutes on the clock and yanepo is yeah
Rook H6 that's that's a sign Robert
that's a sign that nepo just doesn't see
any future in his initiative he is now
down a full exchange unless he cover
misses a fork he is going to win this
game
right because there's an extra G Pawn if
that pawn removed I still would favor
hit cars yeah because of the clock so
Hikaru needs to keep up the pace and
come with an idea I think C5 followed by
Knight D4 is the best try he'll have the
Knight on E8 is awkwardly placed but
Rook f8 by Hikaru he wants to play Rook
F4 at some point the Knight can come
back out to F6 things of that nature and
D5 by yawn his last attempt to Anchor
the bishop on e4 the bishop anchors the
night a conga line forms the problem is
that he is down in exchange and White's
King is safer than it has ever been uh
Hikaru still with the challenge of kind
of untangling and coordinating his
pieces and he's trying to do that by
playing Rook F6 vacating and opening up
the pathway for the night to get to D6
how is nepo going to avoid a trade of
either Rooks or minor pieces maybe he's
not so afraid of 96 takes E4 because
he'll just put a Pawn on e4 and if you
can get this G3 Pawn if he could trade
off the pawn on e4 that's about to be
there and the pawn on G3 maybe feels
like I'm down in exchange but I have
chances to hold this one
he most certainly does if he takes G3 I
agree even Knight and three against rook
and three that is a lost position though
and Hikaru says I'm forget Knight and
three versus Zircon 3. you are not
getting my Jeep on the king is too weak
here if black tries Knight H4 you have
this check on G7 it's an Intermezzo and
the other Rook gets into the game and
once that happens I think the game is
over
it was Rook H2 he needs to play C5
followed by Knight D4 that's his biggest
idea in this position and for Hikaru is
there a way to free up that Rook on C1
you're saying rookie six is going after
E4 Pawn that actually looks very
promising because if E4 drops in
favorable way for Hikaru then Jan will
not be able to drum up enough counter
play and he's about to play it and
remember after rookie six rookie two you
can send the other Rook over to H1 and
there is a ladder made thread I think
Rook H1 ends the game I think Rook H1
ends the game here I just don't see a
single chance here for Yan maybe King D7
after Rook H1 or B5 no defending
which move is it at The Rook H1 is there
well verification C2 check is not of the
question but I think you lose the
resulting end game but otherwise E5 B6
to B5 to give your king the B6 Square
great tactical eye by you but B5 I'm
afraid that white will go Rook H to H6 I
will try to eliminate your C Pawn in
order to close down your last source of
shelter the sea the C Pawn along the
sixth rank which gives the king this
Escape Pathway to A5 potentially but
it's not coming fast enough B5 is played
yes Jan plays B5 I think Rook H6 looks
very powerful but that's gonna be better
I think black is B4 check as the only
move just trying to save the black king
by distracting white king
but beef okay he plays a three which is
also good you're just stopping B4
all right and repeat three check check
but the king runs away and now you're in
just died
no Knight comes back to D4 Jan's still
trying to use his remaining pieces
fighting tooth and nail all of the blood
has been spilled here can ikaru put the
finishing touches on this game
yeah before he's gonna go B4 it's mate
oh my goodness it is
come on but B4 check still is good right
because the King goes up to C4 and maybe
make their rookie five Rook C5
yeah that is a mate I think before
forces King D6 but then you win the
Knight Rook D7 Rook H5 B4 ends the game
wow
immediate game Hikaru Nakamura will take
this Armageddon if that's the case and
we'll see hikar on the clock he has so
much extra time oh yeah he's calculating
he's doing the right thing he's not
rushing because he knows the position on
the board is winning he doesn't need to
worry about the clock if you see Hikaru
touch the beep on the Fisher random
World Championship will be over Hikaru
is one move away from 65 000 additional
dollars as well as the title and he's
taking all of the time he needs to take
he doesn't play before he plays Rook D7
the game extends for a couple more moves
but now he plays it it will lead to
Checkmate because if the kid goes up to
C4 you have Rook H5 swinging to C5 with
mate if the King goes back to B6 is Rook
B7 Rook takes A7 and the other Rook
comes here it is Rook HP on the board
Hikaru Nakamura wins the Fisher random
World Championship what a performance
from him he lost game three in the match
game four was a draw off for agritu and
Jana palmchi game only can handle but
when it all is said and done Hikaru
Nakamura stands the top of the world in
Fisher random
that was an insane finale I'll be
totally honest when the queens were off
the board and when Jan found the move
Knight G4 I thought that he basically
had the draw in his pocket it was a
symmetrical position black was flat out
better he wasn't even down on time and
then all of a sudden he carves ability
to build up his piece activity in the
span of three moves and John's decision
to trade that Bishop on C3 that I think
was the initial culprit but the way that
Hikaru punished him the way that he
built up his advantage and then
converted his extra exchange eliminating
all possible counter play that was
Exquisite and that is what we have come
to expect from Hikaru Nakamura in the
last couple of years
for sure and Jana Palms he's walking
away you know he must be disappointed
with how that finish but he was a half
point away from the 150 000 and more
importantly to him the Fisher random
world championship title so hikar
Nakamura being interviewed live there in
Reykjavik Iceland um he has so many fans
around the world Iceland has a huge
history of Chess 50 years ago Bobby
Fischer played Boris sposky there for
the world championship so Iceland
celebrating their new world champion
official random you see a card Nakamura
maybe we can hear him would that be
possible let's see if we can tune in
Maybe
okay we are I guess we're just gonna
look at him tune in but we are seeing
Hikaru answering the question there are
so many of you out there shout out to
everybody watching around the world your
world champion your content creator your
Twitch hero your world champion and
Fisher random Hikaru Nakamura so he is
doing the interview he's gonna make the
rounds but he must be feeling ecstatic
I mean you must be feeling ecstatic you
must be feeling exhausted but he's gonna
have to recover real quick because he is
hopping on Iceland Air Reykjavik to
Toronto in order to participate in the
cgc finals with a another world
championship title under his belt
what an unbelievable performance I mean
just remember that Hikaru did not lose a
single game in the entire event this is
a rapid time control format it's unheard
of to play a tournament like this
without losing and until his third match
game with janapamnushi he went lossless
the entire tournament the form that he
displayed the consistency the opening
preparation the Tactical Vision the
technique he has the whole package he
brings the whole package to every
tournament and that is why Hikaru is
such a nasty opponent and couple that
all of that with his ability to perform
seamlessly and flawlessly Under Pressure
a skill that he has brought to his
twitch stream time and time again and
now a skill that he has used to defeat
janapamnushi here at the Armageddon in
the Fisher random World Championship
2022. and for a young diplomacy It's
Just Another Second Place finish and you
know you know he's going to be
disappointed he played that match versus
Magnus Carlson for the first five games
it felt like you know he had everything
under control he was doing well and then
Magnus ran away with things and here in
the Armageddon tie break Hikaru Nakamura
outlasts him the time difference was not
huge 15 minutes to 13 to start but
you're right done yet there were some
critical moments where Jan had a very
nice position but once Hikaru dug that
pawn into D6 he just was able to
maximize the potential of his pieces and
then it felt like Yana Palm she could
not withstand the pressure
yeah the move D6 move 21 I think that
was the game changer that is where he's
he planted the seed of the turnaround
that would happen a couple of moves
later as we look at the prize layout
everybody is going to come home with at
the very least a decent car that they
can buy Hikaru will have 10 cars that he
can buy big big difference between first
and second place Robert this is going to
be a tough feel for John to swallow I
agree completely he was so close he
defeated the world champion he played
amazing chess all throughout the event
but I remember in Madrid I interviewed
tikar and I asked him whether he feels
like his regular streaming his
participation in as many online events
as he played helps him put in reps and
practice performing under pressure and
he said absolutely he said that without
all the title Tuesdays and the arena
Kings and all of the online events that
he has played he wouldn't have been the
same Hikaru Nakamura that he is under
immense pressure it's like nothing
impacts him and he showed that yet again
today he showed that it's not just an
online phenomenon he is the same exact
Iceman over the board
well he was able to secure this
championship title and he's gonna fly
right on over to Toronto Canada where
the chess.com Global championships
reached its conclusion there are eight
players remaining Hikaru Nakamura is one
of those players five on a carwana
eliminated from the competition which is
good news for us and good news for you
because he is going to be compensating
alongside the rest of the people you see
on the screen so he is the special guest
five hundred thousand dollars of the one
million dollar pot will be handed out in
Toronto and will Hikaru Nakamura make it
a one-two punch first the Fisher random
world champion title will he next win
the chess.com Global Championship that
remains to be seen November 2nd through
7th badanya I mean what in display of
Chess Exquisite technique from ikaru
just when you think like things are
knotted up nothing's gonna happen he
just finds ways to give himself chances
when the position is completely even
everybody who is playing playing him
knows it John's like yeah not an issue
then two moves later like wait what how
how what why it's just Hikaru Nakamura
he wins games
listen uh anybody who says the chest is
not a sport I showed them this I asked
them to look at this broadcast I asked
them to look at these performances I am
sweating all through and I'm 5 000 miles
away sitting in my comfortable cabinet I
can't even imagine how Hikaru and Yan
must be feeling but you say that he wins
games the greatest athletes in the world
are bound together by their ability
regardless of the sport to impose their
will regardless of the circumstances on
the ground whether it's Michael Jordan
playing with the flu playing without a
Supporting Cast winning a key
championship game whether it's Roger
Federer or Rafael Nadal playing through
an injury playing down two sets to zero
and whether it's ikar Nakamura playing
in a worse end game his time Advantage
gone Jana published him more confident
than ever and turning things around in
six moves it's the willpower it's that
desire it's the motivation and it is
this unbelievable ability to perform
Under Pressure that to me is the most
impressive thing of all because even
when I'm playing a title Tuesday game
for third place my throat closes up my
fingers turn into thumbs I can't even
imagine what it must be like playing for
65 000 and no matter who you love who
you support you just have to admit that
this is one of the beautiful things
about Chess these performances and these
just situations where players transcend
everything that seems possible for a
human and perform at the level of a
superhuman
felt like a trademark Hikaru Nakamura
performance this is one for the history
books and we're not just saying that
this is a world championship title it is
all hit card with nakamura's I'm sure he
will celebrate with his huge twitch
Community enjoy it he deserves it he's
gonna fly to Toronto to try to get
another title and add that to his
already illustrious career but on that
note we are going to say goodbye we
appreciate all of the organizational
efforts in Reykjavik Iceland we want to
give shout out to Brave for sponsoring
this broadcast and thank all of you
who've been at home watching throughout
this entire event the final eight
players they took part they fought they
dug deep they gave it their all and when
all said and done Hikaru Nakamura is
your official random world champion so
thank you so much thank you to you
Daniel thank you for joining me for the
ride actually assume it's Toronto buddy
but for now we say goodbye keep enjoying
chess no matter if it's Fisher random or
a standard position bye everybody
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]